foreign
are you ready to dive into the world of
cryptocurrencies and take your knowledge
to new heights then you're in the right
place in this video we present you to a
comprehensive and engaging
cryptocurrency full course brought to
you by simply learn cryptocurrencies
have taken the financial World by storm
and it's crucial to stay ahead of the
curve throughout this course we will
unravel the mystery surrounding
cryptocurrencies and equip you with the
knowledge and tools you need to navigate
this exciting field we'll cover
everything you need to know including
the history and technology behind
cryptocurrencies blockchain fundamentals
popular cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
and ethereum and underlying mechanism
that make them work
but that's not all we'll also delve into
the topics like cryptocurrency mining
wallets and exchanges giving you a
practical insight into how to engage
with cryptocurrencies securely and
efficiently
our expert instructors will guide you
through Hands-On demonstration and real
for examples ensuring that you gain a
comprehensive understanding of this
fascinating domain
in addition we will discuss the impact
of cryptocurrencies on various
Industries and the potential they hold
for the future
you'll discover how cryptocurrencies are
revolutionizing Finance fostering
Innovation and creating new
opportunities for businesses and
individuals alike so why wait let's
embark on this exhilarating adventure
together
but before we dive in if you're looking
to take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field and if you're ready to be
inspired here's a success story that
showcased the incredible potential of
cryptocurrencies I always believe in
upgrading myself upskilling not only
helped me with the knowledgeable s but
also help me to reach New Heights in my
professional career I am currently the
chief technology officer at O3
Technology Solutions New York USA we
serve our clients in the banking finance
and incident sector hi I am
25 plus years of experience in the
information technology domain I work for
large organizations like IBM India Tata
infotech Sunmark assistance Gulf
business machines in Dubai after working
for almost 14 years in Dubai at GBM I
wanted to make a career change
to do that I had to improve my portfolio
that's why I chose to upskill myself and
decided to take professional
certification program in blockchain from
IIT Concord offered by simply learn
after completing the course I was able
to make a complete paradigm shift to my
career to grow to the position of city
world combinational skill sets like
artificial intelligence machine learning
cloud computing and especially
blockchain is the reason my management
thought and the right fit to the
position of CTO the course helped me
understand the end-to-end architecture
side of it which gave me ample knowledge
about program in solidity and
understanding the different blockchain
platforms Technologies and functions
like cryptography cryptocurrency nfts
tokenization decentral finance and
decentralized applications after
completing the course
I'm definitely more confident about
connecting with clients understanding
the problem statements and coming out
with Solutions I'm a fitness Enthusiast
when I was in Dubai I got into fitness
my last 20 kgs of weight in four years
what my fitness journey taught me was
to achieve something in life you need to
keep pushing and improving yourself the
funny thing is that I am a 42. I love to
eat good food so basically my exercise
to eat good food and still stay in shape
the same philosophy applies in
everyone's professional career as well
one needs to keep up Skilling and
continuously
try improving their skill to grow as a
professional I strongly recommend
gaining new skills regularly
to stay relevant and to achieve your
career goals so if you want to explore
more captivating videos like this one
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to stay
updated with the latest content from
Simply learn we are committed to
providing you with high quality
educational material that keeps you
engaged and ahead of the curve meet
Frank and Daniel one day they decide to
go for a trip to Venice they made a
budget list for all their expenses like
residence flight Etc they thought of
making their bookings online from a site
that offered discounts to the first 10
visitors on that day while making their
respective flight bookings Daniel's
transaction failed and he missed the
offer going on on the other hand Frank
paid his share very quickly and easily
and became one of the three Lucky Draw
winners Daniel was surprised and asked
Frank how he could make the transaction
when Daniel himself could not to which
his response was it's simple I used
Bitcoin a type of cryptocurrency
Daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
Frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 By
Satoshi Nakamoto Daniel felt that it
sounds similar to other online payment
options yes what makes it so different
Frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or Central Authority unlike
other payment systems that Banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
Daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit or his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank but on the other hand
cryptocurrency charges almost no or very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
24 7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges on making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account on any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency this is what makes
cryptocurrency different from other
online payment options Daniel was
impressed by cryptocurrency but he
wondered how it works without the
control of an external Authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital Ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system then it is verified and validated
by every node to proceed with the
process of making the transactions the
crypto and cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives now Daniel was
completely aware of the whole technology
and concept behind cryptocurrency and
was influenced by Frank to adopt
cryptocurrency in his daily lifestyle
too he did that by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount
like Daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide due to this
increasing popularity new companies like
metoo and PayPal are coming forward and
investing in cryptocurrency every day in
2018 Malta an Island located in the
Mediterranean Sea south of Italy was
titled blockchain Island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like finance and
okx have already begun to take advantage
of malta's financial incentives and have
moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island since man evolved
currency has been a very important part
of our lives in the cave manner they use
the barter system now the barter system
involves goods and services being
exchanged among each other so now we
have a situation where a caveman is
exchanging seven apples and getting
oranges in return now the barter system
fell out of use because it had some
glaring flaws now these flaws include
having people's requirements coincide
for example say you have five apples and
your friend has five oranges you want
some of its oranges now until and unless
your friend has a requirement for the
apples that you own he'll not be ready
to make in exchange for it there's no
common measure of value now since
there's no common measure in terms of
which value of a commodity can be
expressed there's a problem when you
have to decide how many apples you're
ready to trade for one orange or a mango
not all Goods can be divided or
subdivided for example you can't divide
a live animal into different smaller
units the goods cannot be transported
easily now unlike how model currency
fits in your wallet or your mobile phone
the goods that you own cannot be taken
with you everywhere you go after
realizing that the barter system didn't
work very well currency went through a
few iterations in 110 BC an official
currency was minted in 1250 A.D
gold-plated Florence was introduced and
this was used across Europe and from
1680 to 1980 paper currency gained
widespread popularity and misused across
the world this is how modern currency as
we know it came into existence modern
currency included paper currency and
coins credit cards and digital wallets
for example you have Apple pay Amazon
paytm PayPal and so on all of this was
controlled by Banks and governments now
this means that there was a centralized
regulatory Authority that limited how
paper currency and credit cards worked
now imagine the scenario of doing an
online transaction here you're thanking
your friend for paying for your lunch
and you're saying that you're sending
the money to their account now this
transaction takes place successfully but
there are several ways where this could
have gone wrong there could have been a
technical issue at the bank for example
their systems could have been down the
machines weren't working properly and so
on that means there's a central point of
failure which is the bank the user's
accounts could have gotten hacked for
example there could have been a DDOS
attack or identity theft and so on or
the transfer limits for that account
were exceeded this is why the future of
currency lies with cryptocurrency now
imagine the transaction between two
people in the future one of them has the
Bitcoin app and there's a notification
asking whether they're sure they're
ready to transfer five Bitcoins if yes
processing takes place here we are
authenticating the user's identity
checking whether they have the required
balance to make that transaction and
other things now after that's done the
payment is transferred and the payment
is received all of this happens in a
matter of minutes and is as simple as
that this in turn removes all the
problems of modern banking there's no
limits to the funds you can transfer
your accounts cannot be hacked and
there's no central point of failure now
as of 2018 there's more than 1600
cryptocurrencies available now there are
some popular ones like Bitcoin Litecoin
ethereum and Zed cash and a new
cryptocurrency crops up every single day
now considering how much growth they're
having at the moment there's a good
chance there's plenty more to come in
the upcoming years so what exactly is
cryptocurrency a cryptocurrency is a
digital or virtual currency that is
meant to be a medium of exchange now
cryptocurrency is quite similar to real
world currency just that it does not
have any physical embodiment it also
uses cryptography to work the way it
does now some of the features of
cryptocurrency are that there's a limit
to how many units can exist with Bitcoin
this limit exists at 21 million now
after this no more Bitcoins will be
produced you can easily verify the
transfer of funds now the hashing
algorithms that Bitcoin uses makes it
very easy for users to determine whether
a transaction is valid or not they
operate independent of a bank or a
central Authority they work in a
decentralized manner Now new units can
be added only after certain conditions
are met for example for Bitcoin only
after block has been added to the
blockchain will The Miner be rewarded
with Bitcoins and this is the only way
new Bitcoins can be generated so what
makes cryptocurrency so special firstly
there's little to no transaction costs
now if you use the digital wallet you
know that if you're transferring money
from your wallet to your bank account
you lose some amount of money you have
24 7 access to money you can't just walk
up to your bank at 3am in the morning
and say that you want to withdraw some
money there's no limits on purchases and
withdrawals there's freedom for anyone
to use for example if you're setting up
an account in your bank you need to do
some amount of paperwork and
documentation with cryptocurrencies all
of that can be avoided International
transactions are faster now why
transfers take about half a day to
transfer money from one place to another
but with cryptocurrencies it only takes
a matter of minutes or seconds watch the
crypto in cryptocurrencies crypto refers
to cryptography it's a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure
communication in the presence of third
parties with alien tent now this refers
to third parties who want to steal your
data or want to eavesdrop on your
conversation cryptography uses
computational algorithms like sha-256
which is the hashing algorithm that
Bitcoin uses a public key which is like
a digital identity of the user which he
shares with everyone and a private key
which is a digital signature of the user
which he keeps hidden now let's talk
about a normal Bitcoin transaction first
you have the transaction details now
this details who you want to send it to
and how much Bitcoins you want to send
them then it's passed through a hashing
algorithm for Bitcoin we use the sha-256
algorithm the output that you obtain is
passed through a signature algorithm
with the user's private key now this is
used to uniquely identify the user this
output is then distributed across the
network for people to verify this is
done by using the sender's public key
the people who verify the transaction to
check whether it's valid or not are
known as minus now after this is done
the transaction and several others are
added to the blockchain where it cannot
be changed again if the concepts of
hashing seem a little difficult to you I
would suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the blockchain explain
video so that you can understand better
now the sha-256 algorithm like I told
you earlier looks something like this
now seeing how complicated it looks I'm
sure it's safe to say that the
encryption is very difficult to hack
today we will be focusing on two major
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and ether now
Bitcoin is a digital currency that is
decentralized and works on the
blockchain technology it uses a
peer-to-peer Network to perform
transactions let's talk about ether
ether is a currency that's accepted in
the ethereum network now the ethereum
network uses blockchain technology to
create an open source platform for
building and deploying decentralized
applications now let's talk about the
similarities between Bitcoin and ether
they're the biggest and most valuable
cryptocurrencies in the market right now
both of them use blockchain technology
but there's nothing but a technology
that involves transactions being added
to a container called block and creating
a chain of blocks in which data cannot
be altered currency is mined using a
method called proof of work which is a
form of mathematical puzzle that needs
to be solved before a block can be added
to the blockchain finally these are
widely used across the world now let's
talk about the differences with Bitcoin
it is used to send money to someone this
is very similar to how real life
currency works with ether it is used as
a currency within the ethereum network
although it can be used for real life
transaction actions as well Bitcoin
transactions are manual which means you
have to personally perform these
transactions with ether you have the
option to make these transactions manual
or automatic or programmable which means
that these transactions will take place
when a certain condition has been met
for Bitcoin it takes 10 minutes to
perform a transaction which is the
amount of time it takes for a block to
be added to the blockchain with ether it
takes about 20 seconds to do a
transaction now blockchain is used like
money for real world transactions and
ether is used to power the ethereum
network and power real-life transactions
as well ether is used as fuel within the
ethereum network to power both of these
things now there's a limit to how many
Bitcoins can exist which is 21 million
you're supposed to hit this number by
the year 2140. ether is expected to be
around for a while but not to exceed 100
million units now Bitcoin is used for
transactions involving goods and
services and ether uses blockchain
technology to create a ledger to trigger
a transaction when a certain condition
is met for Bitcoin we use an algorithm
called sha 256 for hash fashion and with
ethereum we use ET hash as of July 23
2018 one Bitcoin equals
7668 for ether it costs 464 dollars now
what's the future of cryptocurrencies
the whole world is clearly divided when
it comes to cryptocurrencies on one side
you have supporters like Bill Gates Al
Gore and Richard Branson who say that
cryptocurrencies are better than regular
currencies on the other side we have
people completely against it people like
Warren Buffet Paul Krugman and Richard
Schiller who are both Nobel Prize
winners in the field of Economics they
call it a Ponzi scheme and means for
criminal activities in the future
there's going to be a conflict between
regulation and anonymity since several
cryptocurrencies have been linked with
terrorist attacks governments would want
to regulate how cryptocurrencies work on
the other hand the main emphasis of
cryptocurrencies is to ensure that their
users are kept Anonymous by the year
2030 cryptocurrencies would occupy 25
percent of national currencies which
means a significant chunk of the world
would start believing in cryptocurrency
as a mode of transaction it's going to
be increasingly accepted by merchants
and customers and it will continue to
have a volatile nature which means
prices will continue to fluctuate like
they have been for the last few years
quickly go through the agenda slide
so first we will have a quick
introduction to what is cryptocurrency
following that we will have a crisp
comparison between coin and token
then we will look into the types of
cryptocurrency
and at the end of the video we will
explore why do we need to have so many
types of cryptocurrency
so let's start the video so the first
thing that we are going to understand is
what is cryptocurrency
now a digital payment system known as
cryptocurrency doesn't rely on banks to
validate transactions peer-to-peer
technology makes it possible for anybody
anywhere to send and receive payments
payments made using cryptocurrencies do
not exist as actual physical coins that
can be transported and exchanged rather
they only exist as digital entries to an
online database that details individual
transactions
now a public Ledger keeps track of all
these cryptocurrency transactions that
involve money transfers digital wallets
are where cryptocurrencies actually
Stone
so now that we know what cryptocurrency
is let's break it down and compare the
two most basic forms of cryptocurrency
that is coin and token now coin and
token of phrases that are regularly used
while talking about cryptocurrencies but
there is a distinction even if they may
sound similar
so maintaining their integrity is
crucial so now let's have a quick look
at the differences
so the first one is a digital coin
functions similarly to traditional
currency and is created on its own
blockchain it can be used as a means of
trade between two parties conducting
business together and a way to store
value Bitcoins and Litecoin are a few
examples of points
on the other hand tokens are much more
versatile than merely digital currency
tokens can be used as a software
application component such as to allow
access to an app confirm identification
or track Goods as they move through a
supply chain
they are generated on top of an existing
blockchain like nfts they can represent
digital art
second is coins require significant
resources and skills to create
themselves whereas tokens are relatively
easy to create
third coins are mostly distributed using
the mining process and tokens are
distributed using icos
coming to the next one coins I used to
store and transfer money on the other
hand tokens are used for various
purposes like security and asset
representation
and the fifth is coins can be validated
by any Merchant who uses them and one
Merchant validates tokens
so now that we have reached the most
crucial part of this video the types of
cryptocurrency let's discuss them one by
one
so despite being used to describe all
varieties of digital or cryptocurrency
the term cryptocurrencies is frequently
used interchangeably with coins they are
frequently considered as such even
though most of them aside from Bitcoin
does not function as a unit of account
or a store of value or a medium of
Exchange
so technically there are eight types of
cryptocurrencies security tokens utility
tokens payment tokens exchange tokens
non-functionable tokens D5 tokens or
decentralized Finance tokens
stable coins asset-backed tokens and
privacy tokens
so let's start with the security tokens
now these cryptocurrencies are
securitized and derived their value from
an external asset that can be sold as
security by Financial regulations as a
result they are utilized to securitize
the tokenization of real estate bonds
stocks rollestine and other currencies
from The Real World to protect user
Investments Financial Regulators must
have a Super Wise and regulate The
Exchange issuance dealings values
tokenization backing and trading of
transactions due to the nature
now security tokens basically stand in
foreign interest a share of stock or
Equity voting rights and a dividend
right in the asset they represent owners
or holders share in the profits made by
the issuers or managerial choices
through security token offerings they
are distributed now they can be used
when investors require immediate
settlement open management Asset
Division or Etc
now security tokens are further divided
into Equity tokens and asset backed
tokens now Equity tokens resemble
conventional stocks in appearance and
operation except that ownership and
transfer are carried out digitally
dividends from managerial and issuer
choices and actions are due to investors
that tokens represent short-term loans
with fixed interest rates
now coming to asset back token these
have an underlying word that is
supported by actual real estate works of
art carbon
credits or Commodities they possess
qualities similar to those of gold
silver oil Etc they can be exchange
extra examples of security tokens are CR
funds B cap and science blockchain
now following security tokens we have
utility tokens
now utility tokens are simply digital
units that reflect a value on the
blockchain and are sometimes thought of
as a coupon or vouchers to put it
another way the token Grant specific
access to a good or service offered by
the token issuer by purchasing the token
a person can acquire access to the
product or service and exchange it for a
specified access value
now the holder does not get ownership
but rather the right to a good a service
with an equivalent value to the token
for instance as long as they own the
token they can access the good
or sell this for a reduced cost or for
free
in some jurisdictions a cryptocurrency
classified as a utility token is exempt
from Financial regulations
now some of the examples of utility
tokens are fun fair basic attention
token brick blog Timmy coin sharing lab
token and Golem
so following this comes payment tokens
now payment tokens are used to transact
directly between buyers and sellers
so uh the products and services on
digital marketplaces as opposed to wire
middlemen as is common in traditional
Banking and finance of course the bulk
of cryptogran season tokens fit within
this category whether they are security
or utility tokens but not all the
utility tokens can also function as
payment tokens
now payment tokens are not Securities
and cannot be purchased as such as a
result they're not considered asset
security subject to financial
regulations they might or might not
ensure holders access to any present or
future goods or services example of
payment tokens Monero ethereum and
Bitcoin
next is non-fungible tokens
now a non-fungible token is a blockchain
based digital certificate of ownership
for a singular non-replaceable item or
one that cannot be traded with another
asset it is created using the same
technology as other types of tokens
still it is primarily used to represent
a work of art images audio video
Collectibles real estate virtual words
memes gifs digital content like post and
tweets
now nft marketplaces like open C rarival
foundation and decentral Lan are where
you may buy and sell them
popularity monetizing Goods royalty
payments whenever their work is sold to
a new user partial ownership of
expensive assets
functioning to raise money creating
memorable moments or preserving
histories for Market motives like
trading and celebrity showing are all
included in this application
now some of the examples of nfts are
Logan Paul's videos clips Twitter
founder Jack dorsey's first tweets nft
every day is the first 5000 days drawing
by my Winkleman better known as people
and several cryptokitties
now following that we have D5 tokens or
we can call decentralized Finance tokens
now decentralized Finance refers to the
financial applications or dabs built on
the blockchain or distributed Ledger
which makes them distributed and those
that run to financial and money control
directly to the user while allowing them
to transact globally with
peers-to-peer's methods and access to
global markets
now anyone with internet access can
access these D5 apps each defy app runs
on a token economy that is supported by
a native token these tokens are a
programmable currency where developer me
are logic to have transaction and
payments are made
Avi chain link uni swap polka dot and
Solana just a few examples of popular
decentralized Finance tokens
now decentralized exchanges storage
sharing and apps for Lending are some
examples of D5 application types
following this we have stable coins
now these tokens are of stable value in
nature as their nature implies meaning
that their value is reasonably
predictable in that it essentially never
changes
stable tokens or stable coins as they
are more commonly known are backed by an
asset with a relatively consistent value
such as cash so we have stable coins
that are pegged to the dollar and the
Euro as well as tokens backed by
Commodities like oil gold and other
precious metals
stablecoins assist in eradicating assets
or even other digital currency in
stability stable coins include paxos and
debtor which are all backed by USD cash
in a one-to-one ratio along with true SD
gemi dollar and USD coin are stable
coins packed by gold keto gold
Global and gold coin
then comes acid-backed tokens
now the term asset back tokens refers to
a class of cryptocurrency
whose underlying value is supported by a
real world asset such as cash stocks
bonds property gold and precious metals
on blockchain they are utilized to
represent and treat the value of these
underlying assets digitally
so due to the way the underlying assets
are used in transactions most of these
are provided as security brokers the
equity token offer is the primary method
of issuing them examples of asset packed
tokens are oil coin which tokenizes
barrels of oil held in reserve petroleum
coin ZN Inc oil token Etc the energy web
token tokenized energy green energy
token by W VPP
Etc are some of its examples
and now comes the last but not the least
that is privacy tokens now these
cryptocurrencies are used for privacy
applications as their name implies
because they have Superior privacy
promoting programming to bitcoin and
other popular cryptocurrencies
better anonymity in crypto transaction
is necessary for various reasons
including the right to privacy security
investigations are extremely sensitive
transactions yet they are also utilized
in fraud and crime these
cryptocurrencies use a variety of
strategies like currency mixing offering
transactions and anonymity mechanisms
like coin join to ensure transaction
privacy
some of the examples of privacy tokens
are Monero Z Cash Dash Horizon beam and
Verge
so now that we have covered all the
necessary types of cryptocurrency now
let's understand why we need so many
types of cryptocurrency
so since the source code for blockchain
technology is available to everyone any
software developer can utilize it to
build new things developers have done
just that at the time of this writing
there are reportedly more than 10 000
different cryptocurrencies in use and
the number keeps Rising for comparison
just four years ago more than one
thousand cryptocurrencies existed
there are so many cryptocurrencies now
because of the underlying blockchain
technology it allows programmers to
design various coins with a range of
features
in this video we are going to cover all
important Concepts and components
related to proof of work
first we will have a quick introduction
of blockchain then we will understand
what is proof of work
then we will look into how does it works
and after that we will explore why is it
actually needed
what are the issues faced by proof of
work
and at last we will look into the
blockchains working with proof of work
so without further delay let's get
started with the video
but before that let's have a quick
introduction to blockchain
the term blockchain refers to a
decentralized database that is made up
of sequential blocks that contain
recorded data the database is backed up
by a network of self-certain
participants known as nodes
now let's understand what is proof of
work
proof of work is a decentralized
consensus method that requires Network
participants to spend time solving and
arbitrary mathematical puzzle in order
to prevent the system from being hacked
it is widely used in cryptocurrency
mining for validating transactions and
Mining new tokens
it helps in the processing of
peer-to-peer transactions securely
without the need of a trusted third
party
it also requires huge amount of energy
at scale which only increases as more
miners join the network
now let's have a look at how proof of
work works
the right to add new blocks to a proof
of work blockchain is provided to
individuals who are willing to expand
computational resources to solve
cryptographic issues
the participants competing to add new
blocks are referred to as Miners and the
process is referred to as mining
miners are the one who execute proof of
work miners
use their computational power to locate
a valid block when a piece of
information such as a transaction needs
to be added to the blockchain
this is accomplished by locating a hash
that meets the network protocol specific
requirements
in cryptography a hash is the outcome of
a hash function it converts any format
or size of data into fixed size numbers
the protocol established a level of
mining difficulty that is
algorithmically adjusted so that the
time it takes to obtain a proper hash
averages 10 minutes
can sometimes locate multiple blocks
that satisfy the protocol's requirements
at the same time
and split the chain n into
because there can be only one accurate
chain the protocol must account for
these circumstances miners will
initially continue to mine on both
chains
but once another block is discovered on
top of one of the two pry blocks that
chain becomes the canonical Loop chain
and minus are economically incentivized
to discard the other block
one of the advantages of proof of work
blockchain in terms of security is their
resilience to civil attacks the Civil
attacks occurs when one player in the
network generates many false identities
in the order to get an unfair Edge
over other network participants who only
have one identity 51 attacks occur when
a single user takes control of more than
51 percent of the Network's resources
and hence has control over the adding of
new blocks
now we know how proof of work Works
let's type down Depot and explore why do
we need proof of work
majorly proof of work is required for
security and fraud prevention as well as
Trust
proof of work is intended to prevent
users from printing coins they didn't
earn or from double spending
if users could spend their coins more
than once the currency would effectively
become worthless proof of work ensures
that independent data processor or
miners can't lie about a transaction
linking a block with the proof of work
hash of its predecessor results in
tamper risk resistance because the hash
of each block is an ingredient in the
hash of the following block
any changes in the chain will affect the
final proof of work
hash as well as all Block hashes in
between
so the deeper the altered block the more
computational effort needed for
tampering
the first Miner who discovers the proof
of work answers publishes the solution
to the rest of the network when a new
block is discovered all nodes are
notified we check the answer twice
before moving on to the next block
PS if correct the block minus earn the
transaction fees and the block reward
the protocol only accepts the longest
chain as valid and authentic a fake
chain is Impractical in the long run
since a minus chances of receiving the
block reward and minimal
other miners will continue to extend the
valid chain quicker than the tampered
chain over time
moving on let's have a look at the other
side of the coin as well as understand
some of the major issues with proof of
work
first is it has a negative impact on the
environment
second the 51 attack can be used against
it if minus gain control of 51 percent
of the hashing power they will be able
to determine what is true
aside from the enormous cost of price
there is no mechanism in place to punish
any malicious miners
and four because every node must process
every transaction it does not scale
properly while sharding the network May
boost efficiency it also reduces
security this was all about proof of
work let's explore the best blockchain
networks working with proof of work
Bitcoin is the largest and the very
first blockchain to adapt proof of work
and work with it ethereum is next
working with proof of work
though it is aiming to switch to proof
of state which we will talk about in
upcoming video
then comes Bitcoin cash which is an
extension of Bitcoin and follows the
same structure thus it also works on
proof of work
then come Litecoin which is also an old
coin of Bitcoin
and then comes Monero another
cryptocurrency serving similar purpose
as other cryptos what's in it for us
today let's understand why do we need a
smart contract what is a smart contract
usage of solidity for building smart
contract advantages of smart contract
blockchain implementation of smart
contracts will look at certain examples
of voting and digital token and also we
will take another use case of how smart
contract help us do crowdfunding now why
smart contract now let's take a look
traditionally how contracts used to
happen if suppose two parties A and B
have to get into a contract they will
utilize the services of a third party
whom they have to trust and get the
contract executed now with the
introduction of smart contracts and the
technology which is evolving removes the
dependency on such third parties and
automates the execution of such smart
contracts so if we compare traditional
versus the new smart contract in
traditional we used to have governments
lawyers or any other third party on
which we can trust in smart contracts we
don't need any third party we don't need
any intermediate execution time
definitely there's higher execution time
in traditional contracts because as many
number of middlemen's and their
intermediary layers that many number of
days and time it takes smart contract is
just a matter of minutes it gets
executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined condition
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it's
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional Contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre-embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
credited automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency
is not available 100 in traditional
contracts the transparency is bound
peripheral between the parties and the
entities and the intermediaries involved
as compared to Smart contract
transparency is 100 available 24x7
online anyone can go and review audit
and validate the transactions executed
by the smart contracts archiving
archiving is a big difficult problem for
traditional contracts as most of the
transactions are paper-based or the
records are maintained offline it
becomes very difficult to maintain and
identify the traceability provenance of
all the transactions which have happened
in a traditional contract whereby in a
smart contract it becomes easy as all
the transactions have happened through
the smart contract there's a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till present day And
archiving is automatically happening the
log the audit the transaction history is
automatic practically getting generated
security definitely is a concern in
traditional contracts as the
intermediaries and involved manual
processes involved security can be
compromised at any level at any stage
but in a smart contract the security is
maintained through cryptography mainly
through public key infrastructure the
public and private key infrastructure it
is a very secure way of maintaining
security and cryptography of the
transactions using a smart contract cost
yes traditional contracts are expensive
the cost of transaction is high as
compared to Smart contracts as the
middlemans are involved smart contract
the cost is low as we don't have any
intermediaries and only the cost of
transaction is charged by the underlying
infrastructure of the blockchain network
which is running the smart contract
signatures its manual process all the
transactions are signed manually and
verified manually but here in the smart
contracts all the transactions are
digitally signed using the private key
of the entities and can only be decoded
by the public key shared by the parties
involved in the smart contract so in a
nutshell smart contracts give us n
number of advantages the primary
advantages are listed here and these are
the advantages which enforce us to move
towards an economy and to a system where
we start using smart contracts for our
transactions to avoid any disputes to
keep the transaction costs low thereby
giving the advantage to the end consumer
now what is a smart contract let's
consider a real life example where you
are taking out a chocolate from a
vending machine you deposit a two dollar
note in a vending machine after that you
hit A1 button which is mapped against
the chocolate bar that you want to buy
as a result a lever in the vending
machine moves and pushes out the
chocolate so basically even button is
programmed to the lever in order to move
the chocolate out now a smart contract
is very similar to a vending machine it
eliminates the need of an intermediary
in case of the vending machine is
replacing a direct seller and allowing
you to make a purchase without a
middleman and it only minutes in need of
Escrow Services now smart contracts are
self-executing contract which contain
the terms and conditions of an agreement
between the parties and the peers who
are involved in the beginning so the
terms and conditions of an agreement are
written in a piece of code and it is
executed on a blockchain based
decentralized platform now these
agreements facilitates exchange of any
digital asset it could be digital
currency it could be shares it could be
property or it could be anything which
you want to transact so a blockchain
based decentralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept Anonymous now
let's consider an example where ritual
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to Rachel as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flight's
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and it's
monitoring the flight's delay Rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above x
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get that trigger and
ritual will be credited with that amount
for which he is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so AXA flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
ethereum smart contract AXA is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
Beyond two hours then the insurance
contract will get executed and Rachel
will be get paid so a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delay is less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain network to their EVMS
for evaluation so evm is a runtime
compiler to execute smart contracts code
it is the brain it is the electronic
virtual machine which executes the smart
contract all nodes on the network
executing the code using the evm must
come to the same result because all the
EVMS would have the same copy of the
smart contract deployed so if the flight
is delayed two or more hours smart
contract will be self-executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
Rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middleman paperwork which ritual has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company going going through the manual
process all that has been bypassed and
ritual has been compensated directly now
let's understand why do we need solidity
for developing our smart contracts now
here comes important question which
programming language does a smart
contract use there are two widely used
programming languages for writings
ethereum smart contracts solidity and
serpent however on blockchain platforms
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we were
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides now solidity is a high level
programming language used for
implementing smart contracts it enables
to check the program at runtime rather
than compile time solidity is a touring
complete language it has all the
conditions all the while Loops for Rook
operators
Etc which are there in any matured
programming language in order to write
your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain Loop if
you have while conditions Etc now what
are the advantages of smart contract as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediaries involved the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's a high
speed highly computive smart contracts
which runs on programming code the speed
of its execution is higher than a
traditional contract as the data is
stored in the decentralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and I would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirements terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
network through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
blockchain in voting process can
eliminate voting malpractices a
centralized voting system faces a lot of
problems when it comes to tracking votes
there could be manipulated identities
they could be manipulation in counting
there could be biased decision making a
smart contract is introduced to
eliminate all these malpractices there
are certain predefined terms and
conditions which already set in the
contract no voter can vote from a
digital identity of any other voter the
counting is full proof every vote is
registered on a blockchain network and
the accounting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each ID should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the blockchain network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous organization
based blockchain setup also but it is
100 transparent and every voting
transaction is recorded result world
every voters won't get recorded on The
Ledger and that information cannot be
modified it is transparently publicly
available for audit and verification now
let's take a look at one of the examples
of our voting solidity contract so here
we have our voting solidity contract it
is built in solidity and I'll just give
you a brief overview of what are the
primary functions in this so if we look
at this particular contract this
contract gives you certain basic
parameters like what should be the
minimum number of participants or
proposals which are required for voting
then what should be the minimum amount
of time for debate that needs to pass
before the vote can be executed then the
margin of votes for majority a proposal
passes if there are more than 50 of the
votes plus the margin so basically we
are defining what is the winning
condition what is the majority margin
for any word to be accepted then you
have data structure where you are
accepting the proposals right and then
subsequently we are defining data
structures for members who are
participating in the proposals who are
submitting the proposals we are fetching
the addresses of the members basically
this is the digital identity of the
members who are submitting the proposals
and Etc so this smart contracts
basically allows you to create a voting
system where you can add members we can
remove the members you can change
certain voting rules based on certain
conditions like if you want to increase
the minimum Quorum if you want to change
the debating period minutes or the
majority rule changes then this is the
function for submitting a new proposal
for which the voting has to happen so
basically this example is about if I
have to take a vote within a
decentralized autonomous Organization
for a particular decision so rather than
a central Authority taking a decision
you can have a voting mechanism within
your organization to give a majority to
your proposal if you get them Authority
The Proposal is accepted otherwise
reject then there are peripheral
functions like check proposal code then
there is a voting function the actual
vote happens and for a particular
proposal you start increasing or
decreasing the number of votes then you
execute the proposal if the majority has
been achieved now let's take a look on
how to deploy a smart contract so here
we have our voting smart contract now we
will take a look on how to deploy our
voting smart contract on the ethereum
test Network called robston this is our
voting smart contract now when you open
remix you should also have metamask
which is a chrome plugin installed this
is a utility in order to connect to the
robsten test net which is a ethereum
test Network so basically you say
robson.etherscan.io and this is the
ethereum test Network on which we will
deploy our contract so once you log in
into the metamask you will have a
account created and in that account you
should have have some test ethers
already so that you can use them to
deploy your contract so when you create
an account on robsten you can buy
certain ethers using the robsten test
faucet
so when you reach this site the option
test faucet has already taken the
address for the account for which you
are raising the request and you can
raise request of one ether now whenever
this transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as I already have ethers in it I
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract I have copy pasted it here and
if I go to my run My remix has already
communicated via injected web3 to the
metamask and take in my account which
has 7.83 ether
now I need to do some settings
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and Congress is my
major contract now I will deploy my
contract so on the Run section you will
be able to see in the drop down the name
of the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like I had owned token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a congress so I need to deploy
my Congress contract now in order to
deploy this contract there is a
Constructor which requires certain
inputs so I can give certain values like
what minimum number of proposals I need
800 then minimum number of debates 10
and margin of votes for majority so I
say deploy now as soon as I'll click
deploy it is going to request me for gas
because when the contract gets deployed
it will deduct certain ethers from my
account so when I'll say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the robsten
etherscan.io I click on it so this is
the transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
ethereum network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
created and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0xcc I can load it now this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option ether scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish your
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your meta mask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we opened here
now after you have deployed the contract
you can interact with your contract
directly through remix just to test your
contract all the pink members are the
ones which make changes onto the
blockchain and all the blue ones are the
ones which are only performing read
operations so in order to do any read
operation you will not be requested to
spend any gas so there will be no
pop-ups for metamask requesting for gas
spending but if you do any of these pink
actions then you will be required to
spend gas as it will be requiring to
make some changes onto the block so this
was a example of a voting smart contract
and this will be available as a link for
you to take a look now all our other
contracts which we will be covering
subsequently will be deployed in a
similar Fashion on the Robson test net
now let's check another example if you
want to use Smart contract to issue your
own cryptocurrency or called digital
token you can use ethereum based smart
contract to create your own digital
tokens for performing transactions in
design and issue your own digital
currency create a tradable computerized
token that can be utilized as a currency
share or any asset which you want to
transact these tokens use a standard
coin API like in case of ethereum we
have standardizations of erc20 Etc which
allows contract to automatically access
any wallet for exchange as a result you
build a tradable token with a suffix
Supply and this particular platform
becomes a like a central bank issuing a
digital money your smart contract
becomes the bank issuing the money so
let's take this example here so this is
a implementation of a erc20 token which
is a specification by ethereum and uh
the primary attribute for this token is
that you need to provide a name of your
token a symbol the decimals to which you
support and the most primary is the
predefined supply so just like in an
economy you have limited supply of money
here also you have to Define what will
be the supply of your tokens and it will
be capped that will be the supply so you
need to predefine these parameters and
then you create certain data structures
within solidity to keep a tap on the
balances of the entities to which you
are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep per address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the erc20
specification like transfer transfer
from from approve and Call Etc so all
these methods in a typical token allows
you to do the transaction send and
receive your custom token among multiple
parties so this would also be available
as a link for you to take a look now
let's take another example of our use
case for crowdfunding using smart
contracts to crowdfund your project so
suppose you want to start a business and
for a business you need a lot of funding
which is required but who would lend
that money to someone whom they don't
trust how will you generate that money
for such problems smart contract plays a
major role with ethereum you can build a
smart contract that will hold a
contributor's fronts unless a given date
or a goal is met based on the result the
funds will be released to the contract
owners or will be sent back to the
contributors so basically you can create
a crowdfunding project for yourself if
you want to raise certain amount of
money and the contributors or the
investors will give you the money but
the amount will be kept on hold till the
time your project goal or date has been
met and accordingly the investor will
get you the token which you have
developed for crowdfunding in us or his
account accordingly now centralized
crowdfunding system has plenty of issues
with Management Systems so therefore a
dow a decentralized autonomous
organization is utilized for
crowdfunding the terms and conditions
are transparently set in the contract
every individual participating in the
crowd funding is given a token and the
token is credited to their ethereum
based account now every contribution
gets recorded on the blockchain because
then the token transfer has happened
from the Dow to the individual investor
that transaction get recorded on the
blockchain network so let's quickly take
a look at the contract for a crowd sale
also so a crowd sale contract provides
you the basic attributes like what is
the goal of the funding how much money
you need to raise what is the amount
raised real-time name you can keep a
track what is the deadline right and
what is the price of the token in
ethereum basically what is the your
token amount in ethereum then there
could be that you might give certain
tokens in reward then you can have
attributes for your reward and then you
have your methods in order to keep a
check that once you have received the
funds you can withdraw the funds you can
check whether you have reached the goal
for funding and then you have the
methods for transferring tokens from the
sender to your own account
particular kind of contract allows you
to maintain and keep a check on amount
of funding you have received or you want
to receive have you achieved your target
who are the investors in your token how
much percentage share belongs to your
account and how much percentage share
has been already been distributed all
amongst the investors Etc so everything
can be tracked so their smart contract
can build in such a fashion that there
are methods and utilities available in
order to run your entire crowdfunding so
this contract is also available in the
link and you can take a look so why wait
let's embark on this exhilarating
adventure together
but before we dive in if you're looking
to take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field Ria is a phenomenal Baker
who runs a bakery in New York on seeing
the great success of her business she
thought of growing it even bigger and
launching a new franchise of her Bakery
in LA
so for the funds she applied for a loan
of fifty thousand dollars from the
central bank
after completing her documentation for
the loan she comes to know that the bank
is rejecting her loan application due to
her loan borrowing limit of the amount
decided by the central Financial system
furious with this situation she talked
to a friend Lisa a finance expert to
understand how this whole centralized
Financial system of banks works and why
did her loan get rejected Lisa explained
to her that in centralized Finance Banks
and businesses use the money that you
invest or lend to make profits and their
overriding objective is to make money
third parties or Merchants like debit
credit card providers control money
transfers between the two end parties in
the financial system
each charging a fee for their services
and that is why her loan got rejected
because the loan amount exceeded the
limit decided by the bank or third
parties for her Rio was upset with the
thought of not being able to grow her
business and that is when Lisa suggested
Ria to opt for decentralized finance or
defy Ria got a little confused by the
term and asked what is decentralized
finance
Lisa answered the decentralized finance
is a piece of code that eliminates
middlemen or banks by allowing
individuals business merchants and
corporations to perform Financial
transactions using developing
Technologies
peer-to-peer Financial networks that
provide security protocols and
connectivity to the transactions are
used to accomplish this
stablecoin is a cryptocurrency backed by
an asset or tied to a fiat currency like
the dollar is that the concept's core
Ria was fascinated and asked how it
works and how exactly D5 could help her
get her loan approved Lisa further added
that defy uses the consensus mechanism
to eliminate centralized Finance models
by allowing anyone or everyone to
utilize Financial Services regardless of
who they are or where they are a
consensus mechanism refers to the
methods used to achieve agreement trust
and security across a decentralized
computer network
now this defy mechanism runs in a
decentralized environment and this is
where blockchain comes into the picture
it provides the environment where you
can simply create your decentralized
programs or D apps according to your
requirement
in the blockchain network transactions
are stored in blocks and other users in
that Network can verify them if a
transaction is verified by all its
verifiers the block is closed and
encrypted and a new block is created
containing information from the previous
block thus creating a chain of blocks
and these transactions are handled by
decentralized applications or say d apps
Lisa further explained that urea's loan
got rejected due to the lower limit by
the centralized Financial system but in
defy she can submit her loan
requirements into a decentralized
finance application DIA and an algorithm
would match her up with peers who could
help her
after that she'll have to agree to the
lender's terms to get her loan the
transaction is then recorded in the
blockchain where it will be securely
stored in a ledger that will make it
impossible to hack or any kind of
malicious intervention and after that
she'll receive her required amount of
money once it is verified by the
consensus mechanism
the lender can also then begin
collecting their payments at the agreed
upon intervals from her when she makes
the payment using her D app it goes
through the same blockchain process and
the money is transferred to the lender
Ria was impressed and relieved that she
now could grow her business in a much
more secure and cheaper way all thanks
to defy
Defy is meant to conduct transactions
using cryptocurrency
because technology is still evolving
it's difficult to say how if at all
existing cryptocurrencies will be
applied Finn is part of the management
team in an imminent sea and he has come
up with some profitable investment
policies for his company and his
employees
before its implementation he needs to
pitch his idea in front of the board of
directors but the board of directors
didn't approve of his idea and that too
without any explanation for their
decision
disappointed by this he started browsing
the internet looking for a solution that
could benefit everyone and where every
member gets to have their say and that
is when he came across the concept of
Dao which is a decentralized
organization that is collectively owned
by its members and wherein decisions are
voted upon by by themselves which runs
on blockchain technology
but to understand its concept in depth
we went to his friend Sam who is a
blockchain expert Finn explained to him
his situation how he came across the Dow
and why he wants to know more about it
on realizing his excitement and
curiosity Sam decided to take him
through the Dow and how it functions he
explained that before understanding what
Dao is let's understand a bit about what
blockchain is
blockchain is a system of storing data
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change hack or manipulate the data it's
basically a digital log of transactions
that are duplicated and spread across
the blockchain's whole network of
computers and the dowel is something
that makes use of its rules and policies
for its proper functioning
he further added a Dao or decentralized
Economist organization is a
blockchain-based organization that is
collectively owned and controlled by its
members they have built-in resources
that no one can access without the
group's permission
all proposals are implemented using
voting processes to make decisions upon
its rules and policies ensuring that
everyone in the organization gets a say
and this whole system majorly runs on
ethereum blockchain
Sam further added that back in 2016 the
developers of the Dow believe that by
putting decision-making power in the
hands of automated technology that will
eliminate the decision-making power
driven by an individual or by Body it
was created to allow investors to send
money anonymously from anywhere globally
and they would issue tokens to those
owners letting them vote on potential
initiatives or proposals
Finn was fascinated and asked Sam how
exactly it works and how this can be the
solution for his situation
Sam explained basically smart contracts
are the backbone of doubt
smart contracts are programs that run
when certain conditions are met and are
stored on a blockchain
let's understand this stepwise
Step One is when the documentation of
the idea takes place in the similar way
in doubt a group of people write these
smart contracts to administer the
organization
once the contract goes live on the
ethereum network changes to its rules
can be proposed only by voting the
contract automatically fails if the
rules are violated
then comes step two which is a funding
period in which pitching of ideas takes
place in front of the selected members
and investors of the organization
similarly people in the Dow organization
contribute money to the Dow by
purchasing tokens that signify their
membership in the organization
and when the funding period ends it
proceeds to step three that is when the
approval and implementation process of
the idea takes place or say the Dow
starts to operate people can now make
proposals to the Dow on how to spend the
money and how the members can vote to
approve those proposals
this is how the first ever dowel was
launched by slackit
now the question arises what led the Dow
towards criticism
this is due to the infamous Dow hack
back in June 2016 hackers use Dallas
vulnerabilities to assault its treasury
the hackers were able to gain access to
3.6 million ethereum valued around 50
million dollars
this sparked a divisive debate among Dow
investors with some demanding for the
Dow to be permanently dismantled
initially vitalik buterin the founder of
ethereum advocated a soft Fork of the
ethereum network
which included a piece of code that
would effectively Blacklist the attacker
and prohibit them from moving the stolen
cache
but soon after
problem was detected in its code putting
it vulnerable to assault after great
debate a second alternative a hard Fork
was suggested and subsequently
implemented
the hard Fork effectively reset the
ethereum Network's history and move the
Dows ether to a different smart contract
allowing investors to withdraw their
assets
and as a result of the hard four two
competing and now distinct ethereum
blockchains emerged those who oppose the
hard for which wiped back the
blockchain's history back the soft Fork
version which is now known as ethereum
classic
Etc
the ethereum blockchain is the
blockchain that implemented the hard
Fork changing the blockchain's history
so what's in it for you today we are
going to understand why do we need
blockchain wallet what is a blockchain
wallet how do these Wallet work what are
the different types of blockchain
wallets their comparisons and a demo on
the usage of these blockchain wallets
and we will try to do certain
transactions using these wallets now
before these blockchain wallets came
into existence what were the means in
order for us to do the transactions and
what were the drawbacks in the old days
the transactions with whatever medium
and channels we had the problems were
that the transactions were slow and
Banks were the central point of failure
basically any transaction which has to
go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blockchain wallet a blockchain wallet is
a cryptocurrency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example Bitcoin
ethereum Etc now a blockchain wallet
helps exchanging of funds easily
transactions are secure as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blockchain wallet is
a typical cryptocurrency wallet that
allows users to manage cryptocurrencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
PayPal or any other Gateway which you
use today but now you you can use
cryptocurrency instead similar to PayPal
which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem of
blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain.info
Jax mycelium Samurai and Bitcoin paper
wallet these are just to name a few
blockchain wallets which are existing in
the market but there are many more based
on the requirement you have based on the
security you require and based on the
kind of wallet which suffices your need
so we will see what are the
categorizations of these kind of wallets
are now how do blockchain wallets work
let's take a look so before we move on
to how blockchain wallets work let's
understand what a private and a public
key is and how are these Keys related to
a blockchain wallet now whenever you
create a blockchain wallet you are also
provided a private and a public key
which is associated with your wallet now
let's check an exam sample in order to
understand this imagine a person knowing
your email address is sending you an
email so in our regular day-to-day
activity if we want to receive an email
from someone we give him or her our
email ID and expect an email from them
now what if an unknown person is able to
send emails through my account so I am
giving my email address for receiving
emails but when I am disclosing my email
ID I am not assuming that someone will
be able to send emails through my
account because then for that he has to
be aware of my email account password so
knowing your email address will not give
a person the ability to send an email
from your account you are not giving
your password to the person to send an
email you're just giving the email
address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now blockchain wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share that public key with anyone in
order to receive funds private key is
top secret it's similar to your password
it should not get hacked or you should
not disclose it to anyone and you use
this private key to spend your funds so
now instead of sending an email imagine
you want to transfer money to your
friend just answer process is done
through your blockchain wallet with
blockchain wallets you can now send and
receive cryptocurrencies so as I said a
blockchain wallet has two keys a public
key and a private key public key is
shared with everyone just like an email
address private key is just like your
password which should be kept secret
with the sender so with blockchain
wallet no one will be able to send
crypto coins just like email means
through your public key until they know
your private key but if someone gets
access to your private key there is a
high possibility that your account is
hacked and you might end up losing all
the cryptocurrency deposits in your
account now let's take a look what are
the typical features of a blockchain
wallet it's easy to use it's just like
any other software or a wallet which you
use for your day-to-day transactions it
is highly secure it is just a matter of
you securing your private key and it
allows instant transactions across
geographies barrier-free without
intermediaries and also these
transactions charges you low cost fee
and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies so you can make
payments across cryptocurrencies which
helps you do easy currency conversions
now let's talk about what are the
different type of blockchain wallets now
basically there are two types of
blockchain let's based on the private
Keys one is hot wallet and another is
the cold wallet hot wallets are like
normal wallets which we carry for
day-to-day transactions and these
wallets are user friendly cold wallets
gold wallets are similar to a vault
where cryptocurrencies are stored with a
high level of security now let's take a
look at the differences hot wallets are
online wallets through which
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
quickly they are available online on
internet example coinbase
blockchain.info cold wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed offline and then
later disclosed online so they are not
maintained on the cloud on the internet
they are maintained offline to have high
security and the examples of cold wallet
are treasure and Ledger now in case of
hot wallets private keys are stored in
the cloud for faster transfer in case of
cool wallets private keys are stored in
a separate Hardware which are
disconnected from the Internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper-based
document hot wallet they are easy to
access available online 24 7 it can be
accessed through desktop or mobile but
has a risk of unrecoverable theft when
hacked cold wallet this method of
transaction helps in protecting the
wallet from unauthorized access from
hacking and other online vulnerabilities
now the wallet can be further
distinguished on these criterias there
can be software wallets they can be
Hardware wallets which are like kind of
USB driven and you plug into your USB
drive and your Hardware wallet can be
used or they are a typical paper-based
wallet where you print your public key
and a private key on a paper and keep it
in a secure place so let's talk about
software wallet a software wallet is an
application that is downloaded on a
device either it could be a desktop or a
mobile or it could be a web-based wallet
which can be accessed online now here
are certain examples that's bread wallet
and copay are the popular software
wallets so software wallet can be
further categorized into desktop wallet
online or we can call it web wallets or
mobile wallets now desktop wallet are
like cold wallet in which the private
keys are stored in cold servers
basically the desktop wallets if the
private keys are stored in your desktop
you can unplug it from the internet do
some offline transactions and then bring
it back online now in case the main
server is lost then a cold server
basically a desktop is used as a backup
server these wallets can be downloaded
on any computer but can only be accessed
from the system they are installed on so
you make sure the desktop or the machine
on which you I have downloaded the
desktop wallet is safe has a backup
you're maintaining the hardware you're
not letting the machine go anywhere and
it is on a secure location now these
wallets are definitely cost efficient
and one of the examples is electron and
is one of the most popular desktop
wallet online wallets are the other kind
of hot wallets that run on the cloud
that are available on the internet now
here users have the benefit of accessing
these wallets across any device it could
be tablet desktop or you can use it from
your mobile browser the private keys are
stored online and are managed by a third
party you have to be dependent on a
third-party service so for example green
address is a Bitcoin wallet which is
available on the web has an Android app
is available on a desktop and also is
available on iOS Apple mobile wallets
mobile wallets are like similar to
online wallets except that they are
built only for mobile phone usage and
accessibility these wallets are also
user friendly and they have a
user-friendly interface from which helps
you in doing transactions easily the
example is mycelium which is the best
available Mobile Wallet Hardware wallet
Hardware wallet is a type of cold
storage device typically like a USB
which stores the user's private key in a
protected Hardware device these wallets
are similar to Portable devices that can
be connected to the computer can be
plugged in as I said earlier it is less
prone to malware attacks malicious
attacks and it is hack proof examples
are Nano Ledger treasure and key key are
the top Hardware wallets available in
the market to make a transaction from
your Hardware wallet you have to ensure
the hardware wallet is plugged into your
computer system before you can do a
transaction from your Hardware wallet
paper wallet a paper wallet is an
offline process for storing
cryptocurrencies this wallet is a
printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a QR code now since these
wallets are says they are widely used
for storing large amount of crypto
currencies now example are Bitcoin paper
wallet and my ether wallet are one of
the widely used paper wallets but the
question arises how do I add
cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on your paper wallet now let's
do the comparison blocked in info
blockchain info is a cryptocurrency
wallet which supports Bitcoin and
ethereum it is easy to use and has a low
transaction fee it has its apis exposed
you can easily use them to order to make
your own custom wallets also Ledger Nano
Ledger Nano is a hardware wallet which
offers a high security to your account
it is available for Bitcoin ethereum and
Litecoin uses it is also possible to
maintain multiple accounts and access
them anytime Bitcoin paper wallet paper
wallet helps you to print your own
tamper resistant Bitcoin wallet it
minimizes the threat of hacking Jacks
Jax is a software wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for Bitcoin
ethereum Litecoin and many other
cryptocurrencies with Jacks a user can
view his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so
bitaddress.org provides you a paper
wallet it uses the client-side
JavaScript in order to generate a random
hash for your wallet so you keep moving
your mouse and it will generate a hash
public and private key it is recommended
that when you are doing this process you
should be disconnected from the internet
and once these keys are generated you
can print it and keep it secure and
clear the cache of your browser so as
you can see on the screen this is my
public key for receiving my Bitcoins and
this is the private key for me to spend
it I can print it and keep it handy with
me but of course the safety of these
physical documents cannot be entirely
guaranteed if a hacker discovers the
location of your paper wallet and
physically steals it then they can
access your Bitcoin Holdings so
basically it is of high importance that
you keep the paper wallet in a very very
secure location some users hide or
disguise the paper wallet it should be
protected from physical damage if the
keys fade or can no longer be scanned
then the user will never again be able
to access the Bitcoin which are parked
in that address also take care if you
are using an incorrect type of printer
that also may damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bit pay so you can
download bitpay online and create your
account over here
foreign
you can create a personal wallet you can
create a shared wallet or a joint share
wallet once you create a wallet like if
you see the example over here this is my
personal wallet and I have
3.645 test Bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test Bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
Bitcoins from
testnet.coinfoset.eu hyphen in
now in order to receive it you just need
to
copy
your Bitcoin address
in the test net address
so the test net has given me 0.87
Bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from 3.5 to 3.64 and I can see this
transaction
see three minutes go I just received
0.872287 Bitcoin the transaction is
still in process but in a while as this
transaction is getting mined on the test
net I will receive it now as I have
received it I can even make a
transaction and send it to someone
so from my personal account I can send
Bitcoin to
someone whose Bitcoin address I have and
I have to just paste it over here
transfer to bitcoin wallet either I can
select one of my own wallets or I can
search for any other Bitcoin address
which someone has shared with me and I
can send it to that particular address
now let's take an example of our
Hardware wallet how does Hardware wallet
works with the online wallets so here we
have metamask which has a feature of
connecting with Hardware wallet so once
you have metamask installed you will see
this option of connect Hardware wallet
now metamask has provided support for
Treasure so now once you connect your
Hardware wallet the USB with your
computer you can select an account you
want to view on that particular Hardware
wallet and you can only choose one at a
time and then you can start using that
particular wallet for your decentralized
apps so basically once you have your
Hardware connected it is integrated with
your metamask and then you can start
running your decentralized apps so that
they can start using the tokens or the
currency in the particular Hardware
wallet so use your Hardware account like
you would with anything account login to
dapps and send ethereums buy and store
erc20 tokens and non-fungible tokens
like crypto kitties so if you click
connect to treasure over here
metamask will start looking out for the
connected treasure device so first let's
have a look at what we're going to
explore in this video first you will get
an idea about what is decentralized
finance or defy then you will understand
what a liquidity pool is following that
you will understand the difference
between the liquidity pool and ordered
books then you will get a broader
perspective on how exactly liquidity
pools work and what are the regulations
of the liquidity pool and in the end
you'll get a gist of the pros and cons
of liquidity pools so let me take you
through decentralized Finance first
decentralized Finance or Defy is a new
Financial system that is built on safely
distributed ledgers much like the ones
used by cryptocurrencies D5 reduces the
service charges that Banks and other
financial institutions impose anyone
with an internet connection can use D5
and users can hold their money in a Safe
digital wallet and transfer money
quickly basically by giving people
access to peer-to-peer digital trades D5
threatens the centralized Financial
system and crypto assets are locked into
the contracts referred to as liquidity
Pools by users of D5 protocols so that
others can use them
well now that I've mentioned liquidity
pools let me explain what exactly a
liquidity pool is a liquidity pool is
technically a pool of crypto tokens
secured under a smart contract and these
tokens provide decentralized exchanges
with the necessary liquidity they
require basically the term liquidity
refers to the ease with which one can
swap a crypto token for another because
so many Financial transactions occur
within the D5 ecosystem such Simplicity
is crucial
but this raises the question of how
liquidity pulls differ from ordered
books
to understand how liquidity pools differ
from ordered books let's look at the
fundamental building block of electronic
trading which is the ordered book
simply put the open orders for a certain
Market are gathered in the ordered book
the system that matches orders with each
other is called the matching engine the
ordered book and the matching engine are
the primary components of any
centralized exchange or CeX
this concept made it possible to
communicate information efficiently and
enable the development of intricate
financial markets defy trading however
carries out deals directly on the
blockchain without needing a central
entity to retain the funds in terms of
ordered books this creates a challenge
gas fees are incurred for each
interaction with the ordered book making
the cost of executing transactions
significantly higher additionally it
makes it very expensive for Traders who
act as market makers and Supply
liquidity for trading payers Above All
Else however most blockchains cannot
handle the throughput needed for the
daily trading of billions of dollars but
liquidity pools solve each of these
problems with ease so now that the
definition and purpose of the liquidity
pool are all clear let me walk you
through the working of liquidity pools
as discussed before in a normal
liquidity pool users are encouraged and
rewarded for staking their digital
Assets in the pool rewards may take the
form of cryptocurrency or a portion of
the trading commissions paid by the
exchanges where they pull their assets
here's an example of how it operates a
Trader using Sushi swap to invest in a
BTC to usdt liquidity pool step one go
to sushi swap step two find the BTC usdt
liquidity pool step 3 deposit a split of
BTC and usdt to the BTC usdt liquidity
pool step 4 receive BTC usdt liquidity
provider tokens step 5 lpts should be
deposited to the BTC usdt staking pool
after the agreed-upon amount of time has
passed you'll be given the sushi token
you pledge to keep it safe it can be for
a set period of time like a week or
three months the original BTC usdt pair
would be compensated with a percentage
of the commissions received from
exchanges on that liquidity pool in
addition by staking your lpts you would
receive Sushi tokens now that the
working of the liquidity pool is in
front of you let me give you a gist of
the regulations of liquidity pools for
your Investments
the investment fund manager needs a
license to build a pool in addition
regardless of the jurisdiction and
investment fund license is required
whenever the pool is actively sold or
promoted to clients some cryptocurrency
liquidity pools circumvent the issue by
presenting themselves as community-owned
and distributing governance tokens the
entire Community holds the ownership
thus Regulators won't be able to go
after the owners in court however there
is a significant amount of risk
associated with joining such pools
well now that the concepts of the
liquidity pool are all clear let me give
you a look over the pros and cons of the
liquidity pool to give you a better
understanding
the liquidity pool makes trading on the
decks simpler since transactions are
carried out at current market prices
whereas it goes against the idea of
decentralization that a small group
controls the pool of funds
people can use it to lend money and get
paid in prizes interest or an annual
percentage yield in return for their
cryptocurrency on the other hand due to
LAX security measures there is a risk of
hacker exploits which could cost
liquidity providers money
it uses publicly accessible smart
contracts to maintain the transparency
of security audit information but on the
contrary there is an exposure to
Temporary loss
this occurs when a change in the price
of your assets that are held in a
liquidity pool results in an unrealized
loss as opposed to if you had just kept
the Assets in your wallet
well this was all about liquidity pool
and its related Concepts Jordan a fresh
graduate is working as a sophomore
engineer at a big firm saving money for
higher studies one day he came to know
that the bank where he was saving money
got bankrupt and all his money was now
gone with the bank
Jordan was confused how come if the bank
had gone bankrupt his money was also
gone
when his friend Jack learned about this
he explained that banks are basically a
centralized system for storing the data
of all transactions Banks rotate money
to ensure the existence of the money of
their customers for instance the amount
of money appearing on your account is
just a number of value so if they go
through any crisis your money also comes
at risk a real life example of this was
the bankruptcy of layman brothers when
they caused a global recession
in a nutshell by giving your money to
the bank you are giving control of your
money to someone else and this causes
the problem of transparency and this
doesn't stop there
due to the irrational ratio of Banks and
data present technical failures and
double spending we're due to internal
server issues the amount gets deducted
twice became prominent issues
Jordan was shocked to know such an
in-depth mechanism of Banks and how they
negatively affect their money and
wondered if these issues are so
prominent what is a solution
and that's when Jack replied well there
is a solution and it's Bitcoin Jordan
was confused and asked what Bitcoin is
Jack explained that Bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency that came into existence
in 2008 a white paper was published by a
guy named Satoshi Nakamoto suggesting a
way of creating a system for a
decentralized currency called Bitcoin
its motive was to show the world that
the decentralized control structure can
work with the institutional government
Bitcoin claimed to create a digital
solution that would solve all these
problems like double spending corruption
and low transparency without the need
for a central Authority
Jordan was excited to know about Bitcoin
but needed clarification about how
Bitcoin can solve such issues that large
institutions like Banks cannot
Jack further explained that Bitcoin is a
transparent Ledger without a central
Authority and works on blockchain
technology
blockchain is a system for storing data
in a way that makes it challenging or
impossible to alter hack or defraud the
system a blockchain is simply a network
of computer systems that maintains
duplicate copies of all transactions in
a digital Ledger disseminated throughout
the network
and BTC is the currency used to make
those transactions successful and as
there are no middlemen the transaction
cost is way cheaper as each system in
the network carries a copy of The Ledger
or transaction stored in it making it
impossible to hack or manipulate
because to do so you will have to take
down or hack every system or node
participating in the network
Bitcoin is completely digital
Jordan after knowing this ask how it
could solve his problem and how he could
get access to bitcoin if it's completely
digital
Jack explained that one can always buy
Bitcoins once you own Bitcoin it gives
you a specific ID which gives you full
control over your money using that ID
you can send or receive funds in your
Bitcoin account that can be later
converted into any currency anytime you
want
so if he would have invested that same
amount in Bitcoin years ago he could
have easily accessed it and it would
have been worth much more than they were
years ago
another reference is a Vignesh
sundarison famously known as medicovan
who became a billionaire with just five
thousand dollars investment all because
of Bitcoin
so these examples are powerful enough to
establish the fact that Bitcoin is the
best alternative for today's Financial
establishment and also how bright its
future is going to be so let's get
started and let's talk about what is
Bitcoin mining so what is bitcoin so
let's check an example so there is
someone who wants to send five Bitcoins
to Rachel now we will see how this
transaction can happen now Bitcoin is
based on the concept of digital currency
anyone across the globe can transfer
amount in Bitcoin irrespective of the
geography from anyone to anyone so
basically you need to just open an
account on the Bitcoin Network have some
Bitcoins in it and you can transfer it
either you can purchase the Bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have Bitcoins in
your account you can transfer it to
someone you want whose address you have
now do you want to know how this
transaction work well this transaction
is done by Bitcoin mining so we will go
deep and understand that how the Bitcoin
transaction Works what all entities are
involved behind the scenes in order to
maintain the sanity of the Bitcoin
Network and make sure that whomever you
wanted the Bitcoin to reach to has
reached and there is no loss of Bitcoin
in the network and it is a successful
transaction so let's understand certain
Basics so what's in it for us today we
need to know what is bitcoin we will
understand the underlying technology
blockchain so we will talk about that
then we will see what are the advantages
of Bitcoin as compared to other digital
currencies and other digital
Technologies then we will go into the
concepts of Bitcoin mining then what is
Bitcoin mining and we will do a demo on
certain aspects of Bitcoin mining now
what is bitcoin Bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like Banks governments agents broker is
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediate now
Bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called Satoshi
nakomoto now Bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular Fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed the intermediaries from between
the cost of transaction also goes down
and it is cryptographically secure it
uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities of the sender and
the receiver are also secure and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the user's information who doing the
transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of Bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a Bitcoin Network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public Ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the Bitcoin Network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so Bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distribute Ledger
in which transactions made in Bitcoins
or any other digital currency are
recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized Authority or the body and
the transactions are towed in containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain which records all the
transaction a basic structure of a block
is something like this it has four
Fields these are the primary attributes
for Block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block nons
so in proof of work consensus algorithm
which is used in Bitcoin nonce is a
random value which is used to vary the
output of the hash value so every block
is supposed to generate a hash value and
nonce is the parameter which is used to
generate that hash value and the proof
of work is the process of transaction
verification done in blockchain now hash
is the resultant hash value obtained by
passing the previous hash value the data
and the nouns through the sha256
algorithm to generate the hash of this
block so this is the digital signature
of the block which is generated and this
is the basically identity of this block
now sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
big alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of Bitcoin
mining what is Bitcoin mining Bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
Bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain Ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by Bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called miners so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of Legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on a regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in Bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining Community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every Miner's job is to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction The Miner who first solves
the person gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzle as I said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand Bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public Ledger it uses sha-256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
Bitcoin mining so distributed public
Ledger a distributed Ledger is a record
of all trans actions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by Bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secure they are
digitally signed their hash value once
generated cannot be altered now sat 256
it takes an input string of any size and
returns a fixed length 256 bit output
value and that is the primary feature of
shf 256 encryption algorithm you give
any input it will always give you a 256
bit output and it is a one-way function
you cannot derive the input reversely
from the output what you have generated
and third is the proof of work in
blockchain mining is a process to
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the miner is to
determine the nonce value and that non's
value is that mathematical puzzle that
minus required to solve in order to
generate a hash Which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the Bitcoin
Network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying a
nonce which produces a hash value lower
than a predefined condition which is
called as the target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 Bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the Bitcoins associated with
the transactions can be spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of Bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregate get it in the
block the transfers are made then from
one account to the another now in order
to generate the hash let's see you use
the Sha 256 hashing algorithm you define
the hash value if it is less than the
defined condition the target then the
puzzle is deemed to be solved and if not
then you keep on incrementing non's
value and you repeat the sha-256 hashing
function passing on to the nonce value
and you Define generate the hash value
again and you keep doing this process
till the time you get the hash value
Which is less than the Target now let's
check an example so for example Beyonce
wants to share 10 Bitcoin with Jennifer
now in order to do that what will be the
steps so bronze transaction data is
shared with Bitcoin users the miners
from the memory pool the transaction
goes and sits in a memory pool of
unmined transactions so in a memory pool
set of unmined or unconfirmed
transactions wait until they are very
fight and included in a new block they
remain in that unconformed transaction
pool now miners competing to validate
the transaction using proof of work they
keep on continuously pulling the
unconfirmed transaction pool they pick
up those transactions and start
validating those transactions they
aggregate in a data block and start
validating they start solving the puzzle
The Miner who solves the puzzle first
shares his result across the other nodes
the other set of miners now once the
block has been verified the nonce has
been generated then the nodes will start
granting their approval if maximum nodes
grant their approval the block becomes
valid and is added to the blockchain now
simultaneously The Miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
Bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the Bitcoins the 10
BTC for which the transaction was
initiated now we'll get and will get
transferred from Beyonds to Jennifer now
let's take a look at certain facts in
proof of work a predefined condition the
target is adjusted for every 2016 block
which is approximately every 14 days and
an average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for Block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash Target of
the first block divided by the hash
Target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have told the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash Target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as I said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of Bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of Mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of whatever the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of block Box ABC
Now each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to Tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of Block B
will all get d-linked because the
previous hash value of Block C will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the Block B which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of Block B which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying Hardware requirements for
Bitcoin mining and how the hardware has
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit CPUs now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as I said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so they
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular CPUs so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any Miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called asric application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so miners are profitable when
their cost of resources to mine one
block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they earn so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new Bitcoins are created
in the network so the Bitcoin total
Supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million Bitcoin
are in Supply 17 to 18 million Bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 Bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the Bitcoin mining
reward goes by the halfing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so the then after that
threshold is reached the Bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 Bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is Bitcoin mining pool your chances of
winning the lottery is difficult but in
a community if individuals buy multiple
lottery tickets and pool their tickets
together then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed amongst all the participants
Bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to minor
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result right the Bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
Bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the Bitcoin Network as you can
see this is a block and this is the lock
reward 12.5 Bitcoin so this was a block
which was mined this is the block number
and these are the set of transactions
which were part of this block now once
this block was mined by The Miner all
these transactions can be done these are
the transfers of Bitcoin from one
account to the other this is the nonce
which was generated by The Miner or the
mining pool in order to mine the block
and these are the other attributes and
if you take a look at this URL this is
an example of a mining pool it's a demo
account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconformed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have mine so
why wait let's embark on this
exhilarating adventure together but
before we dive in if you're looking to
take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field
ethereum and its Concepts
ethereum
simply put while Bitcoin is defined as
digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime fraud
and third-party interference and also
has its own cryptocurrency called ether
ethereum aims to enable Innovations in
three key areas
currency Assurance through ether which
serves as in the innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum the first feature
of ethereum is that it is secure because
it is almost impossible to tamper with
the transactions in the block or to add
any fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
Community following
ethereum has attracted a lot of
attention from people all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset a virtual share a proof of
membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast while Bitcoin requires a block time
of 10 minutes in ethereum it's only a
few seconds the last feature that we
will discuss is the fact that ethereum
is uncensored ethereum's open source
Network allows complete transparency to
view every transaction alright that's
all about the features of ethereum let
me tell you about an important Concept
in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain it is the crypto fuel for
ethereum it can be considered a
transaction fee which has to be paid
when one party sends ethers to another
party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails gas price is expressed
in ether and the miner decides whether
to refuse the transaction process or not
based on the expected gas price one can
see their transaction fee in eth or USD
when searching for the transaction on
etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit the total cost of a transaction is
the product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single transaction
this avoids situations where there is an
error somewhere in the contract and you
end up spending a very high amount of
gas however the units of gas required
for a transaction are defined by the
amount of code executed on the
blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much if enough
gas to cover the computational resources
of the network is not supplied with the
transaction the transaction will fail
due to an out of gas error SO gas is a
commodity which is essentially a cost of
using the system
like Bitcoins ethereum also has its
currency which is called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations it ensures that the
developers write error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost ethereum is a blockchain based
platform and ether is the cryptocurrency
that fuels the platform it is commonly
denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between Bitcoin and ether
Bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is in the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies while
Bitcoin uses
sha-256 to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses ethash to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
Bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier Bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services however ethereum being a
touring complete platform also supports
smart contracts and decentralized
applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies currently the
price of BTC is approximately 3 500 US
Dollars while that of eth is
approximately 100 US dollars the market
cap of BTC is almost six times greater
than that of BTC even though eth has a
higher circulating Supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
BTC is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of BTC is
much slower than eth while btc's
transaction speed is measured in minutes
eth is just a few seconds
like Bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets let's understand
what our wallets in ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies basically a wallet
stores the means of accessing your
currency using the private key
now that I have told you about the
ethereum and its currency
it will only be fair that I explain evm
now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm is an engine which executes
translation code
smart contracts are compiled into
bytecode which an evm can read and
execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi-turing complete
machine it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm bytecode
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm bytecode
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of five eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in
ethereum-specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm byte code and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity solidity
is an object-oriented high-level
language used for implementation of
smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
solidity was influenced by python C plus
plus and JavaScript
it is designed to Target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like language
abbreviated as Triple L it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is Viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is Mouton Mouton is
similar to C like language and supports
a dynamic full higher level language it
compiles to Native ethereum assembler
however Mouton is now deprecated
the last language is Julia it is an
intermediate language that can compile
to various different backends like evm
1.0 evm 1.5 and e w ASM let me now tell
you about the accounts handled by
ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts
eoa is an account controlled by a
private key that has the ability to send
ethers and messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no Associated code
smart contract smart contract is a code
running on top of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other as an account it has the
following properties firstly it has an
ether balance
secondly it has an Associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts and fourthly when
executed it performs operations of
arbitrary complexity some of the
advantages of smart contracts are as
follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes and lastly it lowers
the transaction cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing they operate autonomously
to execute the terms of the contract and
verify the transactions without the need
of a third party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant process
of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works first an optional
contract between the parties is written
as a code into the blockchain the
individuals involved are Anonymous but
the contact is made through a public
Ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike prices hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next Regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract thus
the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes Undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce in an externally owned account
nonce represents the number of
transactions sent from the account's
address however in a contract account
the nonce is the number of contracts
created by the account
the next property is balance this number
shows the amount of way owned by the
address whether the eoa or contract
account each ether is divided into one e
plus 18 Wei the next property is code
hash it is the hash of the ethereum
virtual machine code of an account this
is the code that gets executed if this
address receives a message call it is
immutable and thus it cannot be changed
once the construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string for contract accounts this is the
code that gets hashed and is stored as
the code hash the last property is
storage root it is a 256 bit hash of the
root node of a Merkle tree that encodes
the storage contents of the account
encoded into the tree as a mapping from
the keycac
256-bit hash of the 256-bit integer keys
to the rlp encoded
256-bit integer values this tree encodes
the hash of the storage contents of this
account and is empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts let's understand the
process of mining now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining ethereum makes use of
proof of work mechanism to ensure
security the algorithm used in ethereum
is called ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a miner is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where Bob
wants to send one eth to Alice
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining first Bob attempts to
send Alice one eth once Bob's
transaction is initiated it is combined
with other transactions that have
occurred in the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated The Miner creates a new
block and is rewarded for it
thus Alice receives one eth after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
The Ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 each to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next state for the transaction
State Storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes State routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system State when
the block was created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process to see how ethereum
stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair
this way the last remaining hash becomes
the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three Merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state to maintain
the transactions and to maintain the
receipts also each block always refers
to its previous Block's hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools the ethereum
ecosystem consists of eight major tools
they are Geth
ganache
parody
meta mask
missed wallet
swarm
ipfs
whisper
now let's move forward and take a look
at each of these in detail
gif
is a multi-purpose command line tool
that runs an ethereum node implemented
in go
it is the official golang implementation
of the ethereum protocol and is commonly
used to interact with the ethereum
network
though there are several ways to
download Geth the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache CLI
ganache CLI
ganache CLI is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost thirdly
accounts can be recycled reset and
instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and Mining speed can
be modified fifthly a convenient GUI
gives you an overview of your test chain
events
parody parity is the fastest lightest
and most secure ethereum client that
provides the core infrastructure
Essentials for quick and reliable
services
parity is written in Rust language it
offers better reliability code Clarity
and performance it is an ethereum client
that is integrated directly into your
web browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an ethereum GUI
browser it provides access to a diverse
range of ethereum features including D
apps
metamask
turns Google Chrome into a browser that
allows the users to send and receive
transactions and also fetch data from
the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plug-in to your Chrome
browser it permits you to run ethereum
d-apps directly from your browser
without the need for running a full
ethereum node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain to
overcome this metamask hosts a number of
nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install a
metamask and can automatically get
connected to the nodes thus you can use
the ethereum blockchain seamlessly
let's talk Mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
missed wallet
missed wallet is the end user interface
for ethereum that is developed for
browsing and using d-apps mist is an
official ethereum wallet it was
developed and distributed by the team
which is responsible for the management
of ethereum ecosystem it is usually used
by developers who want to create deploy
and use Smart contracts it is a full
node wallet which means you'll have to
download the entire ethereum blockchain
onto your computer
some of the applications of mist wallet
is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second storing ether
third creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services it acts as a
native base layer service of the
ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
Records to distribute blockchain data as
well as the app codes it leverages the
underlying ethereum infrastructure
through the use of contracts and ethers
to encourage cooperation among nodes the
files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micro payments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs stores data by use of a distributed
hash table or DHT once we know the hash
we request the peer Network who has a
copy of the content located at the
corresponding hash and then we download
the content from the node who has the
desired data which we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in BitTorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time thus it defines how
files move across a network making it a
distributed file system by combining all
of these properties
ipfs is enabling a new permanent web and
augmenting the way we use existing
internet protocols like http
whisper whisper is an identity-based
communication protocol for D apps to
interact with each other
d-apps that need to publish small
amounts of information to each other and
have the publication last some
substantial amount of time prefer using
whisper
for instance a d-app running a currency
exchange may use whisper to record an
offer to buy a currency at a pre-agreed
price on the exchange platform some of
the drawbacks of whisper are as follows
it has low level API which is only
exposed to D apps and never to users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency and
lastly it has no reliable methods for
tracing packets
ethereum Frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
Frameworks
web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node it can be done with
the use of IPC or an HTTP connection the
key connection between ethereum Network
and dap that allows you to compile
deploy and interact with smart contracts
is called web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain let's take an example of
traditional development when you develop
a website it talks to apis using Json or
jQuery to make Ajax calls a website
talks to blockchain using web 3 using
json.rpc which is similar to making a
remote procedure call ethereum comprises
of a large number of nodes which talk to
each other we use Json RPC to make a
request to a particular node which is
like an API call thus if we want to talk
to a Smart contract or read an account
we do it through web 3.
eth.js it is a highly optimized
lightweight JS utility for ethereum
based on web.js in this all the
unnecessary characters are removed from
the source code and the code is reduced
to 160 kilobytes ethereum development
environment the three commonly used
ethereum development environments
include remix IDE truffle and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail remix IDE
remix IDE is a browser-based compiler
and IDE that enables users to debug
transactions and build ethereum
contracts with solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code the next slide shows how
remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle truffle is a development
environment testing framework and asset
pipeline for blockchains using the
ethereum virtual machine or evm it helps
users in developing smart contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications it performs
the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts third managing the complex
systems of interdependent contracts
fourth performing test driven deployment
with contracts using JavaScript
fifth managing different chains like
testnet private net and livenet and
lastly redeploy the contracts if any
changes are done
let's talk about ethereum Networks
ethereum Network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network they are
also referred to as clients they provide
wallet functionality and allow users to
perform transactions on the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
types of network there are three main
types of networks the test net the
mainnet and the private Network
ethereum D apps and daos
D app
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure they run on a
peer-to-peer computer network all the
activity which takes place on an
ethereum decentralized application is
cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
Network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third party intervention and high
security
example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain and 4G Capital these companies
have developed different applications
using blockchain
next we have the daos
d-a-o
daos are organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a Dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works let's consider that a country
is holding elections and wants to
prevent fraud in the voting system
a Dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way so now let's take a
look what's in it for all of us today we
will be talking about what is ethereum
the features of ethereum like
cryptocurrency smart contracts ethereum
virtual machine decentralized
application and it uses and
decentralized autonomous organization
we're also looking at applications of
ethereum and a demo on Smart contract
deployment on a locally running ethereum
client now what is ethereum ethereum is
a blockchain based Computing platform
that enables developers to build and
deploy these centralized applications so
basically ethereum is a platform where
we can build applications which are not
run by a centralized Authority you can
create a decentralized application where
the participants of that particular
application are the decision making
Authority so the hair we can see
ethereum allows us to build and deploy
dap applications now what are the
typical features of ethereum ethereum
allows you to use its own cryptocurrency
called eth it allows development and
deployment of smart contracts it
provides you the underlying technology
the architecture the software which
understands smart contracts and allow
you to interact with it which is called
ethereum virtual machine then it allows
eventually to create Consolidated
applications called decentralized
applications and also it allows you to
create decentralized autonomous
organization now let's talk about
ethereum cryptocurrency ether is a
cryptocurrency that runs on ethereum
network basically it is the fuel which
is running the ethereum network it is
used to pay for the computational
resources and the transaction fees for
any transaction to be executed on a
ethereum network like Bitcoin ether is
also a peer-to-peer currency apart from
paying for transaction ether is also
used to buy gas which is used to pay for
computation of any transaction you make
on an ethereum Network also if you have
to deploy a contract on ethereum network
you will need gas and you would have to
pay for that gas in ethers SO gas is the
execution fee paid by a user for running
a transaction in ethereum ether can be
utilized for building decentralized
applications for building your smart
contracts and making standard
peer-to-peer payments now what is a
smart contract a smart contract is a
simple computer program that facilitates
the exchange of any valuable asset
between two parties it could be money it
could be shares it could be property or
it could be any other digital asset
which you want to exchange these
contracts can be created by anyone on
the ethereum network and primarily the
contract consists of the terms and
conditions mutually agreed between the
parties between the peers and the
primary feature of a smart contract is
that once it is executed it cannot be
altered and any transaction done on top
of a smart contract is registered
permanently it is immutable so even in
future you modify the smart contract the
transactions correlated with the
original contract gears not get altered
or you cannot modify them so for the
verification process smart contract is
carried out amongst the anonymous
parties of the network without the need
of a centralized Authority and that's
what makes any smart contract execution
on ethereum a decentralized execution it
provides the transfer of any asset or
currency in a transparent and a
trustworthy manner as the two entities
are totally unaware their identity is
secure on the ethereum network though
the transactions weren't successfully
done the accounts of the sender and
receiver are updated accordingly and
there's why it generates a trust between
the parties who are transacting using
the ethereum network now what happens in
traditional system of contract in
traditional systems of contract you sign
an agreement then you trust a third
party hire a third party for execution
now the problem is that in such an
engagement the data tampering is
possible now if we talk about the new
smart contract the agreement is coded in
a program now result is not verified by
a centralized Authority it is verified
by the participants on ethereum based
blockchain Network now once a contract
is executed the transaction is
registered and it cannot be altered or
tampered so it removes the risk of any
data manipulation or alteration now
let's take another example where Jack
has given a contract of 500 to Elsa for
developing his company's website now the
Developers code the agreement of smart
contract using ethereum's programming
language now the smart contract has all
the conditions the requirements for
building the website once the code is
written it is uploaded and deployed on
the ethereum evm virtual machine evm is
a runtime compiler to execute your smart
contract once the code is deployed on
the evm every participant on the network
has a copy of the contract now now when
Alpha submits the work on ethereum for
evaluation each node on the ethereum
network will evaluate and confirm
whether the result given by Elsa is done
as per the coding requirements and once
approved and verified the contract worth
500 dollars will be self-executed and
the payment will be paid to Elsa in
ethers so John's account the person who
had gone into a contract his account
will be automatically debited and Elsa
will be credited with 500 in ether
denomination here we will now take a
look we will do a demo small demo on a
deployment of a smart contract so for in
order to execute our smart contract we
will need two set of softwares ganache
and truffle and we will show you in the
demo how to install these two softwares
on your machine now we will be giving a
demo on the following smart contract
this is a smart contract where we are
writing a simple contract of greeter we
have a variable called greeting which we
will be initializing using a Constructor
and then in our demo we will be showing
how you can change the value of the
variable greeting using the set greeting
method and read the value using the grid
method this is the other contract where
we will be defining that whoever is
deploying the contract on the blockchain
network is always the owner of the
contract and then we have defined
certain mandatory functions in order to
kill the contract on the ethereum
network so only the the owner of the
contract can kill it now let's talk
about what is an ethereum virtual
machine it's your virtual machine is
designed to operate as a runtime
environment for compiling and deploying
ethereum based smart contracts basically
evm is the engine which understands the
language of smart contracts which are
written in solidity language for
ethereum evm is operated in a sandbox
environment basically you can deploy
your own Standalone environment which
can act as a testing and a development
environment and you can n number of
times test your smart contract deploy it
verify it and then once you are
satisfied with the performance and the
functionality of the smart contract you
can deploy it on the ethereum main net
now any programming language in the
smart contract is compiled into the byte
code which the evm understands this byte
code can be read and executed you using
an ethereum feature called ethereum
virtual machine so basically evm machine
under stands a byte code so one of the
most popular languages for writing a
smart contract is solidity so once you
write your smart contract on solidity
that contract gets converted into the
byte code and gets deployed on the EV
and thereby evm guarantees security from
Cyber attack now how does evm work so
suppose a wants to pay B 10 ethers the
transaction will be sent to the evm
using a smart contract for a funds
transfer from A to B now in order to
validate the transaction the ethereum
network will perform the proof of work
consensus algorithm the minor nodes on
the ethereum will validate this
transaction whether the first the
identity of a exist or not a has the
relevant amount of balance to transfer
10 ether to B and in will validate the
transaction once validated The Ether
will be debited from A's wallet and will
be credited to B's wallet and during
this course the miners will charge your
fees in order to validate this
transaction and will earn a reward now
all the nodes on ethereum network
execute smart contract using their
respective evns now how does proof of
work works every node in the ethereum
network has the entire history of all
the transactions the entire chain it has
the history of smart contract with
basically the address at which the smart
contract is deployed the transactions
associated with the smart contract and
also it has the handle to the current
state of the smart contract now the goal
of the miners on the ethereum blockchain
network is to validate the block for
each block of transaction miners use the
computational power and resources to get
the appropriate hash value by varying
the nonce now the miners will vary the
nons and pass it through a hashing
algorithm in case of ethereum it is the
it hash algorithm this produces a hash
value which should be lesser than in the
predefined Target as per the proof of
work consensus if the hash value
generated is less than the target value
then only the block is considered to be
verified and the miner gets rewarded
only then now when the proof of work is
solved result is broadcasted and shared
with all the other nodes in order to
update their Ledger if other nodes
accept the hash block as valid then the
block gets added to the ethereum main
net blockchain and as a result The Miner
receives a reward which as of today
stands at three ethers plus the miner
receives the transaction fees which has
been generated for verifying the block
all the transactions which are
aggregated in the block the cumulative
transaction fees associated with all the
transactions is also rewarded to The
Miner now do you know in ethereum a
process called proof of stake is also
under development and it is an
alternative to proof of work it is meant
to be a solution to minimize the use of
expense sensitive resources you spend
for mining using proof of work now in
proof of stake The Miner is actually the
validator can validate the transactions
based on the amount of crypto coins he
or she holds before he or she can start
the mining So based on the accumulation
or the repository of crypto coins with
the miner beforehand will give him the
higher probability of mining the block
now however proof of stake is not widely
adopted as of now as compared to proof
of work algorithm now let's understand
the concept of gas now ethereum virtual
machine has a concept of gas and why do
we need it so like we need fuel to run
car in the same way in order to run
application on ethereum network we need
gas now what is gas to perform any
transactional ethereum network a user
has to make a payment has to Shell out
ethers in order to get the execution
done the transaction done and the
intermediary monetary value is called as
gas on ethereum Network gas is a unit
that measures the computational power
required to run a smart contract or a
transaction so if you have to do a
transaction which is updating the
blockchain you would have to Shell out
gas and that gas will come with a price
in ethers now how is the gas fees
calculated in ethereum the transaction
fees is calculated in ethereum using the
below formula for every transaction
there is a gas and the correlated gas
price so the amount of gas required to
execute a transaction multiplied by the
gas price you generate the transaction
fees so gas limit on ethereum network
refers to the amount of gas which is
used for the computation and the amount
of ether a user is required to pay for
the gas now here we have a screenshot
from the ethereum name mainnet where the
cost of transaction is being shown so if
you see for this particular example
transaction the gas limit was twenty one
thousand the gas used by the transaction
was 21 000 and the gas price was 21 GUI
which is the lowest denomination so 21
GUI into 21 000 gave you the actual
transaction fees which is
0.00441 ether which is approximately
0.21 cents as of today's ether market
value now this transaction fee goes to
the miner who has validated the
transaction to understand the gas limit
and the gas price in a better way let's
consider an example of a car suppose
your car has a mileage of 10 kilometers
and the price of petrol is one dollar
per liter then driving a car for 50
kilometers will cost you 5 liters of
petrol which will be worth five dollars
similarly to perform an operation or to
run a code on ethereum you need to
obtain certain amount of gas like the
patrol where each gas has a per unit
price called gas price now if the user
provides less amount of gas to run a
particular operation then the process
will fail and the user will be given a
message of out of gas and GUI is the
lowest denomination of ether which is
used for measuring unit of a gas price
now how is ethereum's mining different
from Bitcoin mining the hashing
algorithm is the primary difference the
Bitcoin uses sha256 ethereum uses it
hash the average time taken on bitcoin
for mining a block is 10 minutes whereas
in ethereum it is 12 to 15 seconds as of
today the mining rewards for Bitcoin is
12.5 BTC but for ethereum this is three
ethers plus the transaction fee the
cumulated transaction fee for all the
transactions for a block now as of 23rd
July the Bitcoin value was
7667 dollars whereas one ether turns at
466 dollars now here we have a
screenshot of ethereum reward which has
been given to the miner of the block now
as you can see here is the breakup of
the reward three ethers plus the total
accumulated transaction fee of all the
underlying transactions in this block
which is 0.0666 ethers now what is a
decentralized application now let's
compare it with our traditional
applications our traditional websites
which are currently running so for
example when you log into Twitter a web
application gets displayed which is
rendered using an HTML page now the page
will call an API to access your personal
data your information which is centrally
hosted now it's a simple process your
front end executes a backend API and the
API goes and pitches the information
from a centralized DB now if we
transform this application into a
decentralized application then now when
you will log in the same web application
will get rendered but it will be calling
a smart contract based API to fetch the
information from the blockchain network
so the API gets replaced with the smart
contract interface and the smart
contract will fetch the information from
the blockchain network which is its
backend and that blockchain network is
not a centralized DB it's a
decentralized network where the
participants of the network the miners
of the network are validating verifying
all the transactions which are happening
using the smart contract on the
blockchain network so thereby any now
any transaction or any action happening
on the Twitter kind of application which
has been transformed will now cannot be
claimed as a centralized transaction it
will be a decentralized transaction
adapt a decentralized application
consists of backend code that runs on a
distributed peer-to-peer Network it is a
software designed to work on an ethereum
Network without being controlled by a
centralized system and that is the
primary difference it provides the
direct interaction between the end users
and the decentralized application
providers now an application qualifies
as that when it is open sourced its code
is there on GitHub and it uses a public
blockchain based token in order to run
the application a token acts as a fuel
for the decentralized application to run
dap allows the backend code and data to
be decentralized and that is the primary
architecture of any DAC now let's
discuss what are decentralized
autonomous organizations daus is a
digital organizations that wants to
operate without any need of a
hierarchical management it wants to
operate in a decentralized and a
democratized fashion so basically a Dao
is an organization where the decision
making should not be in the hands of a
centralized Authority but it should be
in the hands of certain designated
authorities or a group of designated
people as a part of authority it exists
on a blockchain network where it is
governed by the protocols embedded in a
smart contract and thereby they rely on
smart contract for decision making all
the business decisions are driven by the
smart contracts or we can say a
decentralized voting system within the
organization so any organizational
decision before being taken has to go
through the voting system which is
running on a decentralized application
so how it work people add funds to the
Dow because Dao requires funding in
order to execute and take decisions
based on that each member is given a
token on a percentage basis which
represents the percentage of shares of
that particular member in the Dow now
those tokens are used to vote in the Dao
where the proposal status is decided
based on the maximum votes so every
decision within the organization has to
go through this voting process now let's
take a look what are the applications of
ethereum in real world and where it is
getting used so as we have seen with Dao
voting systems are adopting it the
results of the polls are publicly
available where it ensures a transparent
and fair democracy by eliminating voting
malpractices it is getting adopted
widely in a banking scenarios and
banking systems with ethereum's
decentralized system it is becoming very
difficult for hackers to have
unauthorized access and it also allows
payments on a ethereum based Network so
banks are also using ethereum as a
channel to make remittances and payments
shipping deploying ethereum and shipping
helps tracking of cargo and prevents
goods from being misplaced or
counterfeited so basically ethereum is
providing you of the provenance and
tracking framework for any kind of asset
required in a typical supply chain now
with ethereum's smart contract
agreements can be maintained and
executed without any alteration so any
industry which has fragmented
participants is subject to disputes and
which requires and digital contracts to
be present then ethereum can definitely
be used as a technology for developing
your smart contract and digitally
recording the agreements and the
transactions based on those agreements
so let's get started for a demo on how
to deploy an ethereum smart contract
locally so in order to deploy a smart
contract we will be first installing
ganache client which allows you to host
a local ethereum client on which you can
deploy your smart contract so as we are
working on the Windows environment when
we are downloading the ganache setup we
can also download node order to install
ruffle on our machines
now as the node has been downloaded we
will install node
so now node is successfully installed
now we are going to install ganache
locally
now we will run ganache a little later
before that we will perform certain
steps or we can run ganache and C so
once Ganesh is up and running I'll show
you the interface how it looks
so when ganache is brought up it
automatically creates 10 accounts with
pre-funded balance of 100 ethers it is
running on localhost port number
7545 now as you see there is no
transaction or anything which has
currently happened so the current block
is 0 which is the Genesis block there
are no transactions and there are no
blocks as of now so there are no
transactions in Block which have been
generated so using this ganache client
now we will be deploying our Grita
contract now as we have installed node
we will be installing truffle ruffle is
the utility which allows us to compile
and deploy ethereum contracts
okay now once truffle is installed we
need to create a directory called
greeter
now we need to run the command truffle
now once we run this command
ruffle by default creates a package
structure which has three folders called
contracts migrations test truffle.js and
truffle config now we will be writing
our smart contract called
greeter.soul and we will compile and
deploy basically our greeter dot soul
will be under contracts folder and we
can
our contract is created and it is lying
under contracts folder now we need to
add another file under migrations folder
called as deploycontract.js
so we will aim it as deploy contract now
in this deploy contract we need to put
line of code
now in this file we are asking truffle
to deploy our newly created greeter.soul
file now in the greater contract we have
a Constructor we are initializing the
greater contract with the value High
hello and we are passing a gas value so
this gas is currently at a higher limits
and we know that this gas value the
contract will get executed but otherwise
you can also evaluate the gas value of a
contract using remix now once this file
is being saved you go to the truffle.js
and make the following entry
now here we are trailing truffle that
our Local Host ganache client is running
on localhost at Port number 7545 and
network ID can be anything though the
current ganache client is running on
Port network ID 577 but we have kept it
open that we can connect to any network
ID now after this step I need to go back
to my command prompt and say truffle
company
now if you get this error if we are
getting this kind of error in Windows
then we need to do one quick fix
you need to go to the users directory
and rename truffle.cmg to trough so I'll
go to my e-drive users
just
now here now instead of truffle I have
to say trough
now there might be certain compilation
warnings we can ignore that now my
contract is being compiled now I need to
run the next command trough my grade
at this stage my smart contract is
deployed and now you can see
this is the step this is the place where
the contract has been called and this is
the transaction where the default value
of my variable greeter has been set to
high hello so we will see now I need to
run command trust console
to interact with my contract now as on
my trough console I can check at what
address is my contract deployed so my
contract is deployed at address 0x37
which matches with the address 0x373
now I need to check the default value
which I had said while deploying my
contract so this is my value hi hello
now I can change the value to something
else because in my Grita contract I have
a method called set greeting now
whenever when I'll be performing this
action a new block will get generated
and the block count will increase from 4
to 5 because I am making a change on the
blockchain as you can see now a new
transaction has been created this was
the gas used this is the default gas
price in ganache and block number five
is being mined now I can re-read the
value of the variable now it will return
me the latest value which is change grid
value so this demonstrates how to use a
solidity contract how to compile it
deploy it on a locally running
blockchain Network you can connect
connect multiple nodes to this ganache
client and all the nodes should be
running on the same network ID should
have the same network ID but they can be
running on a different machine so here
we can see all the other details the
block the transactions which have
happened if I perform the action again
Rock number six has been generated has
another transaction associated with it
and I can get the latest value so why
wait let's embark on this exhilarating
adventure together
but before we dive in if you're looking
to take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field
in this video we will explore ethereum
Mining and we'll go through some of the
fascinating Concepts and components
revolving around it both we will have an
introduction to ethereum
then we will understand what is ethereum
mining
then we will explore why should we minor
theorem
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we can understand how the
criteria mining process works
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
thick translation kill Google work
and then finally we will find out is
Mining ethereum Profitable
so without doing Much Ado let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
the time is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decent life applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
ether is the cryptography of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it traps and
facilitates all the transactions
that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple word ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof of work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the minor
miners is a community of people using a
hashing strip etash to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why you need to
mine ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a trademark factors
ignoring the network into a relatively
complex but profitable business also
miners receive a certain amount as a
reward for money each block of the
ethereum blockchain network including
the transaction fees paid by the users
thus it has a mining benefit each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
foreign mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways if they're in Solo mining
ethereum poor lining and ethereum Cloud
mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine the Italian block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also sole mining is only profitable when
you have plenty of resources with you
like 100 plus graphics card
and in Solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of area needed
a taken pool timing is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with Terraria
mining in this you work along with other
people together in a single pool and if
someone from the pool gets the hash code
correctly they share the reward among
everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool like room
size minimum payout and cool fee
four sides determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares the word
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get rewards also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
Italian you need to mine before it gets
credited to your wallet and Port key is
the amount you need to pay to continue
using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
it's adding Cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you you pay some amount of money as
keys to them for investing their time
and resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward the gain by the mining material
this this technique of mining ethereum
have to close and consume so you're not
responsible for any equipment damage you
don't have to acquire all the necessary
equipment and look for ample space to
store it
you can set back of the market and enjoy
the reward for your investment in their
mining
Con in the Italian price drop then there
is no way you are getting your money
back the money you invested or the fees
paid to The Miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
ethereum Cloud mining is considered a
safer way for mining service provider to
guarantee a profit for the resource they
have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
if you're in mind follows a specific set
of steps to function
Step 1 a user request for transaction
with the help of the private key of its
digital Wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 The Miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transactional data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified and it stores a copy of it in
EDM in the process of inform work Begins
for the respective block
step 6 then the notes of the ethereum
network verify how the checksum of the
state of the minus Block matches the
checksum of the updated state of Indian
after execution of all transactions
set 7 only after that the blocks is
added to the ethereum blockchain network
set in on successfully mining the block
it rewards The Miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet the block reward
of ethereum is three ether
and step 9 the requested processing is
approved and credited to the respective
wallet or wallet
each transaction is mined only one with
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
Miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are an essential wallet is
stored on your currency earned
GPU drivers or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb RAM
a mining software suitable according to
your Hardware like GTO
and a compatible operating system the
Windows 7 or 10 with 64-bit
before getting started with mining
Italian you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your info press the
Model T and Legend Nano are the most
reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing GPU drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet
you'll need to update all the hardware
that is drives in your system
you can use two types of graphics card
they are AMD graphics card and Nvidia
graphics card
Claymore is considered the best
profitable mining ethereum on GQ drivers
now we need to follow a few set of step
to get started with mining
Step 1 download the latest version of
claymon dual Miner for the operating
system the latest version is Claymore
11.0
Step 2 click on the latest version of
Windows and download the zip file
that we extract the file to play mode
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5 right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6 edit the start.exe file and add
these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better Source results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your pool address instead
of mining pool address
step 9 save your start.txt file with
your new updates remember while saving
select type as all files
and set 10 once you see click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all existing miners of ethereum
network with a limited time to earn a
return for the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021 or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
October 2020 but the history of delays
regarding this upgrade is worth talking
about
nobody told notes when I tell him 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now will we know all about ethereum
mining this makes me wonder if Italian
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area as a rule anything
below
0.12 per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered profitable you can mind ether
and turn it into a vital source of
income by analyzing these figures like
hash rate of ethereum blocked reward
number of blocks per day and the coin
price of ethereum
this is also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors or you can use this
formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and save an ethereum
in this video I will take you through
various important Concepts and
components of ethereum classic first we
will look into the origin of ethereum
classic
then we will understand what is ethereum
followed by why is the theorem classic
used what are the goals of ethereum
classic and after that we will see the
difference between ethereum classic and
ethereum after that we will look at some
of the limitations of the ethereum
classic and at the end we will explore
what is the future of ethereum classic
so without any further Ado let's get
started with the video so let's start
with the origin of ethereum classic
clock.it a German business created Dao a
decentralized autonomous organization or
Dao initiated on ethereum in 2016.
while the project earned over 150
million dollars through crowdfunding
hackers took advantage of a flaw in its
smart contract and stole 50 million
dollars
most ethereum users including creators
with Alec buterin and Gavin would favor
the heart 4 are a major modification in
the blockchain's underlying protocol
to recover the assets resulting in the
formation of the new ethereum chain
however certain members of the community
opposed to the form
preferring to follow the principle of
code is Law and remained on the old
chain
naming it ethereum classic
the commonly refer to ethereum Classic
as the original ethereum coin since it
preserves the ancient core of the
ethereum blockchain as it existed before
the da over salt that brings us to the
next concern which is to understand what
what is ethereum classic
um classic is a blockchain based open
source decentralized distributed
cryptocurrency platform that runs smart
contracts
ethereum classic is a decentralized
governance platform that leverages smart
contracts embedded within a distributed
Ledger or blockchain Network
it splits the original ethereum
blockchain into two parts with ethereum
classic being the owner of the two and
ethereum being the newer one now let's
proceed further and have a look at the
uses of Italian classic
Italian classic has three major uses
the ETC or ethereum classic like other
cryptocurrencies is primarily used to
pay for decentralized computations on
the ethereum network
Etc is used to pay for executing
transactions and smart contract
functions on the ethereum blockchain
this is referred to as gas and the fee
associated with these actions are known
as gas costs
Etc is also a native token with a
monetary policy that creates a
predictable
distillationary emission scheduled with
the fixed market supply cap
now let's move ahead and have a look at
the goals of ethereum classic
the ethereum classic project has seen
several modifications and additions
since the split the Project's purpose is
to develop a global payment network
based on Smart contracts that can
operate with no centralized Authority
ethereum classic like other
cryptocurrencies will most likely aspire
to be a digital store of value meaning
you can see and exchange it while
maintaining its worth
a crypto's digital store of value
includes its purchasing power which may
be strictly converted to cash or used to
purchase another asset just like money
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
all major
and have a look at how ethereum classic
differs from ethereum
is a speculative digital asset that
investors May trade but the ethereum
token or eth is the more genuine and
extensively traded of the two
with a market capitalization of 3.9
billion dollars
Etc has
116.3 million coins in circulation
while eth on the other hand has a market
capitalization of more than 304.9
billion dollars and around 115.6 million
coins in circulation
EDC trades at
33.65 dollars whereas eth trades for
more than 2 600 per coin now let's have
a look at the limitations of ethereum
classic
although ethereum classic like ethereum
enables smart contracts and targets the
same Market ethereum has grown in
popularity as the more trustworthy of
the two Network despite numerous
software upgrades the scalability of
ethereum Classics payment mechanism
remains one of the Project's largest
concern in the future
furthermore security is likely to be an
issue with smart contracts especially
because ethereum classic has already
been hacked and millions of dollars
stolen so this brings us to the very
important question that is what future
ethereum classic holds for itself
because ethereum is considered the more
authentic of the two networks Italian
Classics future appears to be less
bright than ethereum specially given
ethereum classic security concerns
ethereum classic may have difficulties
and can modify its code and software to
prevent future hacks
well this was all about Italian classic
in this video we will explore ethereum
2.0 and we'll go through some of the
fascinating Concepts and components
revolving around it
first we will have a quick introduction
of what is ethereum Network
then we will look into what ethereum 2.0
is
then we will understand what led to the
origin of ethereum 2.0
then we will understand the changes in
ethereum 2.0
then we will look into the current
status of ethereum 2.0 research
and at last for future we expect for
ethereum 2.0
so without doing Much Ado let's get
started with the video
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
either is the cryptocurrency for
ethereum used to build decentralized
application smart contracts and make
standard peer-to-peer payments it tracks
and facilitates all the transactions and
makes sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the religion of
ethereum 2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions currently it is capable
of handling 15 to 45 transactions per
second which is comparatively impressive
but it is not enough to handle all of
Italian's users worldwide also the high
demand is affecting the driving up a
transaction fees
notes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.2
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of state and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work to record and
validate their transactions
the problems with proof of Works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain undergoes verification by all
participating nodes that means now the
speed of its fluids participant limits
the processing speed of the entire
network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the Network's overall
capacity and make it much faster at
efficient than its updated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
while ethereum 2.2 has been in research
and development since 2014. it has
actually been making some progress the
beacon chain went live in December 2020
introducing this taking concept but
still there is no official claim for the
completion of this transition
the next piece is minute
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum Network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increase transactions per
second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way to completing
the whole trans session so what the
future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total Game
Changer it will create a modified
Network that could potentially process
One lag transactions per second
the much more sustainable Network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide increasing the
ethereum's network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
Alec buterin once said that the issuance
of new Docker should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain Network let's
proceed further and have a look at how
they both differ from each other did you
know there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide
and among them Bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
Bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide Trading
according to decrypt.com Everyday new
companies like me too and people are
coming forward to invest in Bitcoin and
ethereum on March 7 2021 need to
confirmed that it had purchased 40
million in Bitcoin and ethereum on the
other hand PayPal is about to launch a
scheme with the public in purchase and
sell cryptocurrencies initially
featuring Bitcoin and ethereum via
Paypal digital wallet but have you all
ever wondered how they compare based on
their similarities and differences in
various aspects well before moving any
further let's have a quick look at how
Bitcoin and ethereum originated and made
a benchmark in the economic system
worldwide
Bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
Satoshi Nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after Bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
it themselves as a Computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance and that particular field
first we will look into the introduction
of ethereum and Bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language
mining process of ethereum and Bitcoin
monetary policy
transaction
and availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time Bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
Bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for Bitcoin it is an
alternative to Fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using daps or decentralized application
on the other side Bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain Network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the itash cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
Bitcoin uses the sag-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
Bitcoin Network
algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy a certain Network requirements
sat 256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private Keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum and Bitcoin
ethereum uses solidity solidity is a
high level programming language used by
ethereum for implementing smart
contracts but in terms of programming
language Bitcoin keeps it simple Bitcoin
uses C plus plus as its programming
language it is a stack based programming
language used to give Bitcoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both mining is
a process in which transaction made are
validated and added to blockchain public
Ledger and blocks and the people mining
these blocks are called miners ethereum
mine is mine the unvalidated transaction
using the proof of work method but it
aims to switch to proof of stake because
it will make its Network more immune to
centralization energy efficient and
stronger support for a shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the proof of
work method to mine unvalidated
transactions these method is enough to
function in Bitcoin Network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies but
let's first understand what monetary
policy is monetary policy is known as
the process of drafting announcing and
implementing the plan of actions taken
by the compete and monetary authority to
control the money supply and Achieve
goals that promote sustainable economic
growth so ethereum's policy is defined
by the reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises of
two parts having and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining Bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of Bitcoins
you get if you successfully mine a
blockchain block the current block
reward for ethereum is to either per
block and for Bitcoin the block reward
is 12.5 Bitcoins per block also every 14
seconds a block of ethereum is generated
and one block of Bitcoin take 10 minutes
to generate monetary policies are
considered to be fixed and
non-inflationary due to this over time
mining blocks will become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
Bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and Bitcoin is only
used as the value for real world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and Google pay a determine Bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption now talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies ethereum is not limited
but it can occasionally reduce due to
large Network upgrades however Bitcoin
is limited to 21 million coins and as of
today 18 million Bitcoin is already used
but in the end both Bitcoin and ethereum
being the top cryptocurrencies share a
few similarities like both a decent
utilized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction proof of work
also both have a large network of
independent nodes choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's have a demo now let's have a
look at the media outlet website
coindesk where we will see all stats
related to bitcoin and ethereum in
detail coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies it is used to explore
the news and price data related to
cryptocurrencies and also explains how
cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration this graph shows the gradual
change in the price of Bitcoin it
started from 64
439.29 on April 14 at 12 pm and right
now by April 15 at 6 00 am it is at 63
189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
which shows the change in the price of
Bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2. the value of ethereum
started at
2388.13 on April 14 at 12 pm and the
current status on April 15 is positive
with a value of
2442.37 with an increasing rate of 4.67
down below we have a metrics table that
shows the change between the starting
and ending value of ethereum the total
supply of a cryptocurrency in 24 hours
the total number of transactions that
occur and the average transaction fee
for all these transactions now this
graph shows the current status of
cryptocurrency in USD dollars we can
also see its value according to any
centralized currency like Euro or INR
this graph shows the concentrating
change in the value of cryptocurrencies
every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an R to its lifetime so let me tell
you that Dogecoin is an old coin and an
almost sarcastic mean coin that serves
as a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency well that's not enough
so let's dive down and understand the
concept of Dogecoin more precisely hey
everyone I'm shamli and I welcome you
all to this new video of Simply learn on
what is Dogecoin
but before starting let's have a look at
why is it in the news
it's the beginning of the year 2021
Dogecoin has surged more than 950
percent from less than half a penny to
more than 5 cents per Dogecoin then Elon
Musk CEO of test line corporation took
his interest in it and tweeted too much
concentration is the only real issue for
cryptocurrency making the owner of the
Dogecoin wallet a subject of attention
later on are the celebs like Snoop Dogg
also started taking an interest in
Dogecoin and started tweeting and
promoting it on social platforms which
made Dogecoin climb to a peak of 8.2 us
cents and market capitalization of 10
billion dollars in this video we will
come across the following topics first
we will see the origin of Dogecoin and
then we will understand what is Dogecoin
how does it exactly works and then we
will see what led to the growth of
Dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of Dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of those going today
and lastly how can we buy it let's start
with the origin of Dogecoin
Dogecoin was invented by two software
Engineers IBM engineer Billy Marcus and
Adobe engineer Jackson farmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the Year 2013 Bitcoin and
Deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is Dogecoin Dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a Beat coin inspired by Shiba inu's
popular meme AKA Doge moving ahead let's
have a look at how it works to
understand the workflow let's take the
example of two friends Mark and Susan
owe some money to Susan and now he needs
to return it
so it thinks of an idea and decides to
send her Dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital Wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information first his private key and
second her public key
to get access to Susan's private key he
needs to scan a QR code from his
smartphone
then the application alerts all the
Dogecoin miners around the world to
proceed further with the process the
Dogecoin miners validate where the Mark
has enough Dogecoin to make the payment
or not and after the validation process
they approve the transaction request
Dogecoin miners race with each other to
collect all the data of the pending
transaction known as the nons
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for the particular nouns of the
pending transaction The Miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 Dogecoin in
his account
after that Mark and Susan gets a
confirmation message that the request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of Dogecoin is credited into the
wallet as Susan thus the transaction is
completed so what led to the growth of
Dogecoin Dogecoin officially Came live
in 2013 and became an instant hit within
the community of people who just wanted
to play around the cryptocurrencies
freely
as I said earlier Dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for Content creators but
they were very well received it uses of
Internet forums like Reddit and Twitter
adopted Dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
Dogecoin made its surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically Bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000 for a NASCAR driver Josh
Weiss and in return he printed the logo
n98 Dodge Coin over this race car
eventually it almost became the mascot
for what crypto should be let's have a
look at who uses Dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants Grocers web hosting products
retailer ebook Sellers and travel
Services uses Dogecoin for transaction
these are a few example of companies in
every sector that uses Dogecoin Ross's
hello pets gamerheats.com for web
hosting
gamer for products retailer meltdown and
nordx ebook seller canal and travel
services like Velo leo.it this makes me
curious about the current value of
Dogecoin let's have a look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is
0.059357 USD with a trading volume of 16
billion dollars the circulating supply
of this cryptocurrency is 129 billion
Dogecoin and the max supply of Dogecoin
is not available
how can we buy Dogecoin
so to buy Dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps Step 1 open a digital
wallet buy your coin is considered a
perfect application for trading
cryptocurrencies Step 2 register your
account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhar card step 4 add your
bank account details step 5 secure your
account by creating a convenient trading
pin that is only accessible by you
and step 6.
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about Dogecoin did you know
that on 20th April 2020 those coins
search its value to one dollar making
this day named after itself as
the supporters of Dogecoin were trying
to amplify the value of it to make it
one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called mining and this is what affected
torch coin resulting in the rise of its
value
mining coins of the Dogecoin network is
called Dogecoin mining
hey everyone I'm shamli and I welcome
you all to this new video Simply learn
on a very interesting topic of Dogecoin
mining
we will cover all the concepts of
Dogecoin Mining and we will understand
how to mine Dogecoin all by itself
now let's move ahead and see what's in
this video for you
first we will have an introduction to
what is Dogecoin
then we will figure out the net worth of
Dogecoin today
we will understand what Dogecoin mining
is
then we will have a comparison of mining
process of Dogecoin with a few other
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
then we will dive into how to mine
Dogecoin
in this segment first we will see types
of Dogecoin mining like pool and solo
then we will see what exactly you
require to start Dogecoin mining What
hardware and software you need for those
coin mining
and then we will understand A New
Concept of Dogecoin mining which is
Dogecoin Cloud mining
and in the end we will analyze where the
Dogecoin mining is profitable or not
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is togecoin
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology also it provides its users a
completely unknown decentralized and
secure environment free from any
third-party interference to make their
transactions
to secure all its transactions this
makes me curious to know what is a net
worth and availability of those coin
today
according to market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is 0.266 247
USD the circulating supply of the
cryptocurrency is 127 billion Dogecoin
so that brings us to what is Dogecoin
mining
Dogecoin mining is a process of
validating the data blocks of
transactions by solving a complex
mathematical problem and adding them to
the Dogecoin Network
each confirmation of transactions adds a
new block to the Dogecoin Network
miners perform this process Dogecoin
miners are a community of people who
perform complex mathematical Solutions
on the transactions for mining Dogecoin
that makes me wonder what the difference
between Dogecoin Mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining crosses
let's have a comparison between those
coin mining and the Bitcoin mining
process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors first algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm Dogecoin mining uses
script Bitcoin mining uses sh-256
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the SSG 256 algorithm
making mining easier for miners of the
Dogecoin Network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty Dogecoin is
2798 thousand
252 Bitcoin is 3 trillion 511 billion 60
million
899 thus the crews that Dogecoin is easy
to mine among other cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is a Time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
Dogecoin is one minute for Bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at fourth and fifth we have reward
per block and per block USD
it is the amount
in USD to The Miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for Dogecoin is 10 000
dogecoins per block which in USD is
27.36 dogecoins for Bitcoin it is 12.5
Bitcoin per block and in USD it is 86
391.63 Bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine Dogecoin
Dogecoin can be mined in two ways the
first one Dogecoin pool Mining and the
second is solo mining
a Dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
Dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of Mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between Dogecoin pool Mining
and solo mining
in Dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees in Dogecoin
solo mining you don't need to pay any
fees and you're mine all by yourself
also in pool mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the poor
one button solo mining the total reward
earned will be received by you only
as in coal mining many people work
together so the Mind blocks more often
and on the other side solar mining could
take a lot of time before one mine their
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in Solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about Dogecoin pool
Mining and solo mining let's proceed
further and see what we need to start
mining Dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us a PC with any operating system
like Windows Linux Ubuntu Etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the
dogecoins you mind which hardware and
software can we use for Dogecoin mining
you will need your PC CPU which should
be powerful enough to mine Dogecoin a
GPU a graphics card can also be used for
mining Dogecoin for example Sapphire
pulse Radeon RX 580 Asus RX Vega 64 and
many more
stripped Asics minor is programmed to
mine script based cryptocurrencies like
Dogecoin like bitmain and minor L3
bwl21 script Miner Etc
if you are new to Dogecoin mining then
using your PC CPU will be the right
choice and CPU minus the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using GPU
or graphics card you can have a wide
range of software
some of the best software is Buddha
Miner which works perfectly with Nvidia
products CG Miner which works with most
GPU hardware and easy Miner is
considered suitable for beginners
script as IC minus are considered to be
very powerful hardware and multi-miner
is excellent with this Hardware moving
ahead let's understand what Dogecoin
Cloud mining is
is a mechanism to mine Dogecoin using
rented data centers without installing
any hardware and related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in Dogecoin mining at a very
low cost making Dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the Dogecoin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance a direct energy cost
this whole concept of Dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
this dot coin Mining Profitable
Dogecoin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumptions
hash rate and cost the Dogecoin mining
calculator is used to make it simple in
this calculator
the default value for the latest
Dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
Dogecoin difficulty Target is pre-loaded
for better results Dodge Coin mining's
reward is
44 lakh 44
412.25 dollars per year that is 14
million Doge per year the block time for
Dogecoin is one minute which means the
supply of Dogecoin will never go down
after deducting mining power costs and
Mining fees the final daily Dogecoin
mining profit is 22.53 dollars Dogecoin
to USD with the profit margin of
positive 81.72
also I think Dogecoin mining is fun
so that is all about Dogecoin mining but
before moving any further let's see what
we have for you in this video
first we will have a quick introduction
to what is Dogecoin
followed by how to buy Dogecoin then we
will understand what a Dogecoin wallet
is and what are the types of those coin
wallet
then we will look into how to create a
Dogecoin wallet and how to use it
after that we will figure out why
Dogecoin is so popular
and finally we will go through the top 5
Dogecoin wallets in 2021
so without wasting any time let's get
started what is Dogecoin
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on a
blockchain technology also it provides
its users a completely unknown
decentralized and secure environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transactions Dogecoin uses
cryptography to secure all its
transactions now let's proceed further
and have a look at the process of how to
buy Dogecoin
you can buy Dogecoin by following these
Steps step 1 create a Dogecoin wallet
step 2 locate your specific Dogecoin
address which is a long array of
characters that starts from capital D
followed by any other Capital character
or any number
and step 3 find a source that sells
storage coin and voila buy Dodge coins
so that brings us to what is Dogecoin
wallet
a Dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a real
live wallet
Dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key connecting it to the
distributed Ledger over the Dogecoin
Network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
Dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user the private key of
your wallet is used to approve
transactions in The Ledger
your wallet's public key is used to
receive dogecoins from other users on
the other hand your wallet's private key
is only used to send those points to
other users in the network so what are
the types of Dogecoin wallet
wallet is of two types digital Dogecoin
wallet and physical Dogecoin wallet
digital Dogecoin wallet is accessible
through the web and you can also
download it according to your handset or
operating system
on the other hand physical Dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible so moving on let's see how to
create a Dogecoin wallet
to create a Dogecoin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
Step 1 choose the correct volume
Dogecoin core followed and multi-toge
wallet have been created and are
maintained by the developers team of
Dogecoin
here we will be using the Dogecoin core
wallet as reference
Step 2 download and install the Dogecoin
wallet in your handset you can also use
the official website of this wallet for
your windows
and step 3 open the Dogecoin wallet
application and verify your Dogecoin
wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your Dogecoin wallet now when
you have your Dogecoin wallet in your
hand let's see how you can use it on the
very bottom of the home page of your
wallet there are two options request
coins where you can request those coins
from other users in the Dogecoin Network
and send coins where you can send those
coins to other users in the Dogecoin
Network to receive coins first click on
the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third
have the below generated barcode scanned
by the user you wish to request amount
now to send coins
first type the Dogecoin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now you can use your
Dogecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
Dogecoin so popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
Bitcoin Dogecoin has never missed an
opportunity to be in the Limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
Community other than that social
platforms like Reddit and Twitter also
promoted Dogecoin to a great extent due
to its fun factor and the whole joke
story behind it
celebrities like Snoop Dogg Kevin Jonas
Elon Musk also started taking an
interest in Dogecoin and posting
pictures and comments on their social
media handles which increase the queries
of Dogecoin all around the world if
getting your learning started it's half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
so this was all about Dogecoin wallet
now let's have a look at the top 5
Dogecoin wallets of 2021. these are the
top 5 Dogecoin wallets of 2021.
Ledger Nano X freezer model T kipki
binance and Kraken
Kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a Dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it and it
accepts a pretty decent amount of Fiat
money but starting with the comparison
let's look at what we have for you in
this video
first we will have a crisp introduction
of Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
then we will look into the comparison of
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
and at last we will look into a few
similarities between these
cryptocurrencies
so let's get started
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by Shiva inu's
popular meme AKA Doge but it was very
well received by everyone in the crypto
world and today it is the fourth top
cryptocurrency
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
Bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013. Bitcoin enables
transparent and decentralized
peer-to-peer transaction
Bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to National currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
Ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after Bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a Computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deployed a decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
daps or decentralized application
now let's move on the comparison between
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language
mining process
monetary policies
transactions
today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
Dogecoin uses strip cryptography for
mining the blocks of the Dogecoin
Network
in comparison Bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm for mining its blocks
in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses this
algorithm for mining its transactions
language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized Hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific Network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
Dogecoin is considered to be an all coin
for Bitcoin both Dogecoin and Bitcoin
use the same programming language
C plus plus it is a stack based
programming language used to give
Bitcoin and Dogecoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of these
cryptocurrency let's get to the
following very important parameter which
is mining process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public Ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
Dogecoin and Bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in the networks and that is
proof of work
all the ethereum miners also mine the
unvalidated transactions using the proof
of work method it aims to switch to
proof of stake
because it will make its Network more
immune to centralization energy
efficient and more vital support for
shared chains
now we have come to the following person
which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the compete
and monetary or authority to control the
money supply and Achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth
dogecoin's policy is defined by its
block reward paid to its miners whereas
Bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block record
having event is when reward of mining
Bitcoin is cut in half and it also cuts
the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
Bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each block and which is set to
get reduced to 6.25 by 2024.
an ethereum's block reward is to ether
per block
Dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block Bitcoin takes 10 minutes to
generate one block
and ethereum generates one block every
14 seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary due to
this over time mining blocks will become
more complex
now moving on to the following
comparison which is transactions
Dogecoin is the fastest and can complete
70 transaction in one second and takes
just two to three minutes to confirm a
transaction
Bitcoin can complete up to 5 transaction
in one second and takes 10 minutes or
more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
Dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like Reddit and Twitter
Bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for Fiat money and is used
primarily for real world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
Networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of Dogecoin on today's date is
0.2992 dollars
Bitcoin being the highest is 34 857.58
and ethereum holds a value of
2356.58 dollars
now we have reached the last comparison
of Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of Dogecoin is
127 billion
Bitcoin very low as compared to Dogecoin
is just 21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion Dogecoin has
already been mined
for Bitcoin 18 million Bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this graph you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin on the
extreme let you can see first the
options that you can use according to
your requirements like if you want to
know about Dogecoin you can go for the
first option that is
www.dochcoin.com which will lead you to
the official website of Dogecoin if you
want to chat with the executives of coin
Market regarding Dogecoin then you can
go for the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform and
you can also change it according to your
choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Dogecoin which
is 38 billion thirty eight hundred forty
nine million
469 098
it has the total value of Dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 billion 700 million 795 906.
it is the capitalization when Max supply
of Dogecoin was in circulation
on the right side just before total
Supply you can see the volume of
Dogecoin one billion 779 million
417 647.
it is the value of Dogecoin traded in 24
hours next is Bitcoin similar to
Dogecoin you can see the red box on the
right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
Bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www.bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of Bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Bitcoin which is
651 billion 713 million 10 000 753
it is the total value of Bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization that
is 732 billion
387 million two hundred sixty two
thousand six hundred nineteen
and on the right side just before the
total Supply you can see the volume of
Bitcoin that is 30 billion
249 million 939 865.
ethereum is no different from Dogecoin
and Bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.equarium.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is 273 billion
576 million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand Forty Nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is 24 billion one hundred one
million 779
346 but in the end all these top
cryptocurrencies Dogecoin Bitcoin and
ethereum share a few similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized Authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all the
transactions are verified and validated
before processing after complete
verification further transaction process
takes place also all of them have a
large network of independent nodes so
why wait let's embark on this
exhilarating adventure together
but before we dive in if you're looking
to take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field meet Susan an aspiring
painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure as anyone could easily Forge or
replicate them her friend Mark came to
her rescue with an idea of nft
he suggested that Susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy easily transferable and will
also maintain our ownership rights on
her artworks
no idea what nfts were so Mark stepped
ahead and explained it to her nfts turn
your digital assets into one of a kind
by creating a unique digital signature
which defines the ownership of your
assets and that can be bought and sold
for real money cryptocurrency or any
other asset like a non-fungible token
AKA and ft non-fungible tokens means
that they are not interchangeable and
each of them represents unique assets
owned by a specific person on the other
hand fungible tokens are interchangeable
and can be divided into smaller units to
form the same value for example a 100
bill is fungible as you can exchange it
with five twenty dollar bills or two
fifty dollar bills but the painting of
The Last Supper is non-fungible as it
cannot be generated in bulk even if it
is copied it will not be authentic each
nft contains distinguishable information
like who owns the digital asset and who
sold it making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to forge
such a certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is Susan was
curious to know how exactly nft Works
nft basically creates a blockchain-based
digital certificate for your digital
Collectibles including Games music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork A Unique identity the
underlying technology and the
programming language used by nfts are
the same as other cryptocurrencies such
as blockchain and the programming
language ethash or script nft majorly
exists on ethereum blockchain the
distributed public Ledger that records
all the transactions however nft is
quite different from these
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and ethereum
are fungible tokens which means if you
trade Bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands crypto punks is
a remarkable example of nft it enables
you to buy sell and store 10 000
Collectibles with the proof of ownership
being stored on the ethereum blockchain
after exploring how nfts work Susan was
convinced and bought nfts for all her
paintings due to this her artworks were
secured from any kind of forgery and
also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear all in
all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
Jack Dorsey the CEO and co-founder of
Twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my Twitter and
Vignesh sundarasen famously known as
medicovan who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people owing
to its increasing popularity people are
now willing to pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars for nfts nft has enhanced
media exposure and special perks for
aspiring artists like Susan on social
media this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
Frank and Daniel one day they decide to
go for a trip to Venice they made a
budget list for all their expenses like
residence flight Etc they thought of
making their bookings online from a site
that offered discounts to the first 10
visitors on that day while making their
respective flight bookings Daniel's
transaction failed and he missed the
offer going on
on the other hand Frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three Lucky Draw winners Daniel
was surprised and asked Frank how he
could make the transaction when Daniel
himself could not to which his response
was it's simple I used Bitcoin a type of
cryptocurrency
Daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
Frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 By
Satoshi Nakamoto Daniel felt that it
sounds similar to other online payment
options yes what makes it so different
Frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or Central Authority unlike
other payment systems that Banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
Daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit or his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank but on the other hand
cryptocurrency charges almost no or very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
24 7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges on making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account on any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency this is what makes
cryptocurrency different from other
online payment options Daniel was
impressed by cryptocurrency but he
wondered how it works without the
control of an external Authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital Ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system then it is verified and validated
by every node to proceed with the
process of making the transactions the
crypto and cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives now Daniel was
completely aware of the whole technology
and concept behind cryptocurrency and
was influenced by Frank to adopt
cryptocurrency in his daily lifestyle
too he did that by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount
like Daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide due to this
increasing popularity new companies like
metoo and PayPal are coming forward and
investing in cryptocurrency every day in
2018 Malta an Island located in the
Mediterranean Sea south of Italy was
titled blockchain Island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like finance and
okx have already begun to take advantage
of malta's financial incentives and have
moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade spend
and borrow money around the world and
nobody can stop them
people like Bill Gates co-founder of
Microsoft Corporation and Elon Musk CEO
of Tesla support cryptocurrency as it is
much better and secure than physical
money and also holds a great future for
the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as a bane to the
world's economy like Warren Buffett CEO
of Berkshire Hathaway and Ajay benga CEO
of global MasterCard feel that
cryptocurrency is a platform of criminal
activities and will destroy the world's
economy well one thing is clear that
this conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer meet Susan an aspiring
painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure as anyone could easily Forge or
replicate them her friend Mark came to
her rescue with an idea of nft he
suggested that Susan could buy nfts for
all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy easily transferable and will
also maintain her ownership rights on
her artworks
no idea what nfts were so Mark stepped
ahead and explained it to her nfts turn
your digital assets into one of a kind
by creating a unique digital signature
which defines the ownership of your
assets and that can be bought and sold
for real money cryptocurrency or any
other asset like a non-fungible token
AKA and ft non-fungible tokens means
that they are not interchangeable and
each of them represents unique assets
owned by a specific person on the other
hand fungible tokens are interchangeable
and can be divided into smaller units to
form the same value for example a 100
bill is fungible as you can exchange it
with five twenty dollar bills or two
fifty dollar bills but the painting of
The Last Supper is non-fungible as it
cannot be generated in bulk even if it
is copied it will not be authentic each
nft contains distinguishable information
like who owns the digital asset and who
sold it making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to forge
such a certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is Susan was
curious to know how exactly nft Works
nft basically creates a blockchain-based
digital certificate for your digital
Collectibles including Games music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork A Unique identity the
underlying technology and the
programming language used by nfts are
the same as other cryptocurrencies such
as blockchain and the programming
language ethash or script nft majorly
exists on ethereum blockchain the
distributed public Ledger that records
all the transactions however nft is
quite different from these
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and ethereum
are fungible tokens which means if you
trade Bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money on the
other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands crypto punks is
a remarkable example of nft it enables
you to buy sell and store 10 000
Collectibles with the proof of ownership
being stored on the ethereum blockchain
after exploring how nfts work Susan was
convinced and bought nfts for all her
paintings due to this her artworks were
secured from any kind of forgery and
also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear all in
all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
Jack Dorsey the CEO and co-founder of
Twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my Twitter and
Vignesh sundarasen famously known as
medicoven who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people owing
to its increasing popularity people are
now willing to pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars for nfts
nft has enhanced media exposure and
special perks for aspiring artists like
Susan on social media this popularity of
nft creates new opportunities for new
art platforms motivating people to buy
art from internet platforms and
promoting copyright or originality of
digital assets many experts in the
crypto industry say that around 40
percent of new crypto users will use
nfts as their entry point as a result of
its growing popularity nft could
represent a more significant part of the
digital economy in the future
in this video we will explore about
pouch and will go through some of really
exciting Concepts and components
revolving around it
first we will look into the origin of
Shiba Inu coins then we will understand
what is Shiba Inu coins
then we will explore how it is different
and unique from Dogecoin
then we will figure out why is it so
popular
and at last we will explore what future
Shiba inucoin holds for itself
so without wasting more time let's get
started with the video
so how did the shiba inucoin originate
the shiba inucoin was created in August
2020 by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi and Indian
it was intended as an altcoin of
Dogecoin which itself was created as an
altcoin of Bitcoin
and this meme coin has been named after
the Japanese dog breed Shiva Inu
it feels like the shiba inu coin was
built into existence and is now insanely
popular among major crypto exchanges
through the power of its following crowd
memes and a very cute dog now we know
how it originated so let's have a look
at what is Shiba in a coin
is a decentralized community building
cryptocurrency or we can say an
experiment developed within the shiba
inu ecosystem and built on top of the
ethereum blockchain network like many
other coins
it is a meme coin launched as a rival of
Dogecoin a doge killer both Dogecoin and
sheepcoin were made in a humorous manner
but cheapcoin has already taken over
some Dogecoin markets attracting a lot
of attention and Rising as a popular
choice among investors especially after
such market crash of cryptos like
Bitcoin and ethereum
but what is the difference between Shiba
in a coin and Dogecoin
although both Shiva inucoin and Dogecoin
are main coins and share the same tree
of origin both of them differ a lot from
each other at the same time
and the very first difference between
then is the Sheep coin is a token and
Dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development
Shiba Inu coins or sheep coins are built
on and powered by the ethereum network
while Dogecoin has been developed using
the same technology as Bitcoin
then is use cases
sheepcoin is still working upon price
more due to its high popularity than
utility but on the other hand Dogecoin
has already established itself to some
extent as a medium of online payments
then is value according to my coin
market cap the current value of
sheepcoin is
0.00007378 dollars and that of Dogecoin
is
0.261711 dollars
and at last availability the
availability of sheep coin till today is
394 million and for Dogecoin it is 130
billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind why is Shiba in a coin so
popular
Shiba Inu coin is majorly popular
because of two reasons
Tesla founder Elon Musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a Sheba Pub that hyped the crypto
market and its prices Rose by 300
percent
on the other hand its prices fell by
around 40 after the founder of ethereum
blockchain network metallic buterin
donated 50 trillion Shiba Inu coins to
Indian government
for copied Relief Fund of an Indian
crypto entrepreneur Sandeep naival
so now that we know about Shiba in a
coin and its Concepts let's have a look
at what is the future of Shiba Inu coins
though Sheba coin is only known as a
meme coin it's increasing popularity and
people's interest in participating in it
is pointing towards a different but
bright future
according to
investingcube.com the Sheba coin is
predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
this token and its value active buyers
could help its value rise the value
could rise to
0.00001040 in a more active buyers
Market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount due to its popularity
in future it can have a significant
influence over large investors of the
crypto Market
some are very interesting and important
aspects of Solana crypto
first we will understand what is Selana
then we will look into what is a soul
token or Sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of Solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method the sulana use
after which we will understand how
Solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of Solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of Solana holes for itself
and at last we will look into real-like
users of Selana
so without doing much I do let's start
the video
let's explore what is salana
salana is a cryptocurrency that is used
to pay for transactions but a
decentralized Computing Network
Solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability by combining proof of stake
and proof of History consensus as a
result Solana promises to be capable of
processing 50 000 transactions per
second while maintaining
decentralization
now the question arises what is the SL
token or Soul token
Savannah's ecosystem uses the SL token
as its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the Solana class term in exchange for
running on chain programs or certifying
themselves
it can also be used to make micro
payments known as lampodes
now when we are talking so much about
Solana crypto let's also dive down and
explore how and when exactly it came
into existence
platform in 2017. before launching
Solana
worked at Qualcomm after working as a
software engineer at Dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge with
compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties in
the Bitcoin and ethereum blockchain
with the help of Eric Williams and
Solana's CTO Greg Fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol with increased
scalability the team now has experience
from leading companies around the world
including Apple Google Microsoft Intel
Twitter Dropbox and others
now that we know what Solana is and all
about its background let me ask you a
question recently Solana joined hands
with two foundations to raise a fund of
5 million dollars to encourage the next
wave of creators and fans onto crypto
networks so comment down your answers in
the comment section below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it unique and popular
scalable Solana uses proof of history
and a number of other group
groundbreaking features to allow the
network to scale at the weight of
Moore's Law
cost for applications with billions of
users Solana is designed to keep feasts
low
so you will never have to worry about
Rising fees as your user base grows
composable the single Global state of
Solana guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history but what exactly is it
that we will discuss within the type of
consensus method Solana uses
the Solana Network which has 200
physically different nodes can handle a
throughput of more than 50 000 DPS
when using gpus is one of the most
performant permissionless blockchain
unlike Bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm as the system
decentralized clock Solana uses the
proof of History technique
you can use proof of History to
construct historical records that verify
and event occurred at a given point in
time this algorithm is a verifiable
delay function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps to evaluate
each transaction or even data is
examined will be assigned a unique hash
an account that can be verified publicly
and effectively
the count serves as a cryptographic
timestamp allowing us to determine when
each transaction or event occur this
provides increased throughput and
efficiency within the Solana Network
now that we know about its structure and
mechanism let's explore how Solana works
now we know Solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time of a transaction known as proof of
History
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
Step 1 input the details of transactions
performed in the network to its leader
Step 2 leader will now efficiently
sequence and organize the messages so
that they can be processed by another
nodes
step 3 the leader then executes the
transactions based on the Ram's current
state
4 the completed States transactions and
signature will then be published by the
leader to the verifiers or replication
nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation the verifiers will perform
the same transactions on their copies of
the state and publish their signatures
add at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use the published
confirmations as words now that we know
everything about Solana let's have a
look at the price and volume of Solana
according to market capitalization
the Solana Network can process more than
50 000 transactions in one second and
the current price of it is 30 dollars
with a circulating volume of 270 million
as well coins which is quite impressive
considering its time span in market
capitalization as well as compared to
other cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the Solana holds
for itself
being a new project has delivered on its
Promises of speed and scalability its
token price has also done well
attracting investors attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage are still in the early stages
we won't know whether Solana speed make
a significant difference in the Bitcoin
real
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages will only occur as more
people utilize it and more use cases
emerge real life uses of Selana
serum radium bone peda Orca oxygen and
Phantom wallet are some of the recent
projects that sunana is working with
well this is all about Solana crypto in
this video I will take you through
various important Concepts and
components of the cardano first we will
explore what is cardano then we will
understand what is Ada followed by what
is its Max Supply and value in today's
date
then we will see why is it so popular
and after that we will explore various
layers of cardano followed by consensus
algorithm of cardano
after that we will look into the
difference between cardano and ethereum
and at the end we will look into the
uses of cardano
so without further Ado let's get started
with the video
so what is cardano
cardano is a third generation
decentralized proof of State blockchain
platform that aims to outperform proof
of work Networks
the infrastructure load of escalating
expenses energy utilization and lengthy
transaction time limit scalability and
sustainability for proof of work
networks like ethereum
Foundation decentralization smart
contracts scaling and governance are the
five stages of cardano development
the relevance of these issues to
blockchain networks were recognized by
Charles hoskinson co-founder of the
proof of work blockchain ethereum who
began creating cardano and its principle
cryptocurrency Ada in 2014 and
introducing the platform and the Ada
token in 2017. the cardano foundation
iohk and
e-m-u-r-g-o- are all responsible for
cardano's governance
now let's move ahead to what is Ada Ada
is the name of cardano's principle
cryptocurrency it is based on the
Cardinal blockchain a first of its kind
decentralized Network built entirely on
scientific and mathematical principles
by cryptography and Engineering experts
its purpose is to provide a quick and
secure transaction of value and allow
users to operate spark contracts and
applications
furthermore the ability to send and
receive funds instantly and for a low of
fee has numerous applications in the
business and financial roles
it is a proof of stake coin used to fuel
cardano ecosystem now let's have a look
at the max Supply and current value of
ADA in today's state
according to market cap cardano's
current value is
2.1823 USD and the maximum supply of
cardano can be of 45 billion out of
which till today its supply has reached
31 billion but the question is why is it
so popular
currently Ada the native coin of the
popular all coin Cardinal has risen to
an all-time high breaking the previous
record despite a big price crash warning
the Ada USD rate of exchange topped 2.56
dollar for the first time on September
17 2021
capping a
154.54 price so that began on July 20.
now that we have covered the basics
let's write down and explore the layers
of cardinal Network
there are two layers to the Cardinal
blockchain the settlement layer and the
computational layer
the settlement layer of CSL is
responsible for settling transaction
made by Network peers in Ada the local
currency
the computational layer CCL was built
with smart contracts and decentralized
applications in mind to maximize the
Network's capacity for protocol
modification and soft food
implementations
we developed a layer protocol is written
in hair skill while smart contracts are
written in platters a programming
language that allows for the creation of
more stringent contracts
now let's understand the working of
consensus algorithm of cardano
as discussed earlier has killed a widely
recognized and secure programming
language is used to create the Cardinal
open source code
relies on the arborist consensus
protocol which is an uniquely built
proof of stake blockchain technology
this consensus process ensures that ADA
may be issued and received quickly and
securely as well as the security of
smart contracts on the Cardinal
blockchain at the same time as a proof
of stake consensus mechanism
it rewards token holders who stake their
Ada in the network and assist ensure
Network unanimity
so this is how it works
first the network chooses few nodes
called slot leaders at random
have the opportunity to mine new blogs
and control the flow of data
second the blockchain is divided into
slots
each referred to as an epoch
and at last lot leaders can mine their
own specific Epoch any person who
assists in the mining of an Epoch or a
portion of it is rewarded also an EPO
can be partitioned an infinite number of
times now that we know both cardano and
ethereum deal with smart contracts and
apps let's unveil the difference between
them too launch date
cardano was launched in September 2017
while ethereum was launched way ago in
January 2014. cardano was founded by
Charles Hawkinson while on the other
hand ethereum was founded by vitalik
buterin consensus algorithm cardano
follows proof of State although ethereum
also intends to switch to proof of state
it still follows proof of work
programming language cardano uses his
skill and ethereum uses solidity
and architecture cardano has two layers
CSL and CCL but ethereum just consists
of one layer now that we have covered
all the important aspects of cardano
let's have a peek at the uses of cardano
one of the core principles of cardano is
that the Ada is take to the blockchain
as part of the proof of stake blockchain
Network which allows State Pool
operators to successfully verify
transactions on the blockchain this is
where the Cardinal cryptocurrency comes
into play
those that stake their Ada on the
blockchain are rewarded with extra
Cardinal this staking system contributes
to the blockchain security
Edition Ada is used in voting unlike
other blockchain projects Cardinal token
holders board and decide on protocol
updates rather than minors
unlike other blockchain networks
Cardinal or token holders vote and
decide on protocol modifications not
miners
when a new Improvement or enhancement to
the cardano blockchain is suggested
cardano crypto holders vote with the Ada
as a result everyone who owns a
cryptocurrency has a vote in how it
develops so well this is all about
cardano
so what are your thoughts on Cardinal
and will you be investing money in it I
will take you through various important
Concepts and components of thematic
first we will explore what is polygon
followed by what is Matic
then we will look into the features of
Matic
and after that we will understand how
does Polygon works
then we will discover why is it
important to ethereum
and what is its current value and
circulating Supply
and at last we will discuss is it a good
investment or not so without further Ado
let's get started with the venue
so let's start with what is polygon
polygon formerly known as Matic network
is a scaling solution that seeks to give
several methods to boost the speed of
transactions on blockchain networks
while also lowering the cost and
complexity
polygon describes itself as a layer 2
Network which means it is an add-on
layer to ethereum that does not attempt
to alter the original blockchain layer
like its geometric namesake it has
numerous sides shapes and applications
and it promises to be a more
straightforward framework for creating
interconnected Networks
polygon is a scaling solution that seeks
to give several methods to boost the
speed of transactions on blockchain
network while also lowering their cost
and complexity
now that brings us to what is Matic
after the rebranding polygon retained
its Matic cryptocurrency the digital
coin and winning the network
is the payment and settlement unit for
participants who engage within the
network and is also utilized to keep
tokens safe on the polygon Network
since then it has received an Incredible
cost search following a tremendous
expansion in use
thematic cryptocurrency is available on
a number of well-known decentralized and
centralized Trading Card forms including
binance one in exchange and coinbase Pro
the crypto Community is banding together
to make it easier to buy polygon
chromatic tokens by making them
available in both Fiat and crypto
so now that we know what they are let's
have a look at the features of Matic
first is it provides blockchain
performance enhancement Technologies
polygon side chain was one of the first
things they offered a sidechain is a
blockchain that links to it and improves
its performance
transactions are processed faster and
fees are significantly lower
second is its goal to create Foundation
of blockchain network
polygon's future goals are huge its
purpose is to create a foundation full
of blockchain networks instead of being
completely disconnected users would be
able to establish blockchain networks
that interconnect
third comes its ethereum virtual machine
or evm compatible because polygon is
even compatible developers can easily
Port their apps to it
Avi and Sushi swap are just two of the
popular ethereum apps that have already
been deployed on polygon
then comes other blockchain networks as
well as ethereum 2.0 could provide
challenges polygon isn't the only
blockchain Network initiative in the
works
others such as polka dot and Avalanche
provide interconnected blockchains
projects like these May co-exist or one
may develop a Superior Solution and
abandon the others ethereum has also
been releasing updates to ethereum 2.0
in a series of releases
and next is fees governance and staking
are all handled through the polygon
token we have discussed the Project's
objectives but what about polygons
cryptocurrency token it can be utilized
in a variety of ways
now we have almost covered the basic
let's time down and understand how it
works polygon is a multi-level platform
that intends to grow ethereum by using
variety of side chains to unclog the
main platform and the cost effective and
efficient manner
if you're not aware of side chains there
are separate blockchains that are linked
to the main ethereum blockchain and can
support a variety of decentralized
Finance protocols
as a result polygon can be linked to
networks like polka dot Cosmos and
Avalanche now let's have a look at why
is it important to ethereum
Matic is compatible with the evm
developers that are accustomed to
working with ethereum can easily
transition to polygon polygon has a
security layer that may be turned on or
off which enables Sovereign platforms to
forego additional protection while
maintaining their freedom and
flexibility
Matic tokens can be used to vote on
polygon Improvement proposals and
participate in network governance so now
let's have a look at the crypto market
value of Matic
according to market cap polygon's
current price is 1.30 USD dollars
and the maximum supply of polygon is 10
billion out of which till today its
supply has reached 6.67 billion now the
question comes is it a good investment
if you're thinking about investing in
Matic keep in mind that cryptocurrencies
are quite volatile so you'll need to be
prepared for large price rings
so only invest money you can afford to
lose and make sure to build up your
emergency savings and retirement account
first however investors should keep an
eye on the implementation of ethereum 2.
as well as the activity of polygons
competitors
there's still a lot to play for in this
sector and it's unclear how it will
develop so moving on let me give you an
overview of all the topics you are going
to cover across in this video
first we will understand the basics and
explore what is stable coins following
that we will look into the types of
staple coins
after that we will have a crisp
comparison between stable coins and
other cryptocurrencies
moving on we will have a look at some of
best stable coins according to market
capitalization
after that we will write down deeper and
understand why is it so important
and in the end we will see what can we
do with these stable coins so now let's
get started at the basics
what is stablecoin
stablecoin is a type of cryptocurrency
that is backed by its Reserve asset like
the US dollar or gold that aims to
provide price stability
it started gaining popularity since they
tried to combine The Best of Both Worlds
their rapid processing and security or
privacy of cryptocurrency payments as
well as the volatility free and stable
prices of paid currencies so now that we
know what stablecoin is
let's explore its types
the first one that we are going to
understand is Fiat collateralized stable
coins
it uses a fiat currency Reserve such as
the US dollar to issue a sufficient
number of crypto dollar to other types
of collateral include precious metals
such as gold and silver as well as
Commodities such as oil but the majority
of today's fear collateralize stable
coins used dollar reserves now
independent custodians manage such
reasons which are audited on a regular
basis to ensure that the essential
compliance is met better and through us
they are popular cryptocurrencies that
are backed by Dollar deposits and have
the same value as a single US dollar
now moving on to the next one we have
crypto collateralize stable coins
stable coins that are crypto
collateralized are bad by other
cryptocurrencies because the reserved
cryptocurrency may be volatile such
stable coins are over collateralized
which means that a larger number of
cryptocurrency tokens are key as a
result for releasing a smaller number of
stable coins
now coming to the last one that we have
is
non-collateralized or algorithmic
stablecoin
now this don't have any reserves but
they do have a working mechanism
to keep the price stable similar to that
of a central bank the donor pet base
coin for example employs a consensus
method to increase or reduce token
production based on demand
no such practices can be compared to a
central bank producing banknotes to
sustained fiat currency valuations
it is possible to achieve this by
developing a smart contract on a
decentralized platform that can execute
independently so now that we have a fair
knowledge of stablecoin let's have a
quick comparison between stablecoin and
other cryptocurrencies to understand
their functioning even better so the
first one is it is possible to
accurately predict fluctuations in the
value of stablecoin on the other hand it
is difficult to pay the trend in the
value of other cryptocurrencies
the second one is stable coins are
centralized as they are maintained by
independent custodians
on the other hand cryptocurrencies are
decentralized
the third one we have is stable coins
values remains constant at one dollar
cryptocurrency on the other hand has a
price range depending on its performance
in market capitalization
and the fourth one is stablecoin price
remains constant making them
non-volatile
cryptocurrencies on the other hand have
a lot of insecurity making them
extremely unpredictable and highly
volatile now let's have a look at some
of the best stable coins according to
the market capitalization
with the market capitalization of 79.5
billion dollars
then we have USD coin with market
capitalization of 53.5 billion dollar
following that we have binance USD with
market capitalization of 18.3 billion
dollar
then we have Tera USD with the market
capitalization of 13 billion
then we have die with market
capitalization of 9.7 billion dollar
following that we have true USD with
market capitalization of 1.5 billion
dollar
then we have tax dollar with market
capitalization of
947.4 billion dollars
following that we have neutrino USD with
the market capitalization
of
493.9 billion dollars
now let's understand why stable coins
are so important too
people
stable coins are devoid of the volatile
nature of non-peg cryptocurrencies while
retaining some of them most valuable
properties
like
stable coins are open Global and
available to everyone on the internet 24
7.
the transport data quickly cheaply and
very securely
and they are programmable and digitally
native to the internet
now that we have covered almost
everything about stable coins and its
Concepts now let's see what all can we
do with these stable coins
first is to
treaties like Bitcoin and ether have a
lot of volatility sometimes even by the
minute
buyers and sellers can have confidence
that the value of their tokens will need
a grown or fall unpredictably in the
near future the asset is linked to a
more stable currency
for say stable coins the second one is
stable coins can be held without a bank
account and a simple to transfer the
value of stable coins need easily moved
around the world even to countries where
the US dollar is difficult to come by or
where the local currency is volatile
coming to the third one is there are
several simple ways to earn income on a
stable coin investment which is often
higher than what a bank would offer
so for the fourth one we have
with transfer fees of less than one
dollar people have sent as much as a
million dollar worth of usdc
and the fifth the last one is stable
coins like usdc is a wonderful
alternative for transporting money
around the world because of their quick
processing and cheap transaction fees so
well this was all about stable coins
before getting to the comparison of
crypto coins and tokens let me give a
quick introduction to what is a digital
asset this will help you understand the
difference between crypto coins and
tokens better broadly speaking a digital
asset is a non-tangible asset that is
created exchanged and kept in a digital
format by this definition
cryptocurrencies and crypto tokens are
considered digital assets in the context
of blockchains since both
cryptocurrencies and tokens are digital
assets on blockchains the terms are
frequently used synonymously but they
are not similar there are multiple
parameters where they differ from each
other on multiple levels and that's what
we will cover moving forward in this
video so let me take you through the
comparison parameters based on which we
will compare crypto coins and tokens
first is definition cryptocurrencies
have their own unique blockchain BTC is
the currency used in the Bitcoin
blockchain ethereum has eth on its
blockchain similar to traditional
currencies the main purpose of these
currency coins is to serve as a form of
wealth storage and a medium of exchange
for this reason cryptocurrency is
another name for cryptocurrency coins
although they are created utilizing
blockchain technology unlike
cryptocurrency currencies crypto tokens
are not native to a blockchain while
cryptocurrency coins imitate
conventional money crypto tokens behave
more like assets or even Deeds a crypto
token may serve as a proxy for ownership
the next parameter that will be measured
is Supply if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skill up by
Sim learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the way they are created mining is used
to create crypto coins in most cases
cryptocurrencies are either mined using
a proof of work or pow or a proof of
stake POS consensus mechanism tokens
unlike cryptocurrencies are generalized
and distributed by the project developer
rather than being mined tokens Can Be
utilized in a plethora of ways once they
are in the possession of buyers now
talking about fees or gas when
transferring a cryptocurrency
transaction fees or gas are cheaper
however when transferring tokens they
are more expensive when transferring
tokens you still require some
cryptocurrency in the same account
because fees are always paid for in
cryptocurrencies now moving on to the
next parameter purpose what are they
used for or what they serve crypto coins
are designed to work in the same way as
paper money and metal coins meaning they
can can be used for many of the things
normally used with US dollars or Euros
including storing value exchanging for
other currencies paying for goods and
services transferring to others and so
forth whereas most crypto tokens are
made to be utilized in dapps or
blockchain based projects crypto tokens
Can represent ownership in a dow a
digital product or nft or even a
tangible item crypto tokens are similar
to currencies in that they may be
purchased sold and exchanged but are not
utilized as a means of exchange to put
it another way crypto coins are more
like dollars and cents whereas crypto
tokens are more like coupons or vouchers
and the last parameter that will be
measured is types choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
the variation of crypto coins or tokens
present in the crypto Market some of the
popular crypto coins are Bitcoin the
first and most well-known crypto coin in
the world ethereum implements smart
contracts and is the home to thousands
of blockchain projects and nfts cardano
an open source and decentralized
blockchain platform that is one of the
first to run on a POS consensus and many
more in crypto tokens some of the
popular tokens are filecoin and R weave
allow users to pay with their utility
tokens for the right to store data on
their decentralized Network maximizing
the potential of cloud storage axi
Infinity one of the best known play to
earn on the market and features a
utility token called Smooth love potions
Chronos a utility token for the
crypto.com ecosystem and there are many
more tokens available in the crypto
ecosystem now the decision of whether to
purchase coins or tokens greatly depends
upon the holder's intention so why wait
let's embark on this exhilarating
adventure together
before we dive in if you're looking to
take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the realm of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with IIT kanpur it's an
excellent opportunity to master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to excel in this rapidly
growing field
so let's have a look topics that we are
going to cover in this topic
first we will understand what is Ripple
followed by what is xrp
then we will see the working of Ripple
then we will learn how to mine xrp after
that we will have a comparison between
Bitcoin and ripple then we will explore
the pros and cons of Ripple after which
we will see how you can actually use
Ripple
followed by we will see how can we buy
and in the end we will see if it is a
good investment or not
so let's get started with the video
first let's understand what is Ripple so
the form behind xrp is Ripple which is a
payment settlement systems and currency
engine Network that can handle
transactions all across the world
basically it acts as a trusted
intermediary between two parties in a
transaction
as the network can be immediately
validated that the transaction was
completed successfully
Ripple can ease the exchange of a wide
range
of Fiat currencies and cryptocurrencies
including Bitcoin so when users utilize
the network to make a transaction the
network takes a modest charge in the
form of xrp
and ripple was built from the ground up
to be a swift a leading money transfer
Network successor or to otherwise
replace into mental layer between large
financial institutions so this raises
the question of what is XR so let's have
a look at it the xrp Ledger created by
Jade mikhailer Arthur Brito and David
Schwartz is a blockchain that runs xrp
Mach 11 Brito would go on to form Ripple
which would employ xrp to enable Network
transactions
you can acquire xrp as an investment
crypto to trade from other
cryptocurrencies or as a way to fund
Ripple Network transactions xrp is
blockchain in particular drifid from
that of most other cryptocurrencies
other cryptocurrencies give anyone who
can solve difficult equations quickly
access to their transaction ledgers and
verification processes Ripple
transactions on the other hand are safe
since the majority of Ledger holders
must agree to the verification before
they can be added also the Ripple
Network which employs xrp is somewhat
centralized and uses a consensus
protocol this means while anyone can
download its validation software it has
its own node list that consumers can use
to validate transactions based on which
participants they believe are least
likely to cheat them
so now that we know the basics of Ripple
and xrp let's have a look at working of
Ripple two verify transactions the xrp
cryptocurrency employs a consensus
protocol validators verify that proposed
transactions are valid by comparing them
to the most recent version of The xrp
Ledger now what transaction must be
accepted by the majority of validators
in order to be verified once it's
verified the transaction is then added
to the blockchain so now that we know
it's working let's have a look at how
Ripple can be mined by its users ripples
or Excel is created using a crypto
Ledger that is akin to blockchain
technology and is Federated by financial
institutions and payment processor
Networks
while it is true that Ripple xrp cannot
be mined by miners it is technically
viable to do it using other
cryptocurrencies so one of the most
viable techniques for mining xrp is to
mine other cryptocurrencies such as
Bitcoin and ethereum and then transfer
the mine crypto for ripple through
exchanges
and that's how the mining is done
as we have discussed all the basics of
Ripple straight down Depot and have a
look at how it differs from Bitcoin to
verify transactions and distribute new
currencies Bitcoin employs mining
participants set up mining devices to
solve complex mathematical equations
with the first person to solve the
equation winning the right to add a
block of transaction to bitcoin's
network
then participants receive Bitcoin
rewards for each block they are in the
exchange for Bitcoin mining whereas the
consensus protocol used by XR plan
confirms transactions for a transaction
to be accepted it must receive the
approval of a majority of validators who
actually review it then Bitcoin
transaction confirms can take several
minutes and are associated with
significant transaction charges due to
the intricate
and expensive nature of mining utilized
in the cryptocurrency but on the other
hand xrp transactions are instantly
confirmed and having cheap transaction
fees the user is charged a small amount
of xrp each time a transaction is
completed on the Ripple Network
now the supply of Bitcoin is limited to
21 million which means there will be
never more than 21 million Bitcoin the
artificial scarcity of 12 Bitcoin has
sparked investor interest in the
currency's potential as a safe haven but
in contrast at the time of introduction
one billion xrp was free mined and
progressively distributed under the
market by the company's major investors
next we have when miners discover
Bitcoins they are released and added to
the network they have no set release
date and their supplies is largely
determined by Network speeds and the
difficulty of the algorithm used to
create coins on the other hand the
release of xrp is controlled by a smart
contract
according to an inbuilt smart contract
Ripple is expected to distribute a
maximum of 1 billion xrp tokens per
month so the current circulation is 55
billion till now
so this was all about the difference
between Bitcoin and ripple and I'm
pretty sure that till now you have
understood all the basic knowledge about
triple so let's move ahead and look into
some of the pros and cons
of purple
though xrp transactions are quick and
inexpensive ripples consensus protocol
is perhaps less secure than other crypto
transaction processing Technologies
next is even though Financial
organizations are already using ripples
payment Network ripples Financial
Partners primarily use triple net rather
than xrp cryptocurrency
next we have is small company owners and
individuals who can utilize xrp to make
safe money transactions yet because it
is administered by a private Corporation
and because of the SEC litigation Ripple
has sparked the debate
and for foreign currency transfers xrp
can be utilized as a British currency
but in the United States buying xrp is
quite challenging so now that we know
its pros and cons Also let's have a look
how you can actually use Ripple xrp can
be used in the same way as any digital
currency for transaction or as a
possible investment other sorts of
transactions such as currency exchange
potentially be processed using the
Ripple Network for example instead of
dealing with the currency conversion
directly through a bank or money
changing exchange you may first exchange
your US dollars for xrp on the Ripple
Network and then use them to buy euros
rather than paying the healthy cost that
Banks and money transmission businesses
May demand this can be a lot fast and
less expensive option
so now that we know everything about
triple let's explore how can we actually
buy Ripple so all you need is sign up
for an account on an exchange that sells
ripples xrp cryptocurrency to buy it
then using any of the exchanges allowed
payment methods buy it here are a few
places where you can get xrp Q coin
uphold and coin mama
now the question is
repel a good investment
so xrp
is a risky investment that is not for
the faint of heart however if you feel
Ripple will succeed as a payment system
it may be worthwhile to invest in xrp so
just be sure you're not gambling with
money you can't afford to lose
well this was all about what is Ripple
so let's start the video
let's have a look at the topics that we
are going to cover in this video
first we will explore what is binance
coin following that we will understand
how it works
then we will type down Depot and explore
a very interesting concept followed by
Finance which is BNB burning
then we will look at the uses of the
binance coin
followed by its benefits after that we
will come across some important factors
to consider before investing in the
binance coin and at the end we will see
the pricing dynamics of the binance coin
the first thing that we are going to
explore is what is binance coin
so binance coin or BNB is a
cryptocurrency that may be used on the
binance cryptocurrency exchange to trade
and pay fees as of January 2018 the
binance exchange was the world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange conducting over
1.4 million transactions every second
this coin is limited to 200 million BNB
tokens and runs on the ethereum
blockchain using the standard erc20
protocol
as an incentive binance coin users
receive a reduction in transaction cost
on the finance Exchange
other cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin
ethereum Litecoin and others can be
exchanged or traded for BNB
now let's move on and see how it works
BNB is a crypto asset that fluctuates in
value as individuals use and traded
similar to other digital assets on the
market
DMV can be stored in suitable wallets
obtained from crypto exchanges and send
directly to others for payments and
other purposes but there is a whole
working initiative behind this process
binance layer 1 blockchain is merged to
form the BNB chain previously the
binance smart chain and the binance
chain binance design the blockchain for
best performance when it comes to
trading on chain when building the pnb
chain and binance Dex
it is also based on this newly developed
chain furthermore BNB chain transactions
are powered by the BNB gas token which
stands for build and build previously
also known as binance coin
now BNB Beacon chain and BNB smart chain
make up the BNB chain the former is
concerned with BNB chain governance
which allows BNB holders to vote and
stick their coins then it's a consensus
layer that's compatible with the
ethereum virtual machine and has
multi-chain hubs
now moving on let's have a look at the
pnb burn concept
binance uses 20 of its profit each
quarter to buy back and burn binance
coins completely destroying them binance
has consistently performed quarterly
burns the most recent being on October
17 2020 which was 13th quarterly burn
finance will continue to burn BNB coins
every quarter until it has purchased and
destroyed 100 million binance coins or
half of the total Supply
Finance coins Supply is reduced as a
result of the procedure and its Rarity
is affected which could affect the
assets value
binance also has a program called the
BNB Pioneer burn program which asses
cases when BNB holders have
unrecoverably lost BNB and compensate
them by reducing the amount from the
next BNB burn
now let's have a look at some of the
uses of the binance coin
the finance coin like other developing
cryptocurrencies has a variety of
applications outside of the binance
exchange including
first is trading binance coin can be
exchanged for other cryptocurrencies on
a variety of exchanges depending on the
exchanges regulations
next is transaction fees on the binance
exchange
users can use BNB to pay for
transactions on the binance exchange and
earn a hefty discount
next we have is credit card payments on
crypto.com BNB can be used to pay for
crypto credit card bills
next is premium processing Merchants can
accept BNB as a form of payments giving
customers more options in terms of
payment methods
next we have is booking travel
arrangements and certain websites BNB
can be used to book hotels flights as
well
next is entertainment now BNB is used
for a variety of purposes in the
entertainment industries from paying for
virtual kids to purchasing lottery
tickets as well
next in the line is investment
binance coin can be used to invest
in stocks ETFs and other assets on a
variety of platforms
and at last is loans and transfers on
some platforms BNB can be used as a
collateral for loans there are also apps
that allow users to use Finance coin to
split bills and pay friends and
relatives
so now that we have covered the basics
of the binance coin let's have a look at
some of its benefits that makes it
unique
starting with quick transactions when
you trade on the exchange with BNB
you'll have access to platform property
matching engine which can handle up to
1.4 million orders per second finding
the appropriate transaction is always
possible and using BNB makes it even
easier and more reliable
next is secure and trustworthy
binance already has millions of
cryptocurrency users and dealers who
rely on the platform and believe in the
security and protection aspects of this
exchange to keep your funds safe The
Exchange uses a multi-cluster and
multi-tire system framework as well as
the secure assets funds for users next
is trade multiple cryptocurrencies
you can trade more than 150
cryptocurrencies on the exchange with
BNB thanks to a rapid secure and low
cost transaction matching technology
aside from that BNB has its own trading
pair to fulfill your individual training
needs there's no need to seek elsewhere
moving ahead is Trading discount
you will also get a 50 discount on your
trading charge if you use BNB with
traditional payment methods if you buy
ten thousand dollar worth of coins
you'll be charged ten dollar and if you
use BNB though the trading charge is cut
in half so you'll just have to spend
five dollars next is spending binance
coin you can utilize BNB in a variety of
ways in addition to having a smooth
experience within the binance ecosystem
and receiving transaction fee discounts
several service providers particularly
in the travel and hotel Industries
accepted using BNB you can purchase
dinner or a new phone as well
now let's have a look at some of the
factors that you should consider before
investing in binance coin
now binance coins can be used to invest
in some icos listed on binance Launchpad
program The binance Exchange will
publish new cryptocurrencies and the use
of binance coins will provide a seamless
Marketplace for creating a range of
virtual tokens
binance will eventually become the
decentralized finance exchanges
principle currency
the Visa debit card of Monaco the
world's first payment and cryptocurrency
platform and the platform's mobile app
also support binance coin
now as we are talking about Investments
let's have a look at the Peak at BNB
pricing and Dynamics
bnb's pricing has traditionally varied
in a similar way to the price of other
crypto assets traded on the market
binance coins market capitalization has
increased over time topic 70 billion
dollars BNB was also sold for around
0.10 per token during finances Ico
today the current value of BNB is
286.67 dollars with the market
capitalization of 46 billion 801 million
two hundred ten thousand eighty one
dollars BNB has seen a tremendous
increase in value since its Ico reaching
a high of more than six hundred dollar
per coins at time is it wise to invest
in binance coin well if purchase join
and sold at the right times it's
conceivable and past price growth
resulted in profit however only time can
tell where the price of BNB will go in
the future Alex like everybody else in
the world had heard a lot of hype around
blockchain and cryptocurrency being
attacking he started exploring
blockchain and cryptocurrency and
understood that blockchain is the
distributed digital database the mixed
recording transactions and managing
Assets in a corporate Network much
easier and cryptocurrency on the other
hand is a digital currency that acts as
a medium of exchange over a blockchain
network it is not supported by any
Central Authority such as a government
or bank but what intrigued him was how
people contribute to blockchain so he
decided to go to a friend Sarah who is a
blockchain expert upon asking how people
actually participate in blockchain Sarah
answered this occurs via crypto mining
cryptocurrency mining is the process by
which specialized computers often known
as nodes or mining rigs validate
blockchain transactions for a specific
crypto coin in exchange for a mining
payout listening to this Alex asked if
he could also join this network and be a
part of the crypto mining process Sarah
said it's a little difficult because
crypto mining requires a huge setup like
a high-end processor GPU high
performance graphics card lots of
electricity and an AC and to set up all
this he needs a huge amount of land Alex
was disappointed and that is when Sarah
said but there is one network that you
can mine without any hassle it is pi
Network Alex got curious and asked what
pi network is and how it can act
differently from other cryptocurrencies
Sarah explained that Pi network is a
digital currency initiative that
attempts to make cryptocurrency mining
accessible as first generation
currencies such as Bitcoin have become
too centralized for many daily users
let's understand this in detail Pi
Network came into the picture in 2019
itself since then it has been in testing
mode even though it's not launched yet
it still offers to mine its coins and
here's how to mine it users must first
Safeguard the currency they also need to
expand their Network by referring it to
others all you need to do is one every
day log in and click a button to receive
digital cash there is no evidence of
Labor being done they simply log in and
press a button because this currency is
not yet exchanged it has no value two
increase your level by inviting
additional people to the site this
allows them to accumulate more digital
cash each day in pyramid schemes and
multi-level marketing this is a common
model she further added that Pi was
designed to be halved regularly to
protect its scarcity when a miner
receives half as many coins for
processing new transactions this is
known as having it usually happens when
you reach a certain Milestone when pi
hit 100 000 users its mining rate fell
to 1.6 per hour then to 0.4 per hour
then to 0.2 per hour and finally to 0.2
per hour when it reached 10 million
users it will continue to have until 1
billion users are reached I'm learning
about this whole new cryptocurrency
transformation in pi Network Alex was
sure that he definitely wanted to lay
his hands on it for once with branding
based on the number Pi the Project's
first phase began on Pi Day on March 14
2019 with the free pie mining app the
network had over 100 000 active users by
June 2019 when Phase 2 began a year
later more than 3.5 million users were
there in May 2020 the app began running
advertisements in order to raise funds
for the project on March 15 2022 Pi
Network said its user base had grown to
33 million up from 14 million in March
2021. it will enable a completely
decentralized web where users are in
control
basically it's designed to link public
and permission networks or Vehicles
private and Consortium chains and yet to
be developed future Technologies through
the polka dot relay chain polka dot
enables an internet with separate
blockchains can communicate data and
transactions in an untrusted manner
decentralized institutions services and
apps are now easier to build and Link
than ever before
polkadot aims to liberate Society from
its Reliance on a broken web where its
powerfully institutions cannot betray
our confidence by giving entrepreneurs
the tools they need to create better
Solutions
now this whole explanation raises a
question of who is responsible for
building polka dot
so let me explain you the web 3
Foundation a Swiss organization
established to promote a fully
functional and user-friendly
decentralized web has made polka dot its
Flagship project
and encourage the creation of the
services and apps that will run on it
the web 3 Foundation is collaborating
with top tier organizations
a world-class implementation of web 3
with polka dot at its core is being
developed by researchers from India
Paris and eth Zurich developers from
parity Technologies and capital Partners
from cryptocurrency funds like polishing
capital in fact do you know that grants
are being offered by the web 3
foundation for ecosystem growth
well so moving on let me take you
through the working of polka dot
because so many parrot genes help the
main relay chain with a lot of the heavy
lifting polka dot is able to analyze all
this data as a result compared to around
seven for Bitcoin and 30 for ethereum
the bulgar Network can execute more than
1000 transactions per second now
polkadot should become much faster if
the network expands and more para chains
are added and then the speed can reach a
million transactions per second as well
now let me take you through a very
important aspect of kolka.network which
is very evident in its name itself and
that is Dot now the native token of the
poll cutout network is Dot gone's action
fees taking governance purchasing a
parish in space and enabling a number of
crucial polka dot features may all be
done with DOT now these dots can be
connected in multiple ways so let's
discuss them one by one first is relay
tuning it's polka dot score aspect and
is in charge of the networks into
parallability across chains consensus
and shared security
second is para genes now these are
independent blockchains that are capable
of creating their own coins and
tailoring their functionality to
particular use cases
third is para thread which is similar to
Parrot chains but uses a pay as your
GoPayment system
now blockchains without a constant
connection to the network are most cost
effective
fourth is Bridges now this enables
connections and communication between
para chains and para threads and other
networks like ethereum and Bitcoin
so now that I have already discussed
about dots let me give you a quick
overview of how one can use these dots
so
if you have one dot it is bare minimum
balance needed to maintain an active
polka dot Network account now your
account will be deleted if the amount
Falls below one dot so find out more
about accounts and the need for existing
deposits
then we have 5 dot to participate in
crowd loans for para chain slot auctions
you must make a minimum contribution of
this amount
then we have 10 Dot it is the bare
minimum stake necessary to submit your
nomination of validators purpose however
in order to receive taking incentives
your stake must be greater than the
dynamic minimum stay among active
nominators find out how to nominate
people
and then it's 20 Dot you can cast a
council vote or register an on-chain
identity now the Democracy of polka dot
benefit from dot to make suggestions to
support them and to vote on them when
they become
referendums
dot must be bonded
to submit a treasury proposal 100 dot in
bonds of five percent of the required
funds must be provided now you may be
able to take part in initiatives like
the Thousand validators programs thanks
to Dot
now moving ahead let me tell you about
why you should consider polka dot
so polka dot provides a platform for
everyone regardless of whether you are a
blockchain developer or just interested
in being a part of the community this
Wiki provider a location for Builders
and maintainers to use tools and for new
students to explore educational content
now let me tell you about how staking
actually works on polka dot
so in order to protect the network or
validate transactions or generate and
distribute new DOT polka dot uses a
proof of stake consensus process
depending on how much time technical
expertise and money they wish to invest
dot holders can engage with the staking
mechanism in a variety of ways like
validators
who do the most work it's a big
commitment and calls for technological
expertise you must maintain a node or
one of the computers that makes up the
network with little to no downtime and
stake a sizable portion of your own dot
in order to become a validator now you
gain the ability to approve valid
transactions and add new blocks of the
transaction to the relay chain and
potentially establish dot while also
receiving a cut of transaction fees and
tips in return
next we have is nominators they enable
everyday investors to take part in
staying covertly you can trust a
validator to follow the rules if you
give them part of your dot in return you
receive a portion of the dot that your
selected validators earn now you risk
losing some of your stake if your
validators violates the rules so choose
carefully any of the jobs mentioned
above will allow you to stay and
participate in the network in order to
be eligible for DOT Awards holders of
dots can vote on proposed software
changes and have a say in how the
network is run
so this was all about polka dots and
it's related well let's have a look at
what you are going to learn in this
video about Litecoin
so first I will take you through
the definition of what is Litecoin
followed by how it works then I will let
you explore the differences between
Litecoin and Bitcoin
then I will help you understand what are
the pros and cons of Litecoin
then I will explain to you how Litecoin
is used following that I will explain to
you how Litecoin is traded and then I
will let you explore why trade Litecoin
with CMC Markets
and then I will take you through the
factors that affect Litecoin
and in the end why should you buy
Litecoin so let's get started with the
video first let me make you understand
what is Litecoin
now the native cryptocurrency of the
open source blockchain project Litecoin
whose code is a copy of Bitcoins is LTC
as the silver to bitcoin's gold Litecoin
was created to be more scalable and to
process transactions consider more
quickly than Bitcoin in October 2011
Charlie Lee a software engineer who had
previously worked at Google
and the cryptocurrency exchange coinbase
announced the creation of the blockchain
on the Bitcoin talk forum now that we
know what is Litecoin let me take you
through how it actually works
Now using an open source cryptographic
technology digital coins are created and
transferred using Litecoin it keeps a
decentralized public Ledger for all
transactions using blockchain technology
now what is blockchain technology
a shared digital Ledger called the
blockchain contains a record of every
Litecoin transaction by miners recent
cryptocurrency transactions are compiled
into blocks after that the blocks are
cryptographically protected before being
connected to the pre-existing blockchain
now Litecoin and Bitcoin among other
cryptocurrencies also use similar
blockchain technology
now this raises a question that what is
mining now mining is the process of
employing miners or mining software to
secure each block to the current
blockchain the release of new Litecoin
units are coming a block has been
secured these units can be reintroduced
into the market by miners well this
raises another question that how exactly
Litecoin differs from Bitcoin now this
comparison will be made on a few
parameters first is
coin release date Litecoin was launched
on 7 October 2011 whereas Bitcoin was
released on 9 Jan 2009.
second is maximum coin Supply
there is a limited supply of coins in
circulation for both Bitcoin and
Litecoin Litecoin has 84 million coins
accessible which is almost four times as
many as Bitcoins 21 million
third is average transaction speed now
despite requiring more Advanced
Equipment than Bitcoin to mine which
takes almost 10 minutes blocks in
Litecoin are actually generated in 2.5
minutes up to four times faster
additionally Litecoin executes Financial
transactions much more quickly and can
handle more of them in the same amount
of time
fourth is halving having interval for
Block rewards their range is based on
basically market supply only and the
last one is mining algorithm a
cryptocurrencies blockchain can grow by
adding new blocks when mine is
successfully solve hash functions now
Litecoin in Bitcoin employ different
mining algorithms script is the hash
function used by Litecoin and Bitcoin
utilizes Sha 256.
now let me explain to you the pros and
cons of Litecoin
now the popularity of Litecoin started
to soar in 2017. five years later it is
still in demand and sales for over 70
dollars it has fared better than many of
its Rivals during the recent
cryptocurrency seller but Investments
always carry a risk it's impressive how
relative stability has held up for
Litecoin throughout time though it
exhibits steadiness but lacks the
impressive growth that attracts
investors
although the coins are reasonably priced
they are nonetheless more expensive than
most of their Rivals also litecoin's
market capitalization is smaller than
other cryptocurrency and it has lost
market share as well also Litecoin is
less speculative than many of the
younger coins even if all cryptocurrency
Investments are speculative
the expansion of Litecoin may be
constrained by the fact that it is less
scalable than competitive blockchain
like Stellar lumens so now that we have
covered the basics of Litecoin let me
take you through how Litecoin is exactly
used
now due to its strong liquidity Litecoin
is a cryptocurrency with simpler trading
actually owners of Litecoin will
discover the businesses like Newegg
sling TV and even Charities like the
American Red Cross are glad to take
their digital money
to make a payment with LTC you can
alternatively utilize a digital currency
app like bitpay or crypto pay now you
can use the binance app to send money
using LTC if you wish to use it for
peer-to-peer payments now let's see how
litecon is exactly traded
now the price of one Litecoin is
typically indicated against the US
dollar when purchasing it on an exchange
in other words you are selling USD to
purchase LTC if the price of Litecoin
increases you can sell it for a profit
because it is now worth more in USD than
when you first purchase it now if you
opt to sell at a lower price and incura
loss this is what will happen also you
can trade Litecoin with CMC Markets
using a spread bed a contract per
difference or save the account this
enables you to make price predictions
without actually owning the
cryptocurrency the possession of
Litecoin is not transferred instead you
are taking a stake whose value will
fluctuate with changes in the price of
Litecoin related to the US dollar
now that you know how Litecoin is traded
let me explain to you why Litecoin
should be traded with CMC Markets so the
first reason is open a long or short
position
now you can trade on increasing and
falling prices with speed betting at
cfds to sell Litecoin which is not
available on cryptocurrency exchanges
and you do not need to hold any second
is efficient use of capital now when you
trade using leverage you merely put up a
small portion of the total trade value
to pick in a position with well-known
cryptocurrency exchanges you must
deposit the entire contract's value
remember that both gains and losses will
be Amplified and your risk losing for
more money than you initially invested
third is no exchange account or wallet
there's no requirement to open an
exchange account or wallet to store the
purchase Litecoin in contrast to trading
the underlying cryptocurrency this
eliminates the need to wait for exchange
approval worry about keeping your wallet
secure and pay fees if you decide to
withdraw money later
fourth is trade with an established
provider CMC Markets is a licensed
provider with 29 years in the business
we provide assistance to all of our
customers anytime the markets are open
and fifth is treat responsibility for
most people cryptocurrencies are still
rather new and can be very unstable they
want our clients to fully access
comprehensive instructions resources to
support their trade now let's have a
look at the factors that actually affect
the LTC coin now similar to bitcoin
litecoins what liability is likely
influenced by the following factors
first is regulation governments and
central banks presented do not control
cryptocurrencies there are concerns
about how this might evolve over the
coming years and its effect on value
second is Supply there are only so many
litecoins that can be mined which is 84
million the rate at which coins are
introduced to the market can also
effectively availability
third is stress public opinion security
durability and the pricing of competing
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin can all
Impact Litecoin prices
and fourth is adoption neither consumers
nor businesses have yet embraced
Litecoin as a form of payment however
some believe that blockchain technology
has promise and may one day be more
widely used now the biggest question of
concern is
should you buy Litecoin according to
blasky or big Ira Litecoin might be a
good addition to the portfolio of an
experienced cryptocurrency investor who
values its stability and adaptability
particularly for those who want a
combination store of value Asset with
the side bonus of convenient
transactions
According to some experts Litecoin might
be a suitable investment for a beginner
looking to learn the ins and outs of
cryptocurrency trading Mania makes the
following conclusion about whether LTC
is a good option for your wallet there
are other blockchain competitors that
individuals need picture but Litecoin
Still Remains a relevant choice so let's
have a look at what we are going to
learn in this video
first we will learn what is algorithm
followed by what is algon then we will
look into its foundation and protocol
then we will understand what is
algorithms taking mechanism and how does
algorithm work and at the end we will
see how to buy algorithm
so before we understand the in-depth
mechanism of algorithm let's first
understand what algorithm is
the blockchain network and project
algorithm was established in 2017 by MIT
computer scientist Professor Sylvia
McKelly in June 2019 I'll go the
Network's native cryptocurrency and the
minute Network both became live
the blockchain facilitates smart
contracts and as was already mentioned
focuses on increased scalability with
support for customizable layer 1
blockchains the algorithm network is a
public decentralized pure proof of Sting
blockchain
now these can be used to build
blockchains that are customized for
particular purposes according to the
initiative Financial Services
decentralized finance fintech and
institutions can all benefit freely from
its technology
well this reminds me do you know which
nation is the first nation to accept
digital currency
to figure out which nation is taking a
step toward future technology hang on
till the end of this video till then you
can all comment down your answers below
now let's get back to the video
so now that we have come to its crypto
algo let's understand that also in
detail
the native currency of algorithm algo
has a total Supply cap of 10 billion
coins which will be issued by 2030.
newly forced block is accompanied by a
new algo that is sent to particular I'll
go holding wallets
so you must have at least one algo in a
non-custed deal wallet to obtain these
algo incentives approximately every 10
minutes this reward which offers algo
holders and apy of between five and
eight percent is given out now due to
this process you can passively stake the
algo coin making it one of the easiest
cryptocurrencies to earn a passive
income now that we know what is
algorithm let's have a look at how its
foundation was built and what projects
it deals with
the algorithm network is funded and
expanded by the algorithm Foundation a
non-profit corporation that was
established in 2019
additionally it contributes
significantly to blockchain governance
research and community
for instance the foundation has provided
developers with education through
University programs and has assisted
algorithm projects within its ecosystem
with accelerator programs however the
private Corporation algorithm
incorporative is in charge of technical
development
Additionally the algorithm Foundation
holds a sizable amount of alcohol which
it utilizes to finance its operations
now this raises the question of what
protocol algorithm primarily follows so
let's have a peek at them
the algorithm Network asserts to address
three main problems referred to as the
blockchain true Lemma
security scalability and
decentralization these are the three
main issues the algorithm protocol
intends to address so let's discuss them
one by one
first is security
now the algorithm protocol is resistant
to malicious assaults which makes it
perfect for transactions keeping
valuable assets and developing secure
business applications
it keeps security at both the network
and consensus protocol levels and
safeguards user accounts individually
second is decentralization
now algorithm lacks a single point of
control or centralized Authority
participating nodes in the network
verified transactions and all nodes have
an equal voice in decision making
algorithm is an extremely decentralized
system as a result
so because the selection is both random
and private anybody on the network has a
chance to be a member of the committee
of users that approves each block
so there is a new set committee and
volunteers from all over the world
administer it notes third is scalability
now the algorithm protocol is more
scalable than Bitcoin or ethereum
because it can process several
transactions per second now the
consensus protocol developed by
algorithm eliminates the requirement for
the computational power that Bitcoin or
ethereum uses to address cryptographic
issues well this brings us to the
staking mechanism of algorithm
special proof of stake variant known as
pure proof of stake one algo token is
all that is necessary to participate in
pure proof of stay
and to help secure the network
on the contrary ethereum 2.0 has a 32
ether minimum stake requirement creating
a substantially higher entrance barrier
for consumers on the other hand a low
minimum staking requirement can
compromise network security such users
may not act ethically if they have
little money at stake in the network
so now that we know that ethereum and
algorithm are closely working with proof
of stake there's a huge rivalry
competition between them so let's see
how they both actually differ from each
other
now blockchain Technologies like
algorithm and ethereum can be seen as
Rivals both platforms employ smart
contracts and provide the infrastructure
necessary for creating more blockchain
based projects
so algorithmet ethereum differs from one
another primarily in the blockchain's
consensus mechanism
ethereum employs the proof of work
algorithm which needs a lot of energy
and processing power to mine new
currencies and complete transactions
ethereum is increasingly switching to
the proof of stake algorithm the most
popular kind that needs blockchain
Network users to choose them as
validators on the other hand algorithm
is already using pure proof of stake
now on average a new block of
transactions can be processed on the
ethereum platform every 12 to 14 seconds
whereas algorithm Network transactions
are completed more quickly in less than
4 seconds also
so now that we have covered all the
basics of algorithm let's dive deeper
and have a look at how it actually works
with proof of stake
now algorithm has provided a two layer
smart contract design since 2020 that
differs significantly from past methods
and this is how it goes
now layer 1 is on chain for smart
contracts that carry out basic usually
transactions directly on the blockchain
now algorithm layer 1 deals with atomic
transfers or when several parties
consent to swap cash
whereas layer 2 is off chain and is for
specific two required smart contracts
this covers two large two complex or two
computationally demanding smart
contracts
the gist is that less complex smart
contracts which will take longer to
process operate outside the blockchain
and run on a different platform now
algorithm can operate more efficiently
than single layer blockchain thanks to
this architecture
algorithm uses a pure proof of stake
mechanism to validate transactions now
anyone can stake their tokens and take
part in the validation process if they
have at least one algo in their
possession the algorithm protocol
chooses participants to validate blocks
of transaction the possibility of
selection for each online user depends
on the number of algo tokens
users receive participation benefits for
confirming their transactions
so here are the three steps that
algorithm undergoes while working with
first is proposal stage
now users become participation notes
once they have staked and generated
their participation key algorithm really
notes serve as the channel for
communication between these nodes
now the block proposal phase then uses a
verifiable random function to choose
several block proposers while taking
into account the percentage of each
validators state the identity of the
chosen block proposal is hidden until
the new blog is offered because harmful
actors cannot Target the selected
validator network security also
increases however proposal can exhibit
their vrf output with the proposed block
to demonstrate their legitimacy
then comes the second stage this soft
board stage
participation notes are chosen randomly
to join the soft vote committee after a
block has been submitted so that only
one candidate can add to the blockchain
this stage screens ideas voting power on
the soft committee is proportionate to
each note stake and votes are utilized
to choose the proposed block with the
lowest vrf hash
now because the lowest vrf hash is an
unpredictable value it will be hard to
attack the blog's proposal in advance
and then comes the last stage certify
word stage the Integrity of the
transaction in the block from the soft
word stage will be examined by a new
committee established to look for double
spending now the block is added if the
committee accepts the work if not a new
blog is chosen the current block is
rejected and the blockchain goes into
recovery mode
it is a aspect of pure proof of stake
consensus mechanism since the leader who
suggests a faulty block is not subject
to a slashing penalty
algorithm folks are relatively uncommon
because only one block proposal may be
certified at a given time all
transactions are then deemed as final
after the block has been added
so now that we have covered all the
technical Concepts and functionalities
of algorithm let me tell you where you
can actually buy algorithm
basically you have a wide range of
choices available when it comes to
purchasing cryptocurrencies thankfully
coinbase binance
etoro Kraken and crypto.com works
wherever algorithm is available so you
may purchase algorithm it is PD simple
and secure
well this brings us to the end of this
video but before ending this video let's
have a look at the question I asked you
before in this video
well the first nation you to accept
digital currency is the Marshall Islands
the Republic of the Marshall Islands is
a country that Embraces emerging
Technologies to create an open Financial
system that uses blockchain technology
the sov a digital currency will coexist
with the US dollar in circulation and
support the Marshall Islands productive
participation in the world economy first
we will understand what an avalanche
network is and why it is so special
followed by what avax crypto is used for
then we will understand the working of
the Avalanche Network
and then we will look into the benefits
of the Avalanche Network and at the end
where and how to buy
so first we will understand what the
Avalanche network is so Avalanche is a
blockchain platform that can support
smart contracts and it was introduced in
2020 by Ava Labs Avalanche focuses on
low prices quick transaction times and
environmental friendliness to create a
scalable blockchain system while
maintaining decentralization and
security users can build as many unique
and functional blockchains as they want
with Avalanche one must pay a monthly
subscription fee to run a blockchain on
the Avalanche coin Apex
but why is Avalanche Network so special
well Ava Labs estimates that the
platform can process
4500 transactions per second compared to
about seven for Bitcoin and 14 for
ethereum additionally it can complete a
transaction in less than three seconds
multiple competing platforms will have
bottlenecks making them more suitable
for massively scalability decentralized
applications
also Avalanche is designed to address
interoperability another significant
issue currently plaguing blockchain
based systems and is very scalable this
is accomplished by permitting
communication between blockchains within
and between subnets allowing them to
complement one another and support
cross-chain value transfers
well now that we know what an avalanche
network is let's look at the usage of
avax crypto technically avax the native
token is a utility token the currency of
the Avalanche ecosystem is avax well in
other words the token is utilized as
money within the network generally for
rewards fee collection during
transactions and many other use cases
additionally it is employed for staking
avax which protects the network then
followers are rewarded with more avacs
and some users stake avax to generate
passive revenue on the network now let's
have a look at the working of the
Avalanche Network
avalanche's developers set out to find a
solution to some of the typical issues
that earlier blockchains like Bitcoin
face to advance and improve blockchain
technology continuously
incompatibility scalability and
usability issues are just a few of these
and by utilizing three blockchains
Avalanche uses a novel strategy to
address these issues
according to time to finality metrics
Avalanche claims to be the fastest smart
contracts platform in the blockchain
industry
the three blockchains that make up the
Avalanche mainnet are x-chain this
blockchain is employed for Asset
Management the Avalanche consensus
protocol is employed then comes C chain
to develop smart contracts this
blockchain is used the Snowman consensus
protocol is employed and in the end it
is p chain and this blockchain is
utilized to create smart contracts and
the protocol for snowman consensus is
used
by having all nodes operate concurrently
the Avalanche consensus protocol
randomly verifies validators transaction
confirmations the goal is to improve the
likelihood that a transaction is true or
legitimate by periodically performing
random checks the Snowman consensus
protocol uses blocks in a linear manner
but otherwise functions similarly well
now that we know the basics of the
Avalanche Network let's have a look at
problems that is solved by this network
well as we discussed before Avalanche
was developed to deal with many of the
problems that most blockchain networks
have platforms like Avalanche aim to
reduce centralization in the
cryptocurrency industry by offering an
alternative to networks like ethereum
Avalanche primarily addresses two issues
congestion scalability was a purposeful
consideration in the creation of
avalanche Avalanche offers sub-second
transaction times on par with top-tier
payment processors like PayPal and Visa
with the ability to handle up to 6500
transactions per second with sub-second
finality Avalanche is incredibly strong
and effective and second is low fees
Avalanche which many people view as
ethereum's rival outperforms ethereum
regarding gas costs avalanche's fees are
significantly less expensive than
ethereums the network charges fees for
several things including producing and
minting assets staking transaction fees
and blockchain development after these
things are done the fees are burned
permanently lowering the amount of avacs
on the platform
and now let's look at some of the
benefits of avalanche Network
The Manor Avalanche was constructed is
mostly responsible for its key
advantages the founders of avalanche
discovered a solution to the frequent
issues with blockchains by utilizing the
Network's special design
first on the list is interoperability
the trade of different types of
cryptocurrencies and data with other
platforms is only supported by a few
blockchains Avalanche makes
interoperability possible by enabling
several blockchains to exchange
information and essentially interoperate
with one another
then it is scalability for instance
mining Bitcoin uses a lot of power in
processing resources and ethereum can
handle only 15 transactions per second
these restrictions make these
blockchains difficult to scale despite
their strength and great value
on the other hand Avalanche promises
sub-second transaction rates and amazing
processing capacity and was designed to
be expandable
and next is usability
usability or how simple it is to use and
implement the technology in many
applications and use cases is one of the
issues with adopting any technology
Avalanche is gaining popularity in the
cryptocurrency world at a rate that can
compete with ethereum and has
demonstrated utility in several
situations
so now that we have discussed all the
necessary Concepts around the Avalanche
Network let's see where and how to buy
avax
these are a few platforms with
illustrations of how to buy avax on that
particular platform first is uphold
followed by binance and then bitpanda
and then gate.io
hey everyone we often encounter
situations where we feel like buying our
own house but sometimes it becomes a
little too expensive but you buy it
anyway well to make that happen you need
to borrow a loan from the bank so you
put up a down payment of 20 percent so
you can borrow the rest of the 80
percent from the bank and make the
payments and if you fail to make the
payment to the bank they can easily
confiscate the house now what exactly
happens is the bank lends you money
knowing that you will pay high interest
on it and then the banks give that
interest to its lenders of course after
having their profiting charges well Ave
is a cryptocurrency version of that bank
so why wait let's embark on this
exhilarating adventure together but
before we dive in if you're looking to
take your career to new heights and
become a true expert in the room of
blockchain and cryptocurrency consider
checking out our professional
certificate program in blockchain in
collaboration with
it's an excellent opportunity to master
key architectural principles and develop
the skills needed to excel in this
rapidly growing field in this video you
will explore what is Ave and following
that you will see how exactly Ave came
into existence and then you will see how
it works and after that you'll see some
real life usages of Ave and at the end
you will explore whether it is safe or
not but before moving ahead please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting videos and hit
that Bell icon so you never miss an
update from Simply learn now moving on
to what is Ave Ave is technically a
decentralized application that allows
people to lend and borrow
cryptocurrencies all without a middleman
in return for some fees Ave uses an
algorithm to determine the lending rates
and match the borrowers with lenders
using a smart contract smart contracts
enable these assets to be managed by a
distributed network of computers running
its software and when lenders deposit
cryptocurrency into the protocol it is
routed to a liquidity pool where it is
used to meet the demands of the
protocol's borrowers now if you're
unfamiliar with what a liquidity pool is
you can definitely see our video on
liquidity pool which will be appearing
at the top of your screen right now this
means that other users do not have to
put their trust in a certain institution
or individual to manage their money they
merely need to believe that the code
will run exactly as intended well now
that you know what Ave is this raises a
question of how and why it came into
existence Ave was founded by stani
kulachoff who was very interested in
ethereum and how it could disrupt
traditional Finance in November of 2017
Stanley kulachoff and a team of
developers released ethland in an
initial coin offering or Ico by letting
users publish loan requests and offers
the intention was to enable users to
lend and borrow cryptocurrency from one
another although eathland was an
Innovative concept the network and its
Associated token lend lost popularity
once the 2018 bear Market began lack of
liquidity and the difficulty in matching
loan requests to offers were the
platform's main problems in 2020
Eastland revamped its offering and
changed its name to Ave switching from
the Lend token to Ave in the process Ave
was redeemable for 100 lend for every
token as part of the migration and since
that movement the group has received
more than 32 million dollars from some
of the leading Venture capitalists in
the blockchain industry including
blockchain capital and standard crypto
so now that you know the functionality
and the motive of Ave let me take you
through the workings of Ave to make you
understand how it fulfills its motive so
the first step is to submit have a
request for comment or Arc the post
should provide all the details of the
potentially final AIP when an arc is
submitted on the governance Forum as a
result the community will have the
opportunity to offer suggestions for
improvement and if a general consensus
can be reached through a community poll
to successfully submit and vote on the
AIP now following that the second step
is to create a snapshot all queries and
remarks are addressed after being placed
on the governance Forum in order to
enhance the arc to get input from the
community and choose the preferred
course a snapshot vote is advised this
quick view enables a general agreement
to be reached to increase the likelihood
that the AIP submission will succeed and
then comes the last step which is to
submit an Ave request for improvement or
AIP a GitHub pull request is used to
submit the suggestion and the community
decides whether to approve it moving on
let me take you through some of the real
life uses of Ave
first is security users can stake the
Ave erc20 token to help secure the
system and receive compensation in
return second is collateral borrowers
who pledge the native token as security
for their loans are required to pay
lower costs than those who utilize other
cryptocurrencies that are locked within
the platform and the third one is Dao
Ave serves as the Dow's governance token
and can be used to cast votes on
proposals about the addition of
additional tokens to the protocol
platform functionality and other uses
well this was all about Ave but wait one
question remains unanswered is are they
safe well Ave a decentralized money
market paves the path for a more
transparent and open Financial system
Ave is an intriguing D5 project that
enables transparent access to funds and
services for Bitcoin users another
encouraging advancement is the Ave token
it gives its owners the power to change
the Ave protocol the procedure is
additionally safeguarded from Black Swan
situations so now this was all about are
they gone let's look at the concepts you
will be exploring in this topic first
you will understand what is Iota
following that you will explore what is
tangle in iotis tangle and then you will
come across the working of Iota and
iota's architecture after that you will
see some features of iota's tangle and
the impact of Iota in real life
so what is iota's tangle iota's tangle
is a distributed Ledger that is open
cost free and scalable and is made to
facilitate frictionless data and value
movement the Iota network is the
backbone of iot and is designed for the
internet of things and has low resource
requirements tamper-proof data and
fee-free microtransactions the internet
of everything is a network for
exchanging money and data between
devices and this distributed Ledger is
the first one designed for it also Iota
has no blocks no miners policy which
means you validate two additional
transactions when you send an Iota
transaction and this enables Iota to get
around blockchains financial and
scalability constraints in short Iota is
positioned to be a key player in the
upcoming Industrial Revolution by
facilitating business interactions
between machines and connecting the
economies of P people and machines but
this raises a question what does the
tangle stand for in iota's tangle Well
iota's network is called the tangle it
permanently documents the data and value
exchange it guarantees that the data is
reliable and cannot be changed or erased
it's kind of a digital Ledger that is
replicated on all nodes in an Iota
Network all the data in the tangle is
stored in objects called transactions
and when a transaction is attached to
the tangle it cannot be changed and is
immutable in short it contains the
current transaction history and is the
single source of Truth
so now that you know about the basics of
iota's Tangle let me take you through
the working of it first let's make this
clear that Iota is not a blockchain it's
a dag which stands for directed a cyclic
graph dag is used to agreeing on all of
the transactions inside their tangle
though dags are similar to blockchain
they are still way faster and can scale
better seeming to be the next evolution
of blockchain Technology
in Iota Network each transaction is
called a node which are connected to
each other using edges or arcs directed
stated that the graph as a direction and
the acyclic part states that the graph
always continues in One Direction and
never has a loop now each node will try
to point to at least two other past
nodes but you can find up to eight
once that node has two other future
nodes directed toward it it will be a
confirmed transaction and this whole
network of nodes is called tangle
and the more people use Iota the faster
it gets because you have those two nodes
pointing towards your transaction faster
but what is iota's architecture for
those transactions to take place iota's
architecture includes the following
basic components client users who send
transactions to nodes on the Iota
Network such as wallets applications and
Etc can join the tangle nodes devices
that are connected and in charge of
maintaining the tangles Integrity Iota
is a network made up of these devices
tangle the tangle stores all of its data
in objects referred to as transactions a
transaction becomes immutable and
unchangeable once it is linked to the
tangle well now that you have understood
all the concepts of iota's Tangle let me
tell you some unique features of iota's
tangle
first it is highly scalable unlike
blockchain Alternatives Iota uses a dag
or directed a cyclic graph data
structure that enables transactions to
be added in parallel second is fast
transactions Iota transactions are
confirmed within minutes unlike other
cryptocurrencies whose transaction
confirmation rates depend on the crowd
third is low resource requirements as
discussed in this video Iota is designed
to enable devices to participate in a
low energy Network such as sensors
fourth is finality within seconds the
approval of genuine messages happens
extremely swiftly and effectively
fifth is zero fee transaction as we know
this is the USP of iota's tangle if it
sends one cent it receives one cent and
if it sends a million dollars it
receives a million dollars
and sixth is distributed Iota is a
globally distributed Network that is
resilient and robust against the tax
in continuing this let me take you
through the impact of iotis tangle in
the real world
first is social impact the Iota
Foundation encourages the utilization of
technology to improve Society at large
it focuses on sustainability harnessing
the power of iot to manage natural
resources more efficiently
an identity introducing digital identity
to people Beyond borders and
citizen-centric governance to enable
more transparent and inclusive
governance
second is global trade
Iota can make it easier for businesses
governments logistic companies and end
users to work together while fostering
trust it focuses on track and Trace
sharing updates throughout the supply
chain with provenance data from the
source Customs and Border management
update trade certifications for
International Exchange and digital Twins
turn any product container or
Consignment into a digital twin
and the third one is unifying digital
identity Iota aims to provide trust
between individuals organizations and
things it focuses on self-sovereign
identity a borderless digital identity
that anyone can verify the identity of
things identities to allow devices to
prove their authenticity and
specifications
Regulatory Compliance digital identities
that meet data privacy regulations like
gdpr hey everyone think of a situation
where a person a with headsets wants to
get an iPad and a person B wants to get
in headset with an iPad
so to reach out to each other easily
they go to a gadget shop and sell their
products that shop
and buy the other products headset for
person B and iPad of a person name there
itself
well similar to this gadget shop uni
swap also serves as a platform where you
can exchange ethereum coin with any
ethereum token just by paying a very
small fee and without any intermediaries
hey everyone well in this video you are
going to explore what is uni swap and
what is you and I then you will learn
about its governance process
how does uni swap work
following that you will know how to use
uniform and what are the pros and cons
of using sperm and at last you will know
how to invest in uni swap
let's get started with what uniswap is
uni swap is a completely different kind
of exchange that uses an automatic
liquidity protocol a latest trading
methodology that is fully decentralized
meaning it isn't owned and run by a
single entity
it enables peer-to-peer Market making
uni swap is also a cryptocurrency whose
symbol is uni it enables users to trade
cryptocurrencies without any involvement
with a centralized third party the
ethereum platform serves as the
foundation for the universe black
blockchain
which is controlled by uni owners and is
completely open source meaning that
anyone can view and contribute to the
blockchain school
basically works on supply and demand
mechanisms let me show you how
on Uni's work when you exchange your
ethereum they give you a fair market
value of the basic ethereum token
now after you are done the price of
basic ethereum token Rises because there
are less of them since you bought it and
price of ethereum drops because there is
more of it since you sold it now whoever
comes next will have to buy the basic
ethereum token at a higher price or sell
some ethereum at a higher price
this is actually done to even out the
liquidity pool so that uni swap has an
even amount of ethereum and on the basic
Italian tokens
so now that you know what uniswap is let
me take you through what you and I is
basically the uni swap token makes it
possible for the community and
stakeholders to own and actively manage
the protocol by voting on important
protocol updates and development
projects
through an orange and governance process
uni holders run this protocol therefore
anyone can earn you and I but agreeing
to not sell or trade their crypto
Holdings
question of what is uniswap governance
process is so the first step is the
temperature check procedure determines
whether there is enough motor to change
the current situation
a majority Award with a 25k uni yes vote
threshold prevails at the end of the two
days now the subject is closed on the
governance side if the temperature check
does not suggest that there should be a
change from the current situation then
if it does suggest any changes then it
is pushed to Second Step that is the
consensus check
now the consensus check procedure
develops a formal conversation
surrounding a proposal and takes into
account feedback from the temperature
check another off-ching vote follows
consensus check and a majority vote with
a 50k uni yes vote threshold prevails
after 5 days
and then comes the last step that is the
governance proposal the governance
process ends with the governance
proposal The Proposal comes with a
launching executable code and should
take into account the consensus check
suggestions a delegate must have a
minimum balance of 2 million uni in
order to submit an on-chean governance
proposal a majority vote with a 40 m uni
yes War threshold wins after a seven day
voting period now that you know the
mechanism of of the unisport platform
let me tell you how it actually works
the uni swap platform enables the
decentralized trade of numerous
different digital assets using smart
contracts big on the blockchain through
liquidity pools which utilize smart
contracts to automatically rebalance
themselves up to each trade pairs or
digital assets are exchanged uni swap is
powered by two smart contracts The
Exchange contract and the factory
contract
these automatic computer programs made
to carry out particular tasks when
certain criterias are met in this case
the factory smart contract is used to
add new tokens to platform while the
exchange contract handles all token
swaps or trades
on the new uni swap version 2 platform
any erc20 base token can be exchanged
for another well this covers all the
internal functionality of uniswap so
moving on you will learn how to use
uniswa
well you only need an ethereum wallet
like coinbase wallet and a small amount
of EDH which you'll need to pay for gas
fees in order to utilize unisa you can
access
app.uniswap.org to begin exchanging
tokens or provide liquidity by using the
app browser included in the coinbase
wallet mobile application or its desktop
browse extension moving on let me tell
you about some of its pros and cons
well it enables to decentralize exchange
of many digital assets but it only
supports the exchange of ethereum
compatible cryptocurrencies second smart
contracts enable asset trading that may
be cheaper and more efficient but it
still uses proof of work which is an
energy and resource intensive process
uni swap users can earn you and I but
agreeing to not sell or trade their
cryptocurrency Holdings but uses must do
an eth to pay transaction processing fee
fourth decentralized governance of the
uni swap platform enables anyone to
participate however using a
decentralized exchange requires a
compatible self-hosted wallet
so now comes the most important question
of this whole discussion
how can you invest in units work
by getting you and I you can make an
investment in uni swap using a
centralized cryptocurrency exchange like
coinbase or Kraken is the simplest way
to purchase you and I
another coin like ethereum can be used
to buy uni on the unit swap platform
that's Monero so to make you familiar
with what Monero is let me give you the
example of Lena Lena is a journalist in
a surveillance heavy country who wants
to keep her financial transactions
private she's interested in Bitcoin but
knows it's not completely Anonymous and
could still be traced back to her
Bitcoin address one day Lena comes
across Monero and discovers that Monero
is designed to prioritize privacy and
security
she decides to use manureo to buy some
books from an online bookstore
she sends the payment from her Monero
wallet to the provided address which is
completely private and unreasonable the
bookstore confirms receipt of the
payment and ships or books Lena is
pleased with the privacy and security of
Monero and plans to use it for all her
future online purchases
now if we speak in short Monero is an
open source privacy oriented digital
cryptocurrency that provides users with
complete privacy and security when
making a transaction
its blockchain is OPEC which makes
transaction details and amounts
Anonymous by obscuring the addresses
used by participants leena's story is
one just example of how Monero can be
used to protect one's Financial privacy
and Security in a world where data is
becoming more and more valuable but what
makes Monero so private if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well monero's privacy feature makes it
different from other cryptocurrencies in
order to provide privacy and anonymity
when I wrote relies on two important
Concepts still addresses and ring
signatures now still address with stilt
addresses a sender can create a unique
public address on behalf of the
recipient for each transaction with the
recipient can still receive all payments
using a single public address just like
in Bitcoin
Monero users will generate both a
private view key and a private spend key
the private view key enables them to
view all the transactions linked to the
account while the private spend key
functions similarly to a Bitcoin private
key as it authorizes payments now
talking about Ring signature ring
signatures are a cryptographic concept
that pertains to digital signatures it
allows any member of a defined group of
individuals with private keys to sign a
digital signature
in Monero when you initiate a
transaction your wallet selects a group
of keys from the blockchain and forms a
ring
as a result it is impossible for an
observer to determine which key was
utilized to sign providing anonymity to
the transaction now that you know the
basics of Monero let me take you through
the process of mining Monero
Nero is compatible with various
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS Linux Android and FreeBSD unlike
other cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin
Monero mining doesn't require
specialized Hardware like Asics which
can be really expensive instead you can
use the CPU or GPU of a standard
computer to mine Monero Monero utilizes
proof of work mining as stated on the
company's website this algorithm is
crucial for securing cryptocurrencies
such as Monero by preventing issues
related to double spending that will
actually misrepresent the available
Supply now let me tell you how one can
access Monero now although many
exchanges have opted not to offer Monero
there are still places to purchase it
if you're in the United States you can
buy Monero on track in Q coin or binance
and another way to get Monero is to
purchase it directly from another person
on the decent place peer-to-peer
platform bisc Exchange
or you can simply use Finance to do the
exchanges
first you will understand what is basic
attention token following that the
working of bad after that you will
understand how to use basic attention
token and then you will learn how you
can earn bad rewards and at the end you
will see what is basic attention token
used for so without any further Ado
let's get started with what is basic
attention token
the ethereum network serves as the
foundation for the decentralized open
source basic attention token digital
advertising ecosystem some of the topics
addressed by the project in relation to
Internet advertising include data
security data ownership and consumer
benefit its goal is to create an honest
transparent and Equitable system
advertisers will be able to Target users
directly and reward them with tokens for
the attention with the help of that in
contrast to traditional advertising
systems that use personal data to Target
ads bad users a blockchain based system
that allows users to opt into anonymous
ad targeting users can choose to view
relevant advertisements without having
their personal information shared with
advertisers but prioritizes your privacy
and gives you back control over your
data this raises the question of how Pat
is able to do this well the ethereum
blockchain serves as the basic attention
tokens Foundation as we know its
creators have collaborated with the
brave browser to implement the
Innovative advertising strategy Brave
has implemented the basic attention
metric or bam attention measuring system
it uses an anonymous Ledger system to
distribute money between readers content
readers and advertisers in fact it
brings them together for so many reasons
for example any content creator can
publish a post on their website now
advertisers offer a certain number of
basic attention tokens for ad space on
their content after that they will reach
an agreement based on the attention
score on the basis of user engagement it
basically means that ads are more
tailored to users and give the
advertisers the window of profit
ensuring that brave users see well
tailored ads while it also improves paid
privacy and security of the browser so
now that you have understood the
functioning of basic attention token let
me tell you how you can use a basic
attention token now because payments are
made in the form of tokens there are
numerous opportunities for seamless use
the first is to donate them to publisher
and other content creator this could
even include providing premium content
to donors these tokens can also be used
to purchase digital products such as
data service is on the brief platform
itself now how exactly to earn these bad
rewards now the first step is to
download the brave browser you can then
sign up for brave rewards by clicking on
the triangle next to the search bar
and then you can now start earning that
token simply by viewing advertisement
now advertisements appeared as
background images push notification or
cards in your news feed which is the
second step
they are not included in videos or
pop-ups making the experience seamless
and unobtrusive so now that you have
understood the basics let me tell you
the usage of bat
first is advertising The Advertiser in
this case provides the tokens that will
be distributed to those who view their
advertisements users who choose to
participate in bad rewards are also part
of this advertising ecosystem they are
compensated with tokens for each
advertisement they watch based on the
amount of time and attention they devote
to it second is tipping
now but makes it simple to Express
gratitude to your favorite content
creators you can use your tokens to tip
internet users such as twitch streamers
YouTubers and Twitter users this Fosters
a passionate community of users and
creators allowing for the creation of
better content and third is special
access bat can also be used to allow
content creators to create exclusive
content for users who tip or pay them
thus free and paid content can coexist
in a unified ecosystem this also enables
creators to give back to their
communities by creating exclusive
content for those who actually support
them but before diving right into the
list let's have a quick and crisp
understanding of what crypto trading
actually means
so taking a financial on the price
direction of individual cryptocurrencies
against the dollar or against any other
cryptocurrency is what crypto trading is
all about
cfds or contract for difference are a
popular way of trading cryptocurrencies
because they offer more flexibility
leverage and the ability to trade both
long and short positions
also it's essential to consider things
like supported assets fees
payment methods and security when
considering a cryptocurrency trading
platform so we have also considered
these factors to give you a better idea
of which platform will be the best for
you
so now that we have a basic idea of what
crypto trading is let's dive into the
list of top crypto trading platforms for
2022. the first platform in the list is
coinbase
for many first-time cryptocurrency
buyers coinbase has become the go to
exchange the platform has the appearance
and feel of an online banking tool which
the maturity of consumers are already
familiar with making the transfer to
crypto investing simple
coinbase is the finest cryptocurrency
exchange overall as well as the best
cryptocurrency exchange for beginners it
supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrencies and provide a high
level of security
it's also wonderful alternative for
expert Traders because it offers an
advanced trading platform coinbase Pro
in addition to being a beginner friendly
platform
so let's have a look at the equivalent
prerequisites for coinbase
it supports more than 150 Plus cryptos
for trading with the transaction fee
ranging between zero percent to 0.60
percent also the minimum deposit of
purchase price should be at least two
dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
coinbase offers large volume of
cryptocurrencies
what to trade for it provides smooth
experience to beginners as well as offer
easy training to advance members of it
it also provides liquidity and ease on
its platform
now cons the customer service provided
by them is not up to the mark as well as
coinbase.com is an Institutional account
which means you don't have access to
your private keys
moving on next we have is crypto.com
crypto.com offers a diverse digital
asset ecosystem that includes its own
blockchain the crypto.org a native token
known as cro a crypto Visa card yield
generating crypto products and more it
was chosen as the top mobile crypto
exchange application because it offers a
comprehensive digital asset trading and
investing environment that you can
access from your smartphone
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for crypto.com
it supports more than 250 Plus cryptos
for trading with a transaction fee
ranging between 0.04 percent to 0.40
percent also the minimum deposit or
purchase price should be at least one
dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
crypto.com supports a huge range of
cryptocurrencies to trade for and other
crypto related services like payments
and asset evolution
now moving towards cons it fees is
relatively High also the customer
service is a little poor and stagnant
next in the list we have is Gemini
Gemini stands out as a sign that
prioritizes security and compliance
hot wallet insurance is provided by the
New York based exchange to ensure that
user funds are protected in the event of
a security comprise because it has
comprehensive security protocols ensures
customer cash and is SOC 2 certified
Gemini is the most secure crypto
Exchange
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for Gemini
it only supports 75 plus cryptos for
trading with the transaction fee ranging
between 0.99 to 2.99 also it has a
minimum deposit
or Portuguese price and it varies
according to the asset invested
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
Gemini is available in all 50 states of
United States with extremely liquid
Market
all the funds stored in the wallets are
perfectly insured and secure also if UI
is pretty strong
coming towards cons many traders in it
have high cost also as compared to other
crypto trading platforms it supports
less cryptocurrencies as well
now moving on to the next platform in
the list we have binance
the most appealing feature of binance is
its low cost when compared to other
exchanges beginners will appreciate the
simple Buy sell option while
professional Traders will appreciate the
in-depth basic and advanced trading
platforms
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for binance it supports
more than 500 plus cryptos for trading
with a transaction fee ranging between
0.10 to 0.50 also it has no minimum
deposit or purchase price of 50 dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
purchase piece is non-imediate as well
as instant also a huge variety of points
is available on its platform along with
this it offers various other services
coming to the cons once the verification
of account was hampered it is not yet
available in United States and its
corporate structure is pretty opaque
next we have is Kraken
Kraken is one of the world's most
well-known Bitcoin exchanges in the
early days of the crypto Market it
established itself as the go-to site for
professional investors it has retained
its image as a trustworthy and
professional trading venue
it has some of the lowest fees in the
cryptocurrency exchange world it's also
a top pick for experienced Traders as it
allows leverage and Futures Trading as
well as enables complex order types now
let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for Kraken
basically it supports more than 120 plus
cryptos for trading with a small
transaction fee ranging between 0.00 to
0.26 also it has minimum deposit or
purchase price of minimum one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
supports a large range of cryptocurrency
with minimum fee and also provide the
Traders more Market liquidity
coming to the cons not all states in U.S
can accept it as options for financing
your account are limited
next in the list we have bitstamp
bitstamp is one of the most cost
effective Bitcoin exchanges it offers a
simple pricing structure that bases your
trading fees on your 30-day trading
volume
for users with less than
ten thousand dollars on bitstamp the
highest trading cost is merely 0.50 bit
stamp is a fantastic alternative
for fee conscious crypto investors
because its trading fees are lower than
those of many of its competitors
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
bits time offers only 45 cryptos for
trading with a very small transaction
fee ranging between 0.00 to 0.50 percent
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 10.
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
in terms of trading fees with stamp is
one of the top cryptocurrency exchanges
trade view a real-time trading platform
is also available this version contains
more extensive charting and trading
forms this platform offers a diverse
range of points including many of the
most popular as well as some lesser
known cryptos
and the cons are while bitstem offers a
good selection of cryptocurrencies there
are a significant ones that aren't
available
allows you to onpass money but there are
a few drawbacks as well in 2015 hackers
who successfully in launching a Fizz
phishing salt against bit stem workers
which resulted in a security breach
following bit stamp we have bitmap
bitmap is a global Bitcoin exchange with
over 180 locations users can purchase
sell and store over 1000 different
digital currencies and tokens investors
wishing wishing to add newly launched
or obscure crypto assets to the
portfolios while likely find what
they're searching for on this exchange
as it offers more assets and trading
pairs than its Market leading
counterparts let's have a look at the
account created visits for bitmap bitmap
offers 1000 plus cryptos for trading
with a very small transaction fee that
ranges between
0.045 percent to 0.25 percent
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 30 when purchasing
wire bitmap for spot trading the price
is not published yet
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
bitmut supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrency and provide great
opportunities to earn cryptocurrency as
well along with that it provides an easy
trade option for buying and selling
cryptocurrencies
now moving on to the cons there was a
large scale hack on this platform in
2021 also the customer reviews are
average for this application
moving on next in our list is cuecoin
Q coin is a third party cryptocurrency
exchange that lets you buy sell and
trade a variety of cryptocurrencies
the Founder's goal was to provide a
simple and secure platform for people
all around the world
to exchange a variety of digital
currency cuecoin has a large number of
cryptocurrencies to choose from and has
minimum cost when compared to other
cryptocurrency exchanges staking
leverage Futures and peer-to-peer
trading are all supported which may
appeal to more experienced users now
let's have a look at the account free
requisites for cuecoin so qcoin offers
only up to 28 cryptos for trading with a
very small transaction fee ranging
between 0.00 to 0.10
also coming to its minimal deposit or
purchase the price is nearly five
dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
qcoin maintains the anonymity of the
user while trading yet it offers secure
platform as well also it supports
multiple cryptocurrencies coming to the
cons the trading volume of
cryptocurrencies are pretty low and also
during heavy traffic it can face some
serious issues
following cuecoin in our list we have
cash app
now individuals in the United States and
the United Kingdom can use the cash app
to send spend deposit and invest money
it's an essentially a peer-to-peer
payment app with an investment component
through the cash app users can also
invest in stocks ETFs and Bitcoin it
enables you to purchase sell and store
Bitcoin
from your smartphone itself in a more
simpler and safer manner
now
looking at its account prerequisites
like we discussed cash app is only a
Bitcoin exchange application so it
supports only one cryptocurrency that is
Bitcoin the transaction fee varies
depending on the action also the minimum
deposit of purchase is just one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
up provides an easy access UI and quick
withdrawal from its wallets other than
this it also supports Bitcoin lighting
Network it's a second layer Bitcoin
technology that employs micro payment
channels to increase the blockchain's
ability to perform transactions more
quickly
moving on to the cons it only supports
Bitcoin the wallet is always volunteered
and it has limits on everything be it
deposits sales and other items
so now we have reached a last crypto
trading platform in our list which is
bisc
Bish is the peer-to-peer cryptocurrency
trading platform that allows individuals
from all over the world to trade a
variety of digital currencies and tokens
customers are not required to complete a
know your customer or kyc identity
verification process and this trading
platform is not restricted to users in
specific jurisdictions it lets users to
buy and sell Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies with a variety of
payment options such as bank wire
transfers ACH transfers and cash
deposits as well
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
Bish currently supports 100 plus
cryptocurrencies for transaction with
transaction price ranging between 0.10
to 0.70 and there is no minimal deposit
or purchase required
now moving on to its pros and cons
this Bish application is available
throughout the world and anyone can use
it it provides a high insecurity and
doesn't require any sort of kyc or ID
verification and it provides almost 50
payment options for crypto transactions
moving on to the cons the speed of the
transactions are pretty low and low
trading values are also possible as it
doesn't consist of any minimal deposit
or purchase also it is not a great
option for active Trading
and with that we have reached the end of
this captivating video on our
cryptocurrency full course we hope you
found it both useful and entertaining do
give this video a thumbs up and share it
with your friends if you have any
questions or need assistance with any of
the topics covered in this video please
feel free to ask away in the comment
section below our team will reach out to
you as soon as possible thank you for
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here